bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat pour notre
émission spéciale autour du débat sur la
réforme des retraites au Sénat dans 30
minutes la route assemblée va commencer
l'examen d'une réforme cruciale pour le
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron une
réforme qui demande aux Français de
travailler plus longtemps pour
équilibrer notre régime de retraite par
répartition allez sénateurs ont 11 jours
pour examiner ce texte et chaque jour de
débat vous pourrez le suivre en direct
sur Public Sénat grâce aux dispositif
spécial que nos équipes ont mises en
place et grâce à nos journalistes qui
sont mobilisés au Palais du Luxembourg
on va aller direction à la salle des
contrats bonjour Alexandre bonjour à
tous c'est effectivement un dispositif
spécial un dispositif exceptionnel que
public Sana met en place pendant 11
jours vous le voyez nos équipes ont
installé un plateau ici même au cœur de
la salle des conférences du Sénat cette
salle qui jouxte l'hémicycle où vont se
dérouler les débats pendant 11 jours et
donc oui à mon micro il y aura pendant
11 jours et des ministres des sénatrices
ordinateur qui viendront réagir jour par
jour à l'actualité de l'examen de la
réforme première invitée dans 10 minutes
Alex avec Roger caroutchi et mon micro
le premier vice-président LR du Sénat
merci beaucoup Quentin et puis nous
serons aussi dans la tribune de
l'hémicycle du Sénat avec aujourd'hui
Mathias arez bonjour Alors Mathias de là
où vous êtes et bien vous pourrez nous
faire sentir l'ambiance de ces premières
heures de débat au Sénat absolument
bonjour Alexandre bonjour à tous ici
nous allons vivre ensemble plus d'une
centaine d'heures de débats sur cette
réforme des retraites et nous allons
suivre pour vous les quelques 4700
amendements qui ont été déposés pour ce
texte l'ambiance devra donc monter
doucement ici dans l'hémicycle plus que
30 minutes maintenant avant les discours
d'ouverture de la discussion générale
ils seront tenus par le ministre du
Travail Olivier dussobe et le ministre
des comptes publics Gabriel Attal on va
tendre l'oreille pour vous fournir tous
les détails ces premiers Alexandre merci
beaucoup Mathias vous pourrez de suivre
dans les moindres détails si on joue de
débat de la réforme des retraites au
Sénat ce sera sur l'antenne de Public
Sénat aussi sur le site internet public
sénat.fr avec des articles de décryptage
des enjeux politiques de cet examen et
puis des articles d'analyse des
amendements qui vont être discutés dans
l'hémicycle donc pour tout comprendre de
cette réforme des retraites c'est aussi
sur public sénat.fr alors pour décrypter
les enjeux de cette première journée de
débat sur la réforme des retraites au
Sénat j'accueille sur ce plateau
Stéphane Vernet bonjour bonjour vous
êtes rédacteur en chef délégué au
journal Ouest-France et j'accueille
également Janick Halimi vous êtes
éditorialiste politique à Stéphane
Vernet ce débat au Sénat sur la réforme
des retraites ça va être un moment
important pour l'avenir politique de
cette réforme
oui mais c'est à dire que je pense
surtout que le moment auquel on va
assister c'est qu'on va avoir un vrai
débat le débat qu'on n'a pas pu avoir à
l'Assemblée nationale on va j'espère la
voir au Sénat c'est à dire que à
l'Assemblée où vous avez eu un son de
manœuvre dilatoire une obstruction
systématique on était quand même très
dans le Grand Guignol et le et la
représentation face aux caméras le
travail sur le fond il a pas eu lieu je
vous rappelle qu'il y a eu deux articles
qui ont été examinés et votés
sur 20 à examiner et le un des enjeux de
ce qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui c'est que
l'article central de toutes ces réforme
c'est l'article 7 celui qui prévoit de
reporter l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite de 62 ans à 64 ans tout le
monde demandait à ce qu'il soit examiné
et syndicats le le l'essentiel la nuque
en tout cas c'est composant de PS PC et
écologistes et en fait ce sont c'est la
France insoumise qui s'est qui s'est
prise dans son propre jeu d'obstruction
avec ils ont amassé les amendements pour
faire obstruction avec l'idée de les
enlever les autres ont enlevé leurs
amendements un moment pour que il puisse
y avoir cette étude de l'article de ce
fameux article 7 et la France insoumise
ne l'a pas fait et en fait elle a elle
s'est tirée une balle dans le pied c'est
à dire que elle a elle a complètement
démonétisé et dévalorisée le travail de
l'Assemblée donc c'est une chance aussi
pour le Sénat de montrer que si sur les
deux assemblées si sur les deux chambres
il y en a bien une qui sert à quelque
chose et qui bosse ces sujets au fond
jusqu'au bout c'est celle-là c'est le
Sénat c'est un enjeu pour le Sénat
d'imprimer ça marque sur cette réforme
des retraites et de permettre ce débat
sur le fond un enjeu pour le Sénat comme
institution vous voulez dire c'est ça
oui comme institution comme institution
oui c'est ça oui oui de toute façon ça
ça correspondrait à la culture que veut
incarner depuis maintenant le début de
la cinquième République
le Sénat c'est à dire non une chambre
qui prend de la distance qui est élu au
suffrage indirect donc loin des des
fièvres hexagone hexagonales comme
dirait le l'historien Michel vinove qui
peut s'emparer comme ça d'une partie
du corps social et de la société donc
oui c'est l'occasion une nouvelle fois
pour le Sénat Senna de montrer que le
débat effectivement est possible et puis
loin du bruit et de la fureur qui a pu
avoir l'Assemblée nationale loin
peut-être aussi de certaines idéologies
que peuvent véhiculer avec comment dire
efficacité ou pas les groupes à
l'Assemblée nationale qui soit de droite
comme de gauche l'autre intérêt aussi de
ce qui pourrait se passer au Sénat c'est
peut-être remettre en tout cas en
apparence et sur ce texte-là en
apparence en tout cas un début d'ordre
au sein des républicains je dis bien en
apparence parce que je pense que la
crise est beaucoup plus profonde et puis
aussi si jamais le texte je m'arrête là
était voté
ça voudrait dire que la procédure va
continuer un peu sur son rythme mais qui
a fait fortes chances pour que le texte
de loi soit voté et donc de ce qui se
passera il pourra avoir des conséquences
sur la mobilisation sociale parce qu'on
sait que si le texte était voté il y a
un risque au regard de ceux qui sont
mobilisés et des opposants à ce que la
CFDT se désolidarise des mobilisations
sociales pas de sa contestation sur le
principe mais de la mobilisation dans
les rues et donc
affaiblissent la contestation sociale
sur les pavés des rues allez on va
retourner voir nos journalistes
mobilisés au Palais du Luxembourg on va
aller dans la tribune de l'hémicycle du
Sénat Mathias Arès qu'elle va être le
programme de cet après-midi pour le
début de cet examen alors accrochez-vous
Alexandre parce que l'après-midi promet
d'être riche dans l'hémicycle que
prévoit l'ordre protocolaire tout
d'abord ce sont messieurs Olivier
dussobe ministre du Travail et Gabriel
Attal ministre des comptes publics qui
vont ouvrir cette discussion générale
dès 14h30 l'objectif présenter la
réforme en longueur et sans limite de
temps ce sera ensuite autour de la
commission saisie sur le fond de prendre
la parole Elizabeth Doisneau rapporteur
pas mal de la commission des affaires
sociales René Paul Savary rapporteur de
la branche vieillesse de cette même
commission et Sylvie Vermeillet
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des finances auront alors
approximativement 25 minutes pour
apporter leur vision sur ce texte à la
suite de quoi faire un peu original
cette discussion générale sera
interrompue car des groupes politiques
ont déposé des motions il va y en avoir
deux aujourd'hui toutes déposer par des
groupes de gauche une motion
d'irrecevabilité et une question
préalable toute de visant à rejeter le
texte d'emblée une parenthèse qui
devrait durer environ une quarantaine de
minutes avant la reprise de la
discussion générale ou président de
groupe et chefs de cils alterneront à la
tribune ce qui devrait nous emmener
jusqu'en début de soirée merci Mathias
pour le programme et Quentin Mathias en
parlait la gauche l'opposition dans la
miss cycle du Sénat va déposer ce qu'on
appelle des motions de quoi s'agit-il
oui on le comprend Alexandre il s'agit
aujourd'hui un peu du tour de chauffe
des bas introductif à la réforme des
retraites on parlera des articles on
parlera des mesures plus tard dans la
semaine mais aujourd'hui et demain matin
ce sont des moments qui sont réservés au
débat introductif et donc aux
discussions de motion il y en a
effectivement deux et qui sont déposés
par la gauche par les communistes et par
effectivement les écologistes et qui
vont venir interrompre le milieu de la
discussion générale aujourd'hui il y
aura une autre motion demain matin une
motion référendaire qui elle va et bien
occuper les sénateurs toute la matinée a
priori ce sont des motions comme cela
qui savent et bien à empêcher le débat
autour de cette réforme selon la gauche
qui souhaite et bien interrompre ses
débats dès le début de l'examen du texte
mais c'est motion ont très peu de
chances d'être voté aujourd'hui ou
demain Alex merci beaucoup Quentin
Stéphane Vernet ça va être aussi et bien
un enjeu à la fois pour la droite
sénatoriale et la gauche etatoriale de
se faire entendre dans ce débat
d'avancer certains marqueurs oui bouchon
et ça va ça en fait c'est à dire que on
parle autour de chauffe c'est aussi
l'occasion de s'offrir une tribune vous
avez la parole pendant un moment vous
pouvez développer votre projet enfin
votre propos mais on sait pertinemment
que ces notions n'ont absolument aucune
chance d'aboutir voilà mais elle peuvent
vous vous posez une ambiance je vous
rappelle qu'à l'Assemblée il y avait
fait unique ça s'était jamais produit
deux motions référendaires présentées
par deux groupes différents la nuque
d'un côté via les communistes et le et
le [__] national qui ont été déposés en
même temps en redonne le règlement de
l'Assemblée vous ne pouvez examiner
qu'une seule motion référendaire par
texte et donc la question c'était de
savoir laquelle il fallait prendre et
comme ça avait été tranché quelques
jours avant en conférence des présidents
enfin je j'adresse mais c'est le le le
choix s'est porté sur la la motion
référendaire de du rassemblement
national parce que ce que ce que le au
tirage au sort ce que contestait ensuite
il y a eu une une troisième motion
référendaire qui a été dégainée juste
avant le début de séance pour créer un
incident et le résultat c'est que ça a
été excusez-moi l'expression elle est un
peu triviale mais ça a été la fête du
slip on a
[Musique]
ce qu'on a vu à l'Assemblée nationale
oui c'est cette première journée et je
pense également les les
suivantes pour une raison essentielle et
c'est pas faire offense aux insoumis
même si on peut
on pourrait leur en faire mais les
insoumis qui ne sont qui sont absents
bien sûr du Sénat comme on le sait ils
n'ont pas de sénateurs en revanche ils
ont un groupe important beaucoup plus
important qui a 5 ans à l'Assemblée
nationale ont voulu faire de
l'obstruction alors si on oublie les
dérapages des uns et des autres leur but
c'était de ne pas justement c'était une
stratégie politique qui était surtout
d'éviter de discuter de du fameux
article 7 encore une fois sur l'âge le
report de l'âge de la retraite parce que
ils craignait que si jamais vu la
majorité qu'il y a en faveur de
l'exécutif à l'Assemblée nationale
peut-être d'ailleurs conforter par les
par une partie DLR l'art cette fameuse
article qui met le feu aux poudres
sociales notamment de de la CFDT aurait
pu être voté et dans ce cas là comme je
le disais
tout à l'heure si cet article est voté
il y a des
l'opposition notamment insoumise donc
qui craignait que encore une fois la
mobilisation dans la rue ne se désamorce
parce que une fois que la réforme est
votée et bien beaucoup de syndicalistes
estiment que la légitimité de la
représentation nationale prime sur la
contestation sociale donc il n'y aura
pas ce genre de d'obstruction au sein de
du Sénat et donc on peut prévoir
effectivement que les débats se passent
de façon plus calme mais ça n'empêche
pas tout de même à mon avis les 12 jours
où les onze jours qui viennent d'être
fortement animés allez on va aller dans
la salle des conférences du Sénat ou
Quentin vous êtes avec le sénateur les
républicains Roger carochi
vice-président du Sénat
l'invitation sur ce plateau ici en
direct de la salle des conférences du
Sénat nous sommes à une quinzaine de
minutes du début de l'examen de la
réforme des retraites ici à la Chambre
haute du parlement comment garantir des
débats à la hauteur de l'exigence
qu'attendent les Français envers ce
débat crucial pour le pays
et par conséquent on sait que le débat
sera de qualité ensuite quand on regarde
même les amendements qui ont été déposés
ce sont des amendements de fond donc on
parlera du fond ouais
4000 700 amendements à examiner en 11
jours vous l'avez vous allez présider
certaines de ces séances ce sont total
100 heures de débats est-ce que c'est
jouable selon vous d'examiner tous ces
amendements
de savoir combien sont déclarésorvables
par les articles 40 et 45 de la
Constitution ensuite
ça dépend de la bonne volonté de chacun
si tous les groupes sont d'accords
de l'article 7 mais il faut que tous les
groupes soient d'accord pour que le 12
nous soyons à la fin du texte oui le
président de séance dispose d'outils
pour empêcher le fait qu'il y ait de
l'obstruction au Sénat de quoi s'agit-il
est-ce que vous pensez si vous vous
présidez un de ces jours où ça va pas
assez vite selon vous vous aurez recours
assez ces articles du règlement du site
je préfère et que tout le monde soit
d'accord pour aller assez vite pour
qu'il n'y ait ni obstruction d'un côté
ni contrainte de l'autre côté ça a
toujours été la tradition Sénat
maintenant s'il devait y avoir de
l'obstruction naturellement il y a un
certain nombre d'armes l'article 38 du
Règlement intérieur du Sénat qui permet
de dire un seul orateur pour un seul
orateur contre ce qui est évidemment
limite sérieusement dans les débats il y
a d'autres éléments le vote bloqué ça
c'est à la main ou la Commission du
gouvernement il y a des éléments mais
c'est pas la tradition au Sénat parce
qu'au Sénat il y a pas tradition
d'obstruction allons sur le fond du
texte Roger carochi elle a droite et le
centre qui vont proposer des mesures en
faveur de l'emploi des seniors avec un
CDI senior par exemple ou encore une
surcote pour les mères et qui ont eu au
moins un enfant l'idée c'est quoi c'est
de rendre plus acceptable socialement
une réforme hautement décrié dans le
pays la réforme est décrié mais parce
qu'elle est d'abord mal expliquée et
parce qu'elle était injuste notamment
pour les carrières longues des femmes
qui peuvent avoir des carrières hachées
qui peuvent évidemment voir leur
trimestre de maternité non comptabilisée
ce qui était totalement anormal donc on
a prévu un certain nombre de
modifications
pour les les maires de famille
l'estimation est aux alentours de 300
millions mais en parallèle
nous avons demandé un certain nombre de
chemins d'économie et puis pardon de
vous dire si sur les maires de famille
ça coûte 300 millions faut pas il faut
dire aussi que pour l'avenir si la
natalité remonte et bien naturellement
on aura plus d'actifs pour payer les
retraites donc la question sur ce débat
c'est 11 jours au Sénat ça va se faire
dans un contexte où il y aura aussi de
mobilisation dans la rue notamment le
jour du 7 mars est-ce que vous le dites
c'est mobilisations vous allez les
écouter ou est-ce qu'il y aura comme ça
quelque chose d'imperméable d'hermétique
entre les deux entre la démocratie
européenne et la démocratie il y a rien
d'hermétique c'est évident que les
parlementaires par définition écoute
l'opinion publique écoute les citoyens
écoute la rue mais écoute la rue
elle a un populaire aussi oh non elle
est pas un populaire partout non non on
allait pas si vite mais une fois que le
texte sera corrigé par le Sénat il sera
beaucoup plus acceptable et à partir de
l'enverra écouter la rue oui être soumis
à la rue non et bien merci merci d'avoir
été notre première invité ici sur ce
plateau installé donc au centre de la
salle des conférences Alex qui juxtent
l'hémicycle ou commence les débats sur
la forme des retraites dans maintenant
13 minutes merci beaucoup Quentin on va
tout de suite voir quels sont les enjeux
politiques de ce débat au Sénat sur la
réforme des retraites avec ses
explications d'Hugo le meunier
se démarquer du tumulte de l'Assemblée
les sénateurs en font leur priorité la
chambre haute se donne 11 jours
d'examens en séance contre neuf au
Palais Bourbon un climat plus apaisé
davantage de temps pour discuter dans
ces conditions la majorité sénatoriale
entend examiner l'ensemble du texte et
nous nous avons une responsabilité parce
que c'est notre mission
parlementaire que d'aller jusqu'au bout
et de sortir si je puis dire par un vote
la majorité de droite et du centre
compte bien amender le texte du
Gouvernement le président de la
République puis la première ministre ont
tout de afficher leur ouverture moi j'ai
noté une volonté du Sénat de voter cette
réforme des retraites il y a des
demandes d'amélioration on va évidemment
les examiner les républicains ont fixé
un certain nombre d'impératif sur
l'équilibre financier ou une surcote
pour les maires de familles notamment la
droite se s'est en position de force
pour reprendre la main sur les
propositions j'ai bien senti que le
gouvernement centraux ouverte de toute
façon il y a pas le choix
sans cette ligne là qui est une ligne
rouge pour nous sans ce point-là jamais
nous ne voterons une réforme ni
maintenant ni au CMP ni après en
l'absence de la France insoumise au
Sénat la gauche fait savoir qu'elle ne
compte pas jouer l'obstruction à la
manière des députés nous voulons un
débat de fond sur l'article 7 et nous
voulons un vote sur l'article 7
globalement nous voulons que les 20
articles soient abordés où vont
travailler au fond nous allons
travailler avec le temps nécessaire et
si le gong tombe et bien ce sera de la
propre responsabilité du gouvernement la
gauche veut donc avancer sur le texte et
ainsi marquer son opposition mais le
groupe n'exclut pas de ralentir les ATS
en fin de discussion pour s'opposer au
vote finale de la réforme
Stéphane Vernet on a entendu Bruno
Retailleau le président du groupe les
républicains au Sénat dire finalement le
gouvernement n'a pas le choix d'accepter
les modifications qui vont être
proposées par la droite sénatoriale ce
sont les sénateurs LR qui vont au final
écrire cette réforme des retraites mais
il a raison c'est en tout cas c'est eux
qui ont les clés en main c'est à dire
que il faut quand même comprendre il
faut comprendre une chose très simple
c'est que la précédente réforme des
retraites la fameuse réforme à points
etc avait été avait été pensé par
Monsieur Pisani et dans le premier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron voilà donc
la fameuse réforme à points etc elle
était vous aviez un Laurent Berger qui
était le patron de la CFDT qui était
très favorable à ce système là il a été
abandonné dans les conditions qu'on sait
on repart avec un nouveau système et le
nouveau système qui est présenté c'est
plus celui qui a la faveur de la CFDT
c'est celui qui c'est celui qu'en fait
le Sénat
inventé quand Bruno retaille au dit
c'est pas le gouvernement qui nous
demande de voter sa réforme c'est c'est
le gouvernement qui qui veut faire
adopter notre réforme il a raison et le
la réforme des retraites telles qu'on
est en train de la discuter aujourd'hui
elle a été inventée par le Sénat par le
truchement du compromis et compromis qui
ont été bâtis entre une majorité où vous
avez décentrices et des LR et en gros
vous aviez deux visions de vision
concomitante une qui consistait à dire
tout ça est paramétrique il faut
augmenter l'âge de départ à la retraite
c'était plutôt les républicains et les
centrices qui disaient non non il faut
il faut il faut jouer sur la la durée du
nombre de d'annuités et ensemble ils ont
inventé un système hybride qui joue sur
les deux paramètres ça fait 4 ans que le
Sénat chaque plfssr comment propose de
demander d'introduire cette cette
réforme des retraites ça fait que ça
faisait 4 ans qu'elle était rejetée mais
aujourd'hui la vérité c'est que le
gouvernement la réforme qui est proposée
c'est celle que a inventé par le
l'alliance de des décentrices et des
républicains depuis quatre ans et elle
ne pourra passer si elle devait passer
que par le vote de cette majorité de
cette majorité sénatoriale et donc oui
Bruno Retailleau a raison c'est-à-dire
que non seulement c'est leur réforme et
en plus ils ont toutes les clés et comme
ils sont en position de force ils ont
profite pour demander à ce qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'ajouts et moi je pense
qu'effectivement le gouvernement n'aura
pas d'autre choix que de passer par les
fourches codes de ces revendications
sinon cette réforme sera pas votée et il
ne peut pas le gouvernement ne peut pas
reculer ils veulent absolument qu'elle
soit votée donc ils m'ont dit oui ils
vont s'y plier Janic aliments vous êtes
d'accord à la droite territorielle est
en position de force pour faire adopter
ces modifications sur cette réforme de
retraite par rapport au gouvernement ça
dépend d'abord de je suis d'accord avec
Stéphane Vernet on l'a dit on l'a répété
c'est vrai que la première réforme
systémique a été abandonnée par Emmanuel
Macron et que c'est après sa seconde
élection ou pendant la campagne il
prenait quand même les 65 ans donc sous
la pression après concertation avec les
LR qui l'a donné qu'il a accouché si je
puis dire du projet dans sa globalité
avec les 64 ans
les invités etc maintenant est-ce que
c'est le projet c'est de des sénateurs
tels qui se présente aujourd'hui qui
devra être adopté ou alors les sénateurs
ne ne voteront pas c'est pas sûr du tout
parce que déjà tout d'abord la procédure
va continuer parce que même si le Sénat
ne vote pas il y aura une CMP donc les
navettes vont reprendre avec
l'Assemblée nationale et si c'est vrai
que la majorité macronienne au sens
large du terme qui n'est qu'une majorité
relative a besoin des LR dans leur
globalité pour faire passer la loi il
n'a pas besoin seulement que DLR du
Sénat ils ont besoin aussi DLR de
l'Assemblée nationale or les LR on le
sait ne sont pas du tout d'accord entre
eux on va pas revenir notamment sur pour
les mises à l'écart et les les pas de
côté important de Pradier de Monsieur
Pradier qui a été démissionné si je puis
dire évincé de son poste de numéro de
DLR mais par exemple à écouter les
sénateurs alors que les députés assistés
sur la les carrières longues la les
sénateurs c'est pas ça les sénateurs
c'est plutôt les femmes bon qui sont les
statuts des femmes et des mers qui le
mettent en avant les les les pourquoi
pas les les comment dire la majorité n'y
est pas contre elle est députée ne sont
pas contents non plus mais ils mettent
aussi en avant en tout cas certains
d'entre eux l'accélération de la
suppression des régimes sociaux et là je
peux
spéciaux par an là il est clair que
l'ensemble des LR n'est pas du tout sur
cette même longueur cette même longueur
d'onde le
Gérard arraché encore dans le Figaro ce
matin reprenez les termes de
l'amendement de des sénateurs au projet
de loi de d'il y a 4 ans qui part d'une
extinction progressive c'est ce que
disait également
Valérie Pécresse pendant sa compagne à
la présidentielle en insistant sur le
fait que la suppression des régimes
spéciaux était une priorité secondaire
donc tout ça pour vous dire que la
source projet de loi oui les LR sont
essentielles pour l'exécutif et pour la
majorité mais toutes les revendications
si je puis dire des sénateurs déjà ne
font pas l'unanimité au sein des LR donc
c'est pas à prendre ou à laisser on
devra mettre de l'eau dans son bain
allez on va parler un peu de la gauche
on va aller en salle les conférences du
Sénat ou quand un Calmet est avec Rémi
Féraud à sénateur socialiste de Paris
Alex effectivement nous sommes ici sur
ce plateau installé par la rédaction
publique Sénat au cœur de la salle des
conférences pour suivre au plus près les
débats qui vont s'ouvrir dans maintenant
4 minutes et 30 secondes dans
l'hémicycle qui se trouve juste ici à
quelques pas d'ici et donc effectivement
parler de cette réforme j'accueille
de Paris un mot sur ces amendements on
en compte donc plus de 4700 à examiner
en 11 jours d'après les calculs de la
réaction publique c'est là 3300 viennent
de la gauche quel est votre stratégie à
gauche ça va être d'empêcher d'aller au
bout du texte et qu'on n'est jamais de
vote sur l'ensemble du de la réforme des
retraites c'est ça ça nous verrons notre
stratégie c'est la combativité pas
l'obstruction la combativité
d'accord parce que tous les amendements
que nous déposons sont des amendements
de fond je crois que juste avant sur
votre plateau Roger caoutchi le
reconnaissait lui-même et l'amendement
avec des virgules ou des feuilles de
salade
il n'y a pas d'amendement qui soit
cosmétique ou de pure prétexte ça non
mais par ailleurs si le Sénat comme
l'assemblée avant elle n'a pas le temps
nécessaire suffisant pour discuter cette
loi la responsabilité en reviendra au
gouvernement par l'utilisation de
l'article 47 1 de la Constitution il
faut être clair sur la 20 jours à
l'Assemblée nationale 15 régionales
étant de débat sur les plfssr qu'est-ce
qu'on a ici exactement cette méthode du
plfssr est tout à fait baroque et
n’était absolument pas ce que le
gouvernement aurait dû ait pu faire il
l'a fait pour limiter le temps de débat
pour empêcher le Parlement de faire
pleinement son travail donc nous nous
décidons de faire quand même pleinement
notre travail et nous verrons bien
comment avant la discussion de la loi
Rémy frérot la droite et le centre vote
un tel amendement à la loi de finances
de la sécurité sociale tous les ans
depuis 2018 vous pouvez pas la reprocher
lorsque les textes sur la fnderstruck
vient avec les mêmes mesures que celles
qu'ils vote d'adopter le texte mais
c'est d'abord c'est le gouvernement qui
propose ce texte c'est pas à la droite
sénatoriale et en effet le gouvernement
je sais pas ce qui reste dû en même
temps de droite et de gauche de Macron
aujourd'hui ils se font simplement au
gouvernement le relais d'une proposition
de la droite sénatoriale faite depuis
des années ensuite il y a aussi des
éléments sur les carrières longues sur
les femmes etc sur lequel la droite veut
porter des amendements certains qui
peuvent améliorer la réforme d'autres
qui peuvent l'aggra on se positionnera
sur chaque point Rémy frérot vous êtes
membre de la commission des finances du
Sénat on le dit il manque 10 à 12
milliards un moyen terme dans le système
des retraites par répartition vous voyez
pas ce problème il faut pas qu'on fasse
quelque chose à ce manque dans les
budgets nous ne nions pas le fait que à
l'horizon 2030 il y a un déséquilibre
budgétaire dans la retraite est-ce que
cette réforme résout le déséquilibre
budgétaire pas complètement est-ce qu'il
y a urgence même le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites dit que non
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres sources de
financement notamment dans une société
qui soit plus juste en mettant à
contribution le capital les entreprises
oui c'est possible donc une autre
réforme des retraites est tout à fait
possible alors pendant 11 jours on va
voir des amendements de la droite et du
centre notamment et bien sur les des
mesures en faveur de l'emploi des
seniors ou encore pour les femmes ayant
eu au moins un enfant un CDI senior
ainsi pour les plus soixante ans une
surcote pour les mères le retour de
l'index senior toutes ces mesures qui
sont une petite sociale d'après la
majorité la droite et du centre est-ce
que vous allez les voter je ne pense pas
parce qu'il ne faudrait pas que en
votant ces mesures nous donnions
l'impression d'accepter l'ensemble de la
réforme par ailleurs ils ont proposé
d'autres qui aggravent la réforme pour
introduire davantage de capitalisation
par exemple ce qui montre bien que leur
esprit n'est pas forcément de protéger
le régime par répartition donc nous nous
prononcerons d'abord sur les articles du
projet de loi et sur nos amendements et
bien merci merci Rémy frérot d'être venu
réagir dans ce sur ce plateau à
installer Alex au cœur de la salle des
conférences du Sénat nous sommes
maintenant à moins d'une minute du début
de cet examen Alex et oui moins d'une
minute le débat va bientôt commencer à
Stéphane Vernet un mot sur la stratégie
de la gauche sénatoriale le but c'est
d'aller et bien et de débattre sur les
articles de fonds notamment les 64 ans
et puis si les débats sont un peu
ralentis à la fin et qu'il n'y a pas de
vote et bien ce serait tant mieux pour
la gauche oui alors ils vont les
ralentir un peu aussi au début parce que
je reviens à ce que disait Janique au
début c'est à dire que il y a l'idée
qu'il faudrait faut pas coller l'article
7 soit examiné et voté avant la
manifestation du 7 mars donc en fait la
stratégie c'est de c'est de prolonger
les choses pour être sûr que la première
journée de remobilisation et lieu en
dehors de ce contexte là et ensuite le
l'idée c'est de faire tomber de retirer
un certain nombre de ses amendements
pour pouvoir
passer à l'examen de l'article 7 Patrick
Kanner disait à votre antenne tout à
l'heure que qui les ont la volonté
d'examiner les vins articles et y
compris l'article 7 et en fait le truc
c'est ce que vous voulez faire ou c'est
ce que devait faire ce qui était censé
faire la Nupe à l'Assemblée et qui n'a
pas eu lieu parce que la France
insoumise a joué cavalier seul en
bloquant tout et juste par rapport à ce
que disait le député le sénateur pendant
Rémy frérot le gouvernement n'a pas
choisi de passer par un plfssr pour pour
empêcher les débats au Parlement ils
sont passés par un plfssr par calcul oui
c'est vrai parce qu'il savait très bien
que la la France insoumise allait jouer
la carte de construction à fond jusqu'au
bout ça a été une manière de leur couper
l'herbe sous le pied en pouvant dégainer
le 47 le 47 1 voilà et donc c'est de la
petite tambouille c'est de la cuisine
politicienne mais c'est c'est cette
bonne guerre à l'arrivée j'ai envie de
vous dire l'objectif de la gauche
territoriale c'est de faire résonner la
mobilisation sociale emmener par les
syndicats dans la rue elle a fait
raisonner dans l'hémicycle oui
absolument parce que on se souvient que
l'ensemble des syndicats et notamment la
CGT la CFDT avait énormément critiqué la
politique d'obstruction menait notamment
par la consommation
du président du Sénat général archer au
plateau de l'hémicycle de la Haute
Assemblée Gérard l'archet qui va donc
présider cette séance pour le début de
l'examen de la réforme des retraites au
Sénat plus précisément du projet loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale c'est parti pour 11 jours de
débats ici au Sénat à la fois à la
semaine le weekend le jour et puis
jusqu'à tard le soir pour examiner plus
de 4700 amendements déposés par les
sénateurs sur cette réforme des
retraites c'est un débat que beaucoup de
Français attendent les sénateurs ont
promis qu'il y aura des échanges
constructifs sur les différents articles
de cette réforme des retraites et
notamment sur l'article 7 qui reporte
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à 64
ans Gérard Larcher sonne la cloche
du jour appelle la discussion du projet
de loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 dont le Sénat
est saisi en application de l'article
47-1 alinéa 2 de la Constitution et
je crois que je suis
j'ai demandé un rappel au règlement de
madame la présidente du groupe
communistes républicains citoyen madame
assassin
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues à l'orée
du débat de la plus grande importance
qui engage l'avenir de notre peuple je
souhaite affirmer ici quelques principes
qui vont guider l'action de notre groupe
et formuler une exigence nous exigeons
avec 90% des actifs les millions de
personnes qui manifestent et l'ensemble
des syndicats le retrait de ce projet de
loi il est donc
article 42 chapitres 14 du règlement
monsieur il est donc pour nous un devoir
de manifester notre opposition la plus
vive dans cette émission qui ne peut
être en dehors du réel et ne pas
entendre l'exigence d'un grand débat
dans le pays ne pas entendre la colère
froide sérieuse mais déterminée et
massive le débat doit avoir lieu et
notre groupe comme les autres groupes de
gauche utilisera tous les moyens
constitutionnels pour relayer ici les
préoccupations populaires je le dis
monsieur le Président les moyens
constitutionnels le droit d'abonnement
la liberté de parole et d'expression des
parlementaires le droit d'opposition en
amont
même principe de la démocratie la
sérénité la force sont de notre côté par
contre une certaine fébrilité semble
agiter certains au point de menacer
d'utiliser des moyens de procédure pour
accélérer encore un débat déjà tronqué
par l'application du carreaux de 1
monsieur le Président du Sénat nous
appelons donc certains à la raison
n'ayons pas peur du débat et surtout
ensemble écoutons le peuple je vous
demande donc solennellement d'agir pour
que nos droits constitutionnels soient
pleinement respectées de mettre un terme
aux menaces express à l'encontre de
notre expression avant même le début de
la discussion le gouvernement n'a pas
voulu d'un vrai débat il a détourné la
Constitution pour cela comme je vous le
démontrerai dans un instant présentant
une motion d'irrecevabilité le Sénat sa
majorité son président ne peuvent
accompagner monsieur Macron et son
gouvernement dans cette partition
dangereuse pour la démocratie
[Applaudissements]
générale je vais donner la parole au
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion Monsieur Olivier du soft
lever la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur général
monsieur le rapporteur madame le
rapporteur pour avis messieurs les
ministres chers Franck et Cher Gabriel
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
y sommes nous y sommes à nouveau si je
puis dire et nous y sommes enfin je suis
particulièrement heureux de vous
présenter cette réforme et de soumettre
ce texte à votre discussion cette
réforme des retraites j'y crois
profondément j'y crois parce qu'elle
sort d'abord notre système par
répartition d'un état structurellement
déficitaire et avec cette réforme nous
permettons de ne pas faire peser cette
responsabilité sur les générations
futures alors que nous savons tous à la
lecture des rapports du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites que dès 2027
le déficit annuel du système de retraite
sera de 12,5 milliards d'euros par an
pour atteindre 20 milliards d'euros par
an en 2035 et 25 milliards d'euros par
an en 2040
dans un peu plus de 10 ans si nous ne
faisons rien le déficit cumulé et donc
la dette sera alourdi de 150 milliards
d'euros cela nous oblige et notamment
tout au long des débats que nous ouvrons
de rester extrêmement attentif à cet
objectif d'équilibre et le retour à
l'équilibre du système des retraites
cette réforme j'y crois aussi parce
qu'elle rend plus juste notre système de
retraite en répondant à de très longues
attentes des Françaises et des Français
et j'y crois enfin parce que c'est tout
simplement une promesse tenue celle de
réformer les retraites et avec elle de
continuer à transformer le pays et notre
modèle social et je le dis tout en
soulignant que croire à cette réforme
n'empêcher évidemment pas d'entendre les
contestations je n'oublie pas que ceux
qui ont élu le président de la
République ne l'ont pas tous fait pour
soutenir cette promesse là d'abord
certains ont voté pour lui pour cette
réforme d'autres ont voté pour les
malgré cette réforme et d'autres encore
ont voté contre lui à cause de cette
même réforme
cependant est tout au couteau tout au
long de la campagne présidentielle cette
réforme n'a jamais été un projet caché
elle était assumée elle a été portée
annoncée par le président de la
République et par toute la majorité lors
des élections législatives elle
s'inscrit dans le droit cligne des
engagements pris depuis 2017 cette ligne
qui fait du travail la meilleure et la
plus forte des réponses apportées aux
difficultés de notre pays c'est
également vrai pour retrouver
l'équilibre du système de retraite et
puisse encore quand nous considérons que
le travail est la meilleure des
politiques pour plus d'autonomie de
dignité et pour lutter contre la
pauvreté c'est ce que le président de la
République a construit réformes après
réformes depuis 2017 et que nous voulons
ainsi poursuivre
dans la série des réformes déjà
nombreuses notre système de retraite
c'est très forme ne fait pas exception
bien au contraire sur plusieurs points
elle est d'abord difficile difficile car
vous savez comme moi la complexité de ce
sujet la complexité de notre système de
retraite rendue plus opaque à chaque
fois qu'on la modifié et qui aujourd'hui
cash d'innombrables imperfections sous
chacun de ces détails un perfection que
l'on découvre en avançant et personne ne
peut véritablement en réalité croire ou
même se vanter d'en avoir fait le tour
c'est pourquoi réformer notre système de
retraite et toujours une gageure
toujours été cela le reste une cageur
que nous devons conjuguer nos priorités
avec toujours plus de complexité de
complexité et souvent d'inégalité même
un funambule n'y verrait pas un chemin
aisé et en vérité puisque je parle de
chemin le seul chemin que je connaisse
pour aborder cette réforme c'est celui
du débat et du dialogue républicain
d'abord par la concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux et les forces
politiques du pays qui ont répondu à
notre appel et permis d'emprunter ce
chemin
cela n'a évidemment pas permis surmonter
tous les désaccords notamment sur l'âge
de la durée de cotisation mais sur
d'autres points nous avons su acter des
avancées que certains jugent
insuffisants d'autres excessives je
pense à l'emploi des seniors aux
carrière longue mais toutes ces avancées
sont aussi frites cette concertation
elles sont autant de preuves il en faut
que le débat la discussion sont toujours
féconds et que le consensus est toujours
possible quand on veut bien lui laisser
une chance
en réalité parler des retraites est
présenté cette réforme devant vous c'est
aussi regarder les choses en face et
éviter toute forme de déni quand on
demande aux Français travailler deux ans
le plus même progressivement même en
tenant compte de la pénibilité des
carrières longues c'est demander un
effort aux Français un effort pour
assister pour sauver notre système de
retraite par répartition un effort pour
financer de nouveaux droits mais cela
reste un effort et il faut aussi dire
que demander un effort de plus c'est
parfois aussi bousculé des projets de
vie et en fait parler des retraites
c'est parler du rapport des Français à
leur travail alors carrière c'est parler
de leur vie de leur famille de leurs
aspirations j'ai eu un maintes reprises
l'occasion de rappeler combien est
difficile l'exercice qui accompagne un
départ en retraite liquider sa pension
peut parfois avoir l'air d'un solde de
tout compte et l'administration vous
demande finalement de faire le point de
retracer de reconstituer votre carrière
et de se retourner sur sa vie qui n'est
pas toujours une chose facile pour
certains sont bons souvenirs pour
d'autres des moments plus contrastés et
la retraite peut arriver comme une
délivrance ou comme le moment d'un
rappel de cette mémoire vive et donc
c'est aussi à ce titre que cette réforme
question notre rapport au travail au
sens que nous donnons au travail
question qui que se passe pardon de plus
en plus de Français et parfois dans son
angoisse c'est donc bien comme ministre
du travail conscient ce rapport
personnel à l'existence que le sujet
qu'on va que je veux vous présenter
cette réforme et en débattre avec vous
les prochains jours elle s'inscrit dans
la suite de mon action ministère du
Travail en posant quelques fondations à
des chantiers qui nous attendent encore
elle continue de poser les bases une
nouvelle société du travail d'abord
impulsée par les lois pouvoir d'achat
pour n'en rester qu'à ce qu'aucun canard
débuté en 2022 par la réforme du marché
du travail et chantier qui sera prolongé
d'ici peu avec un nouveau projet de loi
nous souhaitons ambitieux pour l'emploi
le travail la formation avec comme
objectif le paiement en réalité toutes
ces réformes en tant commun même
objectif que je viens dénoncer le plein
emploi pour tous mais aussi le bon
emploi pour le plus grand nombre
c'est cet objectif qui requiert toute
notre responsabilité et tout notre
courage
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
dis aussi à cette tribune pour souligner
la complexité la complexité de
l'exercice et le fait que toute réforme
des retraites est difficile je dis en
ayant bien en tête qui s'y même vous
avez régulièrement éprouvé le fait que
décider de telles réformes c'est
s'exposer à la critique à la
contestation c'est aussi faire preuve de
courage et faire cette réforme c'est
aussi avoir le courage de l'amener et
d'affronter les difficultés inhérentes à
cette entreprise d'affronter les
difficultés que d'autres gouvernement
d'autres majorité avant nous n'ont pas
nécessairement eu au fil du temps et qui
nous invite aujourd'hui à agir et agir
vite nous le faisons nous avançons nous
assumons cette difficulté la nécessité
aussi de partager les contraintes les
contraintes budgétaires notamment qui
pèsent sur notre état et notre système
de protection sociale
j'ai eu la grande chance d'être mère
député ministre de la Fonction publique
puis du budget et s'il y a bien une
chose qui m'a été rappelée par
l'exercice de chacune de ces fonctions
sans équivoque et sans nuance c'est bien
que les équipes budgétaires font de
notre système et détermine notre
capacité à agir et puis son corps va
permettre à ceux qui nous succèdent de
continuer à dessiver à décider
souverainement pour eux-mêmes c'est une
certitude cette attachement à
l'équilibre budgétaire et je sais que
vous êtes très nombreux à la partager
comme vous et avec mon collègue Gabriel
Attal ministre délégué au compte public
j'en saurai le garant nous en serons les
garants bien entendu et nous le savons
les moyens ne sont pas une fin et
vouloir sortir un système du déficit
pour le réformer ne signifie pas que
l'objet unique de la réforme serait cet
équilibre mais je le répète à nouveau
toutes les interprétations du monde ne
suffiront pas à contourner un constat
simple autour du caractère structurel du
déficit de notre système de retraite
c'est vrai pour les 25 prochaines années
avec une moyenne déficitaire quel que
soit la convention et le scénario retenu
par le corps et en empruntant ces mots
aux auteurs du rapport je le cite à
l'instant ce souci exclusivement
d'évolution des dépenses sont préoccuper
des ressources qui les permettent n'est
pas une vision alternative ça n'est pas
une alternative parmi d'autres c'est
assumer une forme d'incurie financière
certains par ailleurs quand ils
reconnaissent l'existence d'un déficit
parviennent encore en sa satisfaire ou à
le relativiser et pour le coup c'est
vouloir renvoyer nos responsabilités aux
prochaines générations le prix du denim
quand on parle de retraite c'est la
trahison des générations qui n'ont pas
encore voix au chapitre pour décider
pour elle-même c'est aussi ouvrir la
voie dénaturation tôt ou tard de nos
systèmes de retraite les plus
protecteurs notre système qui protège
les plus fragiles qui réduit les
inégalités et qui garantit la solidarité
en dégénération finalement
nier ce déficit ni la nécessité de
l'équilibre c'est peut-être myope et
penser que le présent mérite de
déverrouiller l'avenir
ce que nous préférons pour nos retraites
c'est effectivement et je l'ai dit
demander un effort à ceux qui le peuvent
comme la majorité sanitoriale le propose
d'ailleurs depuis de nombreuses années
ainsi le choix qu'il neutre et de faire
que l'âge légal de départ sera ainsi
relevé progressivement pour atteindre 63
ans et 3 mois à la fin du quinquennat
puis 64 ans en 2030 nous accélérons
aussi la mise en oeuvre de la réforme
Touraine afin d'atteindre 43 ans durée
de cotisation à la fin du quinquennat et
nous menons ces deux entreprises en
maintenant l'âge d'annulation de la
décote à 67 ans nous faisons ce choix un
moment de notre histoire ou le taux de
chômage ne cesse de baisser ou le taux
d'emploi bat des records et avec cette
certitude que par le travail par
l'important c'est l'augmentation du
volume de travail dans la société nous
pouvons apporter les réponses les plus
efficaces et les plus justes nous le
faisons aussi en sachant reconnaître au
Sénas qui a été initialement conçu au
Sénat et je dis devant madame la
Présidente de la Commission comme devant
monsieur le rapporteur en pensant à ce
traditionnel amendement adopté avec la
volonté d'une réforme de courage et
d'équilibre qui ont à agir sur ces deux
leviers à la fois et la durée de
cotisation sans jamais nier la réalité
de l'effort demandé je veux aussi dire
devant vous qu'au-delà des initiatives
de votre assemblée il y a eu évidemment
avant que nous soyons réunis pour cette
réforme d'autres réformes des retraites
avant celles-ci et quel que soit le
gouvernement elles ont tout en commun
deux choses d'abord avoir relevé l'âge
et où la durée de cotisation pour le
premier point et ne jamais avoir été
remise en cause quel que soit les
alternances une fois qu'elles ont été
adoptées elles ont toutes en forme eu
comme priorité le retour à l'équilibre
financier puisque la création de
nouveaux droits et c'est peut-être sur
ce dernier point que cette réforme se
distingue avec cette volonté d'améliorer
le système mais aussi de financer
massivement des nouveaux droits dans une
ampleur sans précédent puisque nous
demandons de travailler plus pour
produire plus en retour nous
retrouverons l'équilibre et nous
financerons ces nouveaux droits je les
dis là aussi inlassablement améliorer
sans équilibrer serait irresponsable et
équilibrer sans améliorer serait injuste
et c'est pourquoi nous voulons faire les
deux
de fait sur les 18 les 18 milliards
d'euros que génèrent la mesure d'âge en
2030 un tiers c'est-à-dire 6 milliards
d'euros sont consacrés des mesures de
justice et de solidarité c'est
d'ailleurs précisément ce qu'ils font la
justification d'une telle réforme dans
un budget rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale puisque l'effet des différentes
mesures en dépense comment recettes
soient les branches vieillesse sur les
branches accident du travail à maladies
professionnelles justifie pleinement le
recevabilité dans ce pays FSS au titre
de leur impact sur les comptes sociaux
de 2023
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
dit peut-être un peu vite tout à l'heure
que cette réforme est une évidence mais
il est vrai que c'est évident c'est
parfois contesté heureusement pour nous
qu'il a défendons il n'y a pas de
meilleur moyen pour s'en convaincre que
de faire le tour rapidement des
alternatives qui lui sont opposés
alternative qui sortent toutes à un mur
de contradiction certains ont proposé
dans une nostalgie qui nous trompent
personne de revenir à la retraite à 60
ans mais sans toucher au 43 dernités
pour avoir le taux plein c'est un
comprendre ça t'a pensé que le projet
derrière cela est de mettre les Français
au travail le plus tôt possible ou leur
proposer un système qui soit une machine
à décolle une machine à petite pension
et donc une machine à pauvreté d'autres
proposent de revenir à 60 ans avec 40
années comme 20 ans 20 ans en arrière en
diminuant la durée de cotisation c'est
en réalité nous condamner collectivement
à chercher 85 milliards d'euros de
financement chaque année bon courage
pour cette entreprise à moins de vouloir
ruiner un quinquennat de restauration de
notre compétitivité à moins de vouloir
peser sur le pouvoir d'achat des
Français à moins de vouloir asseoir
notre système sur l'imposition de
profits aléatoire je ne vois pas quel
est l'avenir raisonnable d'un tel projet
mortifère qui a d'ailleurs été critiqué
encore cette semaine par une partie de
ceux-là même qui en font la proposition
d'autres contradictions sont en réalité
plus grave car elles disent beaucoup du
manque de sérieux des projets
alternatifs nier la réalité des déficits
tout en prévoyant des dizaines de
milliards d'euros de recettes en plus
pour y répondre ou encore penser
défendre l'égalité en défendant les
régimes spéciaux vous l'avez compris
nous n'en prendrons pas assez schéma
aussi escarpak sans issus et c'est donc
une réforme d'équilibre une réforme
équilibrée qui répartit l'effort que
nous demandons de la manière la plus
juste possible
la réforme que nous présentons est
d'abord une réforme soucieuse de justice
travailler plus longtemps oui mais pas
pour tout le monde et pas de la même
manière nous allons conserver et
améliorer le dispositif des carrières
longues en le rendant plus juste plus
lisible en élargissant aussi aux
périodes de congé parental nous
apportons également une réponse au
carrières très longues en permettant au
travailleur et en commencer à vendre 18
ans de partir 4 ans avant l'âge légal
nous le faisons en préservant les
dispositifs déjà prévus pour soyons
débuter avant 20 ans et si vous
l'acceptez bien sûr nous vous proposons
d'inclure ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 21 ans comme l'a évoqué
la première ministre devant l'Assemblée
nationale ces améliorations ne pourront
pas pour autant dénaturer le système
dans le principe fondamental et que la
durée de cotisation est un minimum un
plancher sans jamais avoir été un
plafond nous vous proposons un système
plus juste qui est aussi un système qui
prend mieux en compte les travailleurs
les plus fragiles les victimes
d'accident et maladies professionnelles
ainsi les travailleurs handicapés
pourront toujours partir à la retraite à
55 ans et les travailleurs invéliers
d'où il n'a percevront toujours une
retraite à taux plein dès 62 ans comme
aujourd'hui dans le même temps
maintenant le qui de départ anticipé à
50 ans pour les salariés exposés à
l'amiante avec ce texte nous vous
proposons aussi de mettre à profit cette
opportunité pour compléter les lois
duchaseigne du nom du président du
groupe communiste à l'Assemblée
nationale en particulier la première en
considérant comme complète la carrière
des exploitants agricoles qui auraient
été interrompu avant son terme pour une
aptitude ou invalidité cette condition
d'une carrière complète et que c'est
exigée pour bénéficier de la pension
minimale et l'aménagement proposé dans
ce texte permettra ainsi à 45 45 000
exploitants à la retraite de plus dans
bénéficier avec une revalorisation
d'environ 80 euros par mois concernant
les aidons nous créons une assurance
vieillesse pour les aidants qui viendra
compenser les interruptions de carrière
par l'attribution de droits de nouveau
et nous veillons ainsi à tenir compte
des particularités des parcours comme de
la difficulté des métiers exercés
nous voulons aussi avec cette réforme
créer de nouveaux droits et faire de
cette réforme une réforme de progrès
nous entendons donc améliorer la prise
en compte de la pénibilité et notamment
l'usure liée aux conditions d'exercice
de certains métiers l'accès les droits
acquis avec le compte professionnel des
prévention seront considérablement
renforcés avec un abaissement des seuils
avec une meilleure prise en compte des
polyexposés avec la création de nouveaux
utilisations possibles comme un congé de
reconversion afin d'éviter l'enfermement
dans des métiers difficiles sans perdre
en rémunération nous demanderons aussi
aux bronches de négocier des accords de
prévention l'usure professionnelle pour
les métiers identifiés comme difficiles
par les instances de la sécurité sociale
notamment la bronche à TMP afin de tenir
compte de l'exposition aux critères
ergonomique de part de charge lourdes de
posture pénible ou de vibrations et pour
accompagner ce suivi pour financer les
mesures des accords de prévention nous
créerons un fond d'investissement dans
la prévention l'usure professionnelle
doté d'un milliard d'euros sur les cinq
prochaines années
pour les travailleurs les plus exposés à
la pénibilité nous voulons aussi
renforcer le suivi médical à compter de
45 ans pour garantir la possibilité de
départ d'anticiper quand c'est
nécessaire mais aussi avec une visite à
61 ans et entre les deux un rythme de
visite défini par les branches
professionnelles et par le dialogue
social cette réforme est donc une
promesse à celles et ceux qui ont des
métiers difficiles de partir en
meilleure santé et nous voulons ajouter
à ces progrès sur la prise en compte de
l'usure de la prévention de l'usure
d'autres progrès notamment pour ce qui
concerne les petites pensions ainsi
conformément à l'engagement du président
de la République nous revaloriserons le
100 euros la retraite minimale de nos
compatriotes qui ont eu une carrière
complète au niveau du SMIC pour les
retraités de demain comme ceux
d'aujourd'hui comme l'a dit le président
de la République depuis sa campagne et
comme je dis depuis le début cette
mesure concerne les carrières
complètement cotisées complètes à taux
plein et j'insiste sur ce point car il
s'agit non seulement d'une mesure forte
pour valoriser le travail mais aussi
d'une défense même de la nature de notre
système
la valorisation du travail d'une part
qui ne doit pas se confondre avec une
politique de minima sociaux car comme
j'explique aussi à ceux qui soulève
cette question et qui comprennent
l'argument on ne peut pas imaginer un
système de retraite qui distribuerait
des pensions très supérieures au salaire
perçu pendant la carrière et par
ailleurs la défense de la nature de
notre système car ça serait entretenu
c'est important pardon d'entretenir une
scène différence entre ce qui relève de
l'assurance contributive et du minimum
de pension la retraite est une assurance
le minimum vieillesse est un minimum
social ce sont deux instruments
différents pour deux objectifs distincts
avec cette revalorisation environ un
million 800 000 des retraités actuels
bénéficieront d'une revalorisation du
SMIC et pour la moitié d'entre eux
c'est-à-dire 900 000 cette
revalorisation sera comprise entre 70 et
100 euros pour les futurs retraités il y
en a 800 000 par an ce sont 200 000
retraités qui bénéficieront d'une
pension meilleure grâce à ce système de
pension minimale que sans la réforme
beaucoup l'avait dit depuis 20 ans
lorsque le principe des 85% du SMIC a
été inscrit dans la loi mais aucune
majorité aucun gouvernement de l'avait
fait personne n'avait prévu de système
d'indexation c'est ce à quoi nous
voulons apporter une réponse enfin cette
réforme est une réforme d'équité et j'en
viens à la question des régimes spéciaux
ceci ont leur histoire ils avaient leur
raison d'être mais pour la plupart
d'entre eux ne se justifie plus mettre
un terme à ces différences dans notre
système à hérité au fil du temps c'est
aussi avoir le courage que peu ont eu
avant s'agit d'effacer des différences
de Venus incompréhensibles et faire
preuve de responsabilité personne ne
comprend plus pourquoi des agents de
conduite par temps moyenne avec un peu
plus de 56 ans en région parisienne
alors que c'est 62 ans dans d'autres
régions nous devons dans cette
entreprise de fermeture des régimes
spéciaux en matière d'assurance
vieillesse naturellement accompagné
financièrement les régimes thermiques
progressivement et ce à l'occasion des
taxes financiers l'automne 2023 et je
dis très clairement nous assurons la
soutenabilité des caisses de retraite
comme nous l'avons fait pour la SNCF
ainsi les nouveaux employés des
entreprises concernées seront affiliés
au régime général de l'assurance
vieillesse à partir du 1er septembre
2023 et dans le même temps les salariés
actuels continueront à bénéficier du
régime spécial en matière d'assurance
vieillesse mais chaque entreprise devra
négocier une période de convergence à
l'issue de laquelle l'âge spécifique
d'ouverture des droits les âges
spécifiques de retour vers d'ouverture
des droits seront relevés eux aussi de
deux ans c'est un point qui est
important que nous voulons souligner
devant vous voilà Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs les principales
caractéristiques du texte que je vous
présente place au débat désormais face
au débat au Sénat puisque l'examen
l'Assemblée nationale aura évidemment
permis d'entendre de nouvelles demandes
mais n'aura pas permis de les discuter
pour autant je pense aux mesures pour
les pompiers volontaires je pense aux
enseignants aux apprentis à la situation
de Mayotte ou encore aux possibilités de
rachat de trimestre de stage ou d'études
ce sera l'occasion pour le gouvernement
de soutenir les amendements allant ce
sens et nous en avons aussi déposé
quelques-uns
nous devons aussi aller plus loin et
ceux dans la continuité des discussions
que vous avez eu en commission des
affaires sociales et vous savez nous
l'avons dit avec la première ministre
notre volonté d'ouvrir un débat sur les
droits familiaux c'est un sujet complexe
car sensible appuyé sur des inégalités
entre les statuts qui portent sur un
système pension initialement pour
compenser des trimestres non cotisés
alors même que la progression du taux
d'emploi des femmes a changé la nature
de ces trimestres qui parfois viennent
s'ajouter à ce cotiser sur la même
période nous devons veiller à ce que
notre système de retraite soit donc
fidèle à son époque notamment pour les
mères de famille et il apparaît que le
sujet n'est plus dans un certain nombre
de cas tant les interruptions de
carrière qu'elles subissent comme cela
souvent été comme ça il y a encore
parfois mais plutôt l'accès à la
promotion et l'égalité professionnelle
les conclusions de ce débat sur les
droits familiaux à la fois en termes de
maternité d'éducation des enfants de
pension de réversion trouveront leur
place dans le cas du PLFSS pour 2024
mais cela ne doit pas nous empêcher
d'avancer et d'apporter de première
réponse je pense à deux sujets en
particulier le premier qui doit nous
permettre d'aller plus loin dans la
compensation en matière de valorisation
des pensions des écarts de salaires dont
une large partie est due corruption
c'est tout le sens du dispositif de
surcote à partir 63 ans que votre
commission des affaires sociales a
adoptée que nous regardons avec beaucoup
d'intérêt car il répond à un certain
nombre de ses priorités même si vous
savez je l'ai dit notre attachement à
l'équilibre financier du système le
second le second point de progrès
concerne une initiative du président
Bruno retaillod concernant la création
d'un dispositif d'un dispositif
spécifique de pension de réversion pour
les orphelins et en particulier pour les
personnes en situation de handicap et
connaissant cette situation d'être des
orphelins c'est un dispositif que nous
soutiendrons pour conclure mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs voilà donc la
réforme que nous vous proposons voilà
comment elle s'inscrit dans notre projet
politique vous savez où nous voulons
aller vous savez comment nous voulons y
aller et avec cette réforme je crois que
nous prenons nos responsabilités pour
nous et pour les autres je compte bien
évidemment sur les débats du Sénat pour
l'améliorer pour l'enrichir et vous
trouverez avec le gouvernement une
oreille toujours attentif à l'ensemble
de nos échanges merci de votre attention
donc si monsieur le ministre il est
14h55 à l'antenne de public vous suivez
depuis 14h30 la discussion générale qui
sert et bien d'introduction au débat sur
la réforme des retraites au Sénat après
le ministre du Travail Olivier du socle
c'est au tour de Gabriel Attal le
ministre en charge des comptes publics
de prendre la parole et les ministres
qui peuvent s'exprimer aussi longtemps
qu'ils le souhaitent retour en émission
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur général monsieur le
rapporteur pour la branche vieillesse
madame la rapporteur pour avis mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs nous voilà
mon collègue ministre du Travail et
moi-même devant le Sénat et devant les
sénateurs pour présenter le projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale qui réforme nos
retraites à l'orée de ces débats je
voudrais vous dire que nous venons
devant vous avec un objectif simple
construire un compromis clair pour la
retraite des Français
je le répète l'objectif du gouvernement
et de la première ministre c'est qu'à
l'issue de nos discussions nous
puissions trouver un compromis pour
payer les retraites des Français sans
impôts en plus ni retraite en moins
alors je le disais nous voilà devant
vous cet après-midi et c'est j'allais
dire le cycle naturel des lois
financières après l'Assemblée nationale
vient le temps du Sénat et je veux vous
dire
je sais qu'ici par de là les divergences
politiques on s’écoute je sais qu'ici
par de la les oppositions de fonds on
débat je sais qu'ici par de la les
parcours de chacun on se respecte je
sais qu'ici il n'y a pas de ZAD il n'y a
que la République
et donc je serai tenté d'espérer
qu'après le vacarme et l'obstruction des
extrêmes s'ouvre à cet instant le temps
de la sagesse et de la raison
car je souhaite poser une question et
une seule
des senteurs de débats à l'Assemblée en
commission et dans l'hémicycle soit
davantage de temps que pour les réformes
précédentes qu'en est-il sorti de bon
pour les Français du point de vue de
ceux-là même qui ça rejoint le monopole
de leur défense et qui ont tout fait
pour retarder les débats au fond chacun
apportera la réponse qu'il souhaite même
si je crois que les Français se sont
malheureusement fait leur avis et ne
nous ont pas attendu pour cela mais si
je pose cette question Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs ce n'est pas uniquement pour
dénoncer une nouvelle fois ce qui a pu
se passer si je pose cette question
c'est parce que c'est la seule qui
vaille d'être posée
et parce qu'elle résume à elle seule au
fond notre seul boussole celle qui doit
nous réunir l'intérêt général et celui
des Français et pour moi l'intérêt
général l'intérêt des Français il tient
en quatre points clairs d'abord pouvoir
payer sereinement les retraites de
bientôt 20 millions de retraités en
France ensuite ne pas faire perdre 1
euro de pouvoir d'achat aux Français et
donc exclure toute hausse d'impôts ou
toute baisse des pensions troisième
point équilibrer notre système de
retraite en travaillant donc globalement
un peu plus longtemps et enfin prendre
en compte la situation de chacun pour
que la réforme soit équilibrée sur le
plan budgétaire je l'ai dit mais
répartissent aussi équitablement
l'effort demandé aux Français
voilà l'approche cohérente qui est la
nôtre et que nous soumettons à votre
examen voilà le cadre qui est le nôtre
et dont nous ne dérogerons pas mais au
sein duquel nous sommes ouverts au
compromis voilà ce qui nous semble être
des conditions raisonnables pour œuvrer
ensemble au service de l'intérêt général
et on l'espèce l'intérêt général cela
veut dire permettre à chaque Français le
temps venu de pouvoir compter
sereinement sur la retraite à laquelle
il a droit ni plus ni moins voilà ce qui
est en jeu préserver nos retraites non
pas par dogme ou par réflexe mais par
bon sens une vie de travail à la fin on
doit en voir les fruits et le fruit
d'une ville de d'une vie de travail pour
l'immense majorité des Français c'est
leur pension de retraite qui leur permet
de financer leur mode de vie auquel ils
n'ont aucune envie de renoncer au fond
c'est cela la classe moyenne tous les
Français qui n'ont que leur travail pour
vivre cette classe moyenne qui a trop
souvent le sentiment de travailler pour
d'autres qui eux font le choix de ne pas
travailler
si on ajoute à cela le fait de
travailler dur pour une retraite qui en
plus diminuerait alors ces Français
perdront définitivement foi en l'action
publique alors c'est pour eux que nous
agissons c'est pour eux que nous sommes
engagés dans cette bataille c'est pour
eux que nous vous présentons ce texte et
c'est pour eux mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que je souhaite lancer un
appel loin des polémiques les polémiques
j'adresse un appel engageons-nous dans
ce débat sans faux semblant et sans
posture politique un appel au compromis
entre la majorité sénatorial qui incarne
la volonté d'une réforme et la majorité
présidentielle qui porte la
responsabilité de la réforme un appel à
la cohérence la majorité sénatoriale a
tant voulu cette réforme et la voté de
nombreuses fois un appel à la
responsabilité augmenter les impôts pour
financer les retraites ce n'est pas la
bonne solution car à la fin il y en a
toujours un qui paye et celui-ci
s'appelle le contribuable
j'adresse donc cet appel au Sénat
discutons amandon des bâtons mais à la
fin votons ce texte votons-le car
garantir aux Français que leur retraite
seront payées n’est ni de droite ni du
centre ni de gauche c'est tout
simplement
œuvré pour l'intérêt général
cet appel n'est ni Idéalis ni déconnecté
des réalités politiques à l'oeuvre
Parlement car en effet la progression
des débats dans le pays a permis de
trouver des points de convergence qui
rendent possible ce compromis et je
souhaite les partager brièvement avec
vous
premier point de convergence politique
qui me semble intéressant de noter plus
personne ne remet en question le
problème de financement de nos retraites
et si il est un progrès permis par le
débat à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
d'avoir vu la partie gauche de
l'hémicycle la nupesse reconnaître enfin
qu'il y a un problème de financement
pour notre système de retraite cela a
été dit par plusieurs députés de la nups
les faits sont là et les faits sont
têtus en 2002 notre de sécurité sociale
devait payer la retraite de 12 millions
de retraités en 2030 elle devra payer la
retraite de 20 millions de retraités
c'est un quasi doublement en une
génération quel pays pourrait absorber
ce choc sans rien faire aucun et
d'ailleurs tous les pays européens ou
presque ont réformé leur retraite c'est
un premier point d'accord je crois qu'il
me paraît essentiel et je tiens à cet
égard à saluer la qualité des travaux
conduits par Catherine Deroche et
Elisabeth Doisneau René Paul Savary et
Sylvie Vermeillet dans cette assemblée
il témoigne d'une volonté sincère
monter les problèmes et vous nous
trouverez toujours à vos côtés pour cela
ensuite le contexte social du pays nous
oblige tous collectivement notre
avertissement est clair enlever un euro
de pouvoir d'achat aux Français qui
travaillent ou au retraités seraient
d'une injustice presque sinistre nous
nous y opposerons de toutes nos forces
comme nous l'avons fait à l'Assemblée
nationale où les propositions en matière
de taxes d'impôts de cotisation ont été
nombreuses on nous a proposé de taxer
les heures supplémentaires alors même
qu'un ouvrier sur deux dans notre pays
fait des heures supplémentaires on nous
a proposé de taxer les petites
successions dans notre pays 80% des
successions sont aujourd'hui exonérées
d'impôts les amendements venus de la
nups nous proposaient de taxer toutes
les successions dès le premier euro y
compris les petites successions à 30000
40000 euros de Français qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie dont le travail
a été taxé toute leur vie et qui aura
été à nouveau taxé au moment de la
succession on nous a proposé d'augmenter
les charges pour les petits artisans les
petits commerçants les petits chefs
d'entreprise 700 euros de plus pour un
salarié au Smic de charge c'est ce qui
était proposé à l'Assemblée nationale
cela voudrait dire que pour un boulanger
qui emploie trois salariés au SMIC il
aurait dû en licencier 1 pour payer les
charges des deux autres qui étaient
proposés dans les amendements c'est
exactement les propositions qui nous ont
été faites mais je vois qu'elles ont
aussi leur défenseur ici notre
conviction
notre conviction c'est que c'est le
travail qui crée la richesse pas les
nouveaux impôts enfin
enfin notre système actuel est injuste
et il faut le corriger pour les
travailleurs qui ont des métiers
pénibles et qui arrivent casser à la
retraite pour les femmes dans les
spécificités de carrière en lien
notamment avec la maternité et
l'éducation des enfants mais également
avec des inégalités de rémunération ne
sont pas assez prises en compte au sein
même du système de retraite pour les
petites retraites qui sont trop basses
et que nous voulons revaloriser voilà en
toute transparence les points d'accord
qui sont je crois largement partagés sur
les bancs et qui rendent possible la
perspective d'un compromis en tout cas
je l'espère nous y sommes pour notre
part tout à fait prêt notre volonté est
réelle elle est sincère elle est entière
mais je suis lucide si l'Assemblée
nationale a été la chambre des
divergences brutales je ne crois pas que
le Sénat sera pour autant celle des
convergences miraculeuses car un
compromis se construit à certaines
conditions la discussion dans laquelle
nous nous engageons la capacité à faire
évoluer notre projet nous la démontrons
le compromis se construit aussi par la
cohérence que les Français attendent de
nous tous je rappelle que si les
parlementaires qui soutiennent depuis
des années une réforme des retraites par
le recul progressif de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite répondent à l'appel
que nous lançons alors voter une réforme
serait non seulement possible mais ce
serait même logique en matière de
retraite la majorité sénatoriale a en
effet incontestablement le mérite de la
constance et je ne doute pas qu'elle
aura aussi celui de la cohérence
puisqu'elle vote chaque année en PLFSS
des mesures visant à assurer l'équilibre
de la branche vieillesse le projet du
gouvernement est celui que cette
majorité sénatoriale défend de longue
date sont donc proches je pense
notamment au report de l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans à l'accélération de
l'allongement de la durée et d'assurance
requise pour obtenir le taux plein
autour de mesures contenues dans
l'article 7 de ce PLF RSS je tiens
d'ailleurs à saluer cet esprit de
responsabilité dans un jeu politique ou
malheureusement de trop nombreux
responsables choisissent parfois
d'ignorer le danger qui pèse sur nos
finances publiques
en bref je crois un compromis possible
au Sénat j'y crois et je l'appelle de
mes vœux car ce serait œuvré
démocratiquement pour l'intérêt général
je le dis la force du compromis il vaut
toujours mieux que le fait accompli
l'intérêt général je l'ai dit c'est de
payer sereinement les pensions de
bientôt 20 millions de retraités et pour
cela l'équilibre financier est
indispensable et donc il n'est pas
négociable le menacé n'est pas une
option je dis bien indispensable car ce
n'est pas une variable d'ajustement de
la réforme l'équilibre financier n'est
pas secondaire c'est le moteur de cette
réforme puisqu'il s'agit de dire que
nous voulons pouvoir continuer à payer
chaque mois les pensions de bientôt 20
millions de retraités dans notre pays
parlons donc équilibre financier
quelques instants mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs ma responsabilité de
ministre des comptes publics c'est de
dire la vérité sur les chiffres et donc
sur le potentiel impact budgétaire de
mesure votées par le Parlement le texte
qui vous a été transmis venant de
l'Assemblée nationale au sens textuel du
terme est à l'équilibre
un certain nombre de mesures ont été
discutés et votées en commission qui
coûte évidemment pour notre système de
retraite je sais que nous recherchons
tous l'équilibre du système et nous nous
souhaitons pas alourdir davantage son
déficit nous devrons donc pouvoir
discuter de façon approfondie et sereine
au cours de nos débats je pense d'abord
à l'amendement permettant aux assurés
ayant obtenu au moins un trimestre de
majoration durée d'assurance au titre de
la maternité de l'adoption ou de
l'éducation des enfants et justifiant
d'une carrière complète à 63 ans de
s'ouvrir des droits assurcotte sans
devoir attendre l'âge de 64 ans nous
aurons nous aurons évidemment ce débat
mais la première ministre a rappelé
notre ouverture vis-à-vis de mesure de
bonification pour les femmes et qui
contribuent à gommer les écarts dans le
niveau des pensions les évaluations sont
encore en train d'être affinés mais le
coût d'une telle mesure est évidemment
très important
s'agissant de la proposition de
maintenir à 60 ans l'âge minimum de
départ en retraite anticipé pour
incapacité permanente elle représente
combinée aux ajustements permettant à
davantage d'assurer d'être éligible à ce
dispositif présenté en texte initiale un
surcoût de plus de 250 millions d'euros
à horizon 2030 dont 100 millions d'euros
pour le système de retraite je pense
aussi à l'amendement prévoyant le
maintien de l'âge d'éligibilité et la
retraite progressive à 60 ans au lieu de
son report à 62 ans qui coûte un peu
plus de 100 millions d'euros en 2030
s'agissant des mesures visant à
favoriser le recrutement des seniors je
sais que la commission des affaires
sociales a proposé la création d'un
contrat de fin de carrière ouvert aux
salariés d'au moins 60 ans ce contrat a
duré indéterminé serait exonéré de
cotisation famille par ailleurs le
dispositif prévoit la possibilité pour
l'employeur de mettre à la retraite le
salarié si ce dernier remplit les
conditions pour bénéficier d'une
retraite à taux plein
je vois bien l'idée qui est de inciter
les employeurs à recruter des seniors et
à les maintenir dans l'entreprise
jusqu'à ce que ces derniers puissent
liquider leur pension là encore si je
comprends l'intention des rapporteurs je
souhaite alerter sur le coup
considérable d'une telle mesure qui
pourrait avoisiner les 800 millions
d'euros selon selon une première
estimation provisoire mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'en débattre il y a par
ailleurs un risque d'effet de seuil si
j'additionne les coûts de chacune de ces
mesures en retenant en ne retenant que
celles dont les conséquences financières
sont les plus importantes l'équilibre
financier de notre système à horizon
2030 s'éloigne indubitablement et je
veux le dire clairement nous souhaitons
pouvoir respecter cet équilibre
soyons clairs parler de dépenses
supplémentaires n'a jamais été un tabou
mais si nous perdons de vu l'équilibre
financier du régime de retraite une
réforme serait non seulement vaine mais
contre-productive l'équilibre financier
n'est évidemment pas une fin en soi mais
il n'est pas pour autant accessoire
c'est une condition indispensable à ce
que nous voulons faire permettre qu'une
vie de travail donne droit à une
retraite décente enfin puisque j'ai vu
aussi dans vos amendements des
propositions en ce sens je souhaite dès
le début de nos débats vous rendre
compte des progrès que nous
accomplissons en matière de lutte contre
la fraude grâce à la mesure que vous
avez adoptée en loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 les caisses
d'assurance vieillesse ne pourront plus
verser la SPA à compter de juillet
prochain sur des comptes bancaires
étrangers c'est une disposition que
j'avais proposé à l'Assemblée nationale
qui devait entrer en vigueur au 1er
janvier 2024 à la suite d'un amendement
sénatorial nous l'avons avancé au 1er
juillet 2023 c'est même caisse de
sécurité sociale auront accès enfin aux
fichiers FICOBA des bancaire pour lutter
non seulement contre la fraude à la
résidence mais aussi contrôler fraudes à
l'usurpation d'identité j'ai eu
l'occasion il y a quelques jours de
communiquer sur le bilan des fraudes en
2022 nous avons notamment des mantelés
un réseau de front de fraude horrible
lituanien pour les caisses d'allocations
familiales évidemment nous devons mieux
et nous devons renforcer le contrôle de
l'identité concernant les pensions
versées à l'étranger qui concernent un
million 100000 retraités dont 510 000 en
Europe et 440 000 dans les pays du
Maghreb nous avons également renforcé
nos contrôles nous prévoyons également
de déployer dès les prochains mois des
outils biométriques pour permettre aux
assurés volontaires de procéder au
contrôle d'existence un décret en ce
sens est en cours d'examen par la CNIL
et sera publié au cours des prochaines
semaines soyez assurés que compte tenu
de l'ampleur du déficit pour nos
retraites nous prenons toutes les
mesures de lutte contre la fraude pour
assurer le paiement au juste droit et ne
pas ajouter au déficit structurel un
déficit imputable au fraudeur
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs quelques-uns des débats que
nous devrons avoir je sais que nous
serons à la hauteur de ce qu'attendre
nos compatriotes et de l'idée qu'ils se
font du débat parlementaire j'essaierai
pour ma part de faire preuve d'écoute et
d'ouverture pour construire avec vous un
système de retraite plus juste et plus
soutenable en introduction de ma prise
de parole je vous lançais un appel un
appel pour agir afin de payer nos
retraites un appel pour échanger et
s'entendre un appel pour un compromis
politique au service des Français mais
s'il est un appel que nous devons
entendre c'est celui des Français qui
dans les débats qu'ils ont vu ce sont
parfois demandés si au fond cela valait
la peine d'avoir des débats en ayant
trop souvent et si souvent le sentiment
y compris par ceux qui prétendent les
défendre et défendre ceux qui s'opposent
à cette réforme en ayant le sentiment de
n'être ni entendu ni défendu à nous de
leur prouver le contraire discutons et
avançons pour eux je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes en direct sur l'antenne deux
publics Sénat vous suivez depuis 14h30
la discussion générale qui sert
d'introduction au débat sur la réforme
des retraites place maintenant aux
orateurs de la commission des affaires
sociales et avec notamment Elisabeth
Doisneau qui est le rapporteur général
de la commission
évident messieurs les ministres madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur de la branche
vieillesse madame la rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des finances mes
chers collègues comme vous le savez
depuis 2020 la commission des affaires
sociales a souvent réclamé au
gouvernement qu'il déposent un projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale
afin que le Parlement puisse se
prononcer en temps utile sur les
bouleversements que cette crise a
entraîné sur les comptes sociaux trois
années de suite les prévisions et
objectifs de la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale ont été rendus caduques
en cours d'exercice aussi bien en
recette qu'en dépense pourtant nous
n'avons pas été entendus et c'est en ce
début d'année 2023 que nous sommes
saisis d'un collectif social afin de
porter la réforme des retraites
alors même que les prévisions de la
dernière loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale n'ont pas été modifiées
en profondeur
je sais que cette apparent paradoxe
motive une exception d'irrecevabilité
dont nous débattrons tout à l'heure
j'indique tout de suite qu'à mes yeux un
tel véhicule législatif peut contenir de
telles dispositions la commission des
affaires sociales aurait d'ailleurs
mauvaise grâce à prétendre le contraire
puisqu'elle propose une telle réforme
depuis des années lors de l'examen du
projet de financement de la sécurité
sociale de l'automne et sur le fond peu
de mesure pourrait tenir pourrait avoir
un impact sur les comptes de la Sécurité
sociale supérieure à celui d'une réforme
paramétrique des retraites
qu'un texte budgétaire soit le cadre
dans lequel le Parlement débat de la
pérennité financière de notre système de
retraite ne me choque donc pas au
contraire
il n'empêche que la plupart des mesures
que nous allons débattre aurons un
impact financier à terme et que la
rectification des comptes de l'année
2023 n'est que mineur en quelques mots
le gouvernement n'a pas fait évoluer les
prévisions macroéconomiques sur lesquels
il s'est appuyé cet automne
il ne fait donc que tirer les
conséquences pour la seule année 2023 de
la réforme des retraites proposées par
le présente or celle-ci sont faibles et
font apparaître une légère dégradation
du solde de la branche vieillesse de 0,4
milliards d'euros et celle-ci est due
d'une part
à l'augmentation des dépenses à hauteur
de 600 millions d'euros en raison
notamment de la majoration des minimas
de pension et d'autre part en sens
inverse à une économie de 200 millions
d'euros grâce à la première application
du relèvement des bornes d'âge à compter
du 1er septembre
au total le déficit consolide d des
robes et du FSV seraient dégradées de ce
montant passant de 7,1 à 7,5 milliards
d'euros
j'ajouterai simplement que le
gouvernement a déposé à l'Assemblée
nationale un amendement qui n'a pas été
examiné visant à augmenter l'ONDAM de
1023 de 750 millions d'euros
en prenant en compte ce recalibrage la
dégradation du solde pourrait donc
dépasser un milliard d'euros par rapport
à la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023
les débats sur l'article 15 si comme je
l'espère nous parvenons jusque là vous
permettront monsieur le ministre
d'expliquer pourquoi c'est ton dame 2023
doit être revalorisée dès à présent
alors qu'en novembre le gouvernement
soutenait contre la vie du Sénat qu'il
était parfaitement calibré
mais bien entendu le cadrage financier
le plus important intervient à terme
puisque l'objet même de ce texte et
d'organiser le retour à l'équilibre
financier de notre système de retraite à
l'horizon de 2030 dans un contexte
démographique délicat
à titre personnel je souscris à cet
objectif qui me semble cohérent avec les
positions que notre commission et
au-delà le Sénat ont défendu depuis
longtemps je relève qu'au fil de ses
amis le message du gouvernement avarié
bien davantage puisqu'il s'agissait une
année de refonder le système sans
objectif financier puis de refonder le
système en l'amortissant d'un âge pivot
puis de le réformer de façon
paramétrique afin de financer toutes
sortes de dépenses publiques et
finalement comme le Sénat de présenter
une réforme paramétrique pour équilibrer
le seul système de retraite dès lors il
est difficile de reprocher à nos
concitoyens d'avoir du mal à suivre la
pédagogie puisque le mot est à la mode
né de la répétition et non des
changements des changements de pied
pour en revenir aux chiffres je les
reprends en quelques mots
les projections de l'année 2030 font
apparaître un déficit du système pris
dans son ensemble de quelques 13,5
milliards d'euros en l'absence de
réformes
il s'agit bien d'un chiffre annuel
dont le cumul creuserait une dette
susceptible de remettre en cause la
pérennité du système par répartition
créée à la Libération c'est-à-dire le
principe de solidarité entre les
générations qui fait que chaque
génération d'actifs finance par ses
cotisations les retraites de ces énigmes
en comptant sur le fait que les
générations suivantes feront de même
face à ce trou de 13,5 milliards le
relèvement de la légale et
l'accélération de la durée de cotisation
devrait rapporter
17,7 milliards d'euros en 2030 ce qui se
traduirait donc par un excédent
théorique de 4,2 milliards à cet
échéance
néanmoins le présent projet de loi
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale
contient diverses mesures dites
d'accompagnement
pour un total de 5,9 milliards d'euros
le trou donc de 1,7 milliards qui en
résulte a été comblé dans le projet
initial par deux mesures d'ailleurs
d'ordre réglementaire d'une part
l'augmentation de 0,12 points des
cotisations patronales vieillesse qui se
récompensés par la baisse du concurrence
des cotisations ATMP et d'autre part
l'augmentation de 1 point des
cotisations patronales de la cnr-a-cl
c'est donc d'un projet tout juste à
l'équilibre en 2030 par ailleurs fondé
sur des hypothèses qui les permit de
juger optimiste que l'Assemblée
nationale a été saisie le 23 janvier
comme vous le savez les débats n'ont pas
permis au députés d'aller au-delà de
l'examen de l'article de terre et seule
une mesure adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale aura un impact financier
positif significatif
l'harmonisation à 30% du taux de la
contribution assise sur les indemnités
de mise à la retraite d'un salarié à
l'initiative de l'employeur et de celle
verser à l'occasion d'une rupture
conventionnelle c'est donc le l'article
2 bis dont le rendement en 2030 est
estimé à 300 millions d'euros
cependant nous le savons aussi le
gouvernement a déposé des amendements à
l'Assemblée nationale qui n'ont pas pu
être examinés mais qui aurait eu un coup
de l'ordre de 850 millions d'euros s'ils
avaient été adoptés
cette présentation quelque peu aride mes
chers collègues vise à montrer que même
si le Sénat devra naturellement avoir
ses propres marqueurs nous ne
disposerons que de fort peu de marge de
manœuvre pour adopter des mesures
généreuses en recettes commandées
existantes ont déjà été utilisées il ne
serait pas responsable de notre part de
voter une réforme qui suscite tendez moi
dans le pays si nous ne rétablissons pas
véritablement la trajectoire budgétaire
de notre système de retraite
la vraie générosité la vraie générosité
pour les générations futures consiste à
leur léguer un système de retraite
financièrement solide et dans lequel
elles peuvent avoir confiance
je conquerai en disant quelques mots des
articles que j'ai pu particulièrement
instruire en dehors des articles
récapitulatifs l'article premier
concerne la fermeture de plusieurs
régimes spéciaux selon la clause dite du
grand-père concrètement les nouveaux
personnels embauchés à partir du 1er
septembre 2023 cotiserait désormais au
régime général et non plus dans le
régime spécial cette mesure concernerait
les régimes suivants les industries
électriques et gazières la Régie
autonome des transports parisiens
l'éclair est employé de notaire la
Banque de France et les membres du
Conseil économique social et
environnemental même si ces listes peut
sembler présenter un certain aléas les
régimes retenus se caractérisent par un
déséquilibre financier compensé soit par
une subvention d'équilibre de l'État ou
de l'employeur dans le cas de la Banque
de France soit par une taxe spécifique
la Commission proposera donc au Sénat de
s'en tenir à l'équilibre ainsi défini au
bénéfice de l'adoption d'un amendement
de coordination
l'article premier bis c'est introduit
demande de rapports que je vous
proposerai de supprimer par ailleurs
l'article 3 qui prévoit l'abandon du
projet de transfert aux urssafs de
l'activité du recouvrement de l'agir
Carco et de la Caisse des dépôts et
consignations constituent un motif de
satisfaction pour notre commission enfin
c'est dans l'annexe là que figure le
principe de l'augmentation des
cotisations patronales pour la CNRACL je
vous proposerai au nom de la commission
un amendement introduisant dans la loi
le principe de compensation intégrale
par l'État dès 2023 pour conclure je
m'appuierais sur les propos de l'abbé
Pierre qui disaient la responsabilité de
chacun implique deux actes vouloir
savoir et oser dire notre responsabilité
ici au Sénat repose il me semble sur ces
deux volontés complémentaires comprendre
et débattre je ne doute pas de chacune
et de chacun d'entre vous chers
collègues notre haute assemblée sera se
montrer à la hauteur de ses enjeux je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
prochain orateur René Paul Savary chef
de fil DLR sur la réforme de retraite il
a la particularité d'avoir porté depuis
2018 l'amendement au projet de
financement de la sécurité sociale avec
qui modifiait au Sénat à 64 ans l'âge de
départ et donc c'est à lui de prendre la
parole désormais à la tribune
Président Monsieur les ministres madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales madame la rapporteur
général madame la rapporteur pour sur
pour avis de la commission des finances
mes chers collègues la voilà la voilà
enfin cette réforme c'est très fort
attendue si nécessaire
pressante si urgentes mais si longtemps
repoussé la voilà enfin reprise par le
gouvernement cette proposition
sénatoriale renouvelée année après année
votez revotez contre la vie de ce
gouvernement
alors pourquoi pourquoi le gouvernement
n'a-t-il donc pas jugé bon de se rallier
dès 2018 au recommandations du Sénat la
pente serait moins raide le déficit
moins abyssal
que perdu que de temps perdu néanmoins
néanmoins les faits sont là
messieurs les ministres il n'est jamais
trop tard pour bien faire
les mesures de redressement des contes
de la branche vieillesse sont plus que
jamais impératisme madame la rapporteur
général c'est la raison pour laquelle la
Commission approuve les dispositions
d'âge de l'article 7
face à l'accélération de l'allongement
de la durée d'assurance requise pour le
taux plein 43 ans voté par la gauche de
cette hémicycle
cet article 7 reprend le relèvement de
l'âge à 64 ans proposé par la droite de
cette émission
sachez sachez que nous serons quand même
toujours attentifs au rendement des
mesures en ce qui concerne l'article 8
comme je le soulignais en novembre
dernier pour la quatrième fois mes chers
collègues il est nécessaire que ces
mesures ne pénalisent pas les
travailleurs les plus fragiles que
soient prises en compte les spécificités
de carrière différentes aussi aussi la
commission vous propose d'améliorer
l'article 8 qui aménage les différents
dispositifs de retraite
anticipées de façon à accorder une
surcote de 5% aux assurés ayant obtenu
au moins un trimestre de majoration au
titre de la maternité de l'adoption ou
de l'éducation et arriver à une carrière
complète pour qu'à 64 ans c'est
bénéficiaires puissent disposer d'une
surcote
cette surcote est quand même un élément
tout à fait déterminant qui permet
d'améliorer les pensions des mers de
famille et de réduire l'écart de pension
entre les hommes et les femmes
il s'agira pour la nation de compenser
de compenser les difficultés
professionnelles
rencontrées par ces femmes du fait de
leur charge de famille il s'arrivent il
s'agira de
réduire l'écart de pension entre les
femmes et les hommes c'est de la
natalité que dépend l'équilibre
financier d'un système par répartition
néfaste
face à cet effort collectif il n'est pas
envisageable de demander à nos
concitoyens de travailler plus sans
lutter contre ceux qui ne respectent pas
la générosité de notre modèle social
nous exigeons plus de fermeté de la part
du gouvernement qu'au minimum soit
appliquer dès le premier septembre 2023
monsieur le ministre les dispositions
que nous avons votées déjà en 2020 elle
permet de recourir à la biométrie pour
le contrôle de l'existence des
bénéficiaires de pension de retraités
français président à l'étranger
article 9 allonger la durée du travail
implique en nous d'améliorer la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle et
de garantir une juste compensation des
effets de la pénibilité à cet égard les
assouplissements du dispositif de
retraitant anticipé pour incapacité
permanente proposer à cet article 9
associe un recul de l'âge de départ à 62
ans nous semble insuffisants la
Commission propose donc de maintenir cet
âge de départ à 60 ans s'agissant des
victimes de maladies professionnelles ou
ayant connu un certain nombre d'années
préposition assez facteurs de pénibilité
s'agissant du compte
professionnel de prévention le C2P les
améliorations proposées qu'il s'agisse
de son déplafonnement ou de la création
d'une possibilité d'utilisation dans le
cadre d'un projet de reconversion
professionnelle nous semble elles aller
dans le bon sens pour renforcer la
prévention par rapport à la réparation
de même les facteurs de risque
ergonomique il représente une cause
majeure de maladies professionnelles il
paraît pertinent que ces facteurs
fassent l'objet de mesures spécifiques
telles la création du fonds
d'investissement la Commission propose
cependant d'y intégrer les agents
chimiques qui ont été exclues du C2P en
article 10 il est également nécessaire
de mobiliser la solidarité nationale
pour soutenir le revenu des retraités
frappés par la précarité frappé par
l'inflation après plusieurs années de
soudain sous indexation des pensions par
le gouvernement cet article 10 permettra
de revaloriser les minimales de pension
des assurés des régimes alignés et du
régime des salariés agricoles liquidant
leur pension à compter du premier
septembre prochain à hauteur de 100
euros pour une carrière complète
conduisait au niveau du SMIC de façon à
porter leur pension plus globale à 83%
du SMIC net carrière complète
cotisations à niveau du SMIC que les
choses soient claires quant aux
retraitait actuel une majoration de
pension pouvant atteindre elle aussi 100
euros maxi mum sera versé aux assurés
bénéficiant du taux plein et justifiant
d'au moins 120 trimestres cotisés c'est
ce que nous avions réclamé c'est ce que
nous avons obtenu dans la même logique
la Commission proposera notamment
d'ouvrir la majoration de pensions des
parents d'au moins trois enfants les 10%
pour trois enfants de l'ouvrir aux
professionnels libéraux sans oublier
monsieur le ministre les avocats
article 11 c'est la prise en compte de
certains stages d'insertion dans la vie
professionnelle dont les travaux
d'utilité collectives les prendre en
compte comme période assimilée à des
durées d'assurance c'est une juste
reconnaissance
article 12 c'est la création d'une
assurance vieillesse des aidant là aussi
c'est une juste reconnaissance envers
celles et ceux qui mettent leur carrière
professionnelle entre parenthèses on
profite d'un proche plus vulnérable
article 13
une réforme des retraites qui allonge la
durée du travail ne peut être envisagée
sans favoriser l'emploi des seniors
ce texte est insuffisamment imaginatif
il
uttait de bon temps me semble-t-il de
débattre d'une loi travail prenant en
compte l'employabilité des seniors avant
de leur rendement des plus
nous remettons les choses dans le bon
sens
nous souhaitons engager dès à présent
une campagne de mobilisation
un seigneur une solution
qu'elle est sur celle que nous avons
connue
un jeune une solution
[Applaudissements]
le premier mesure
permettront de favoriser leur
recrutement leur maintien en emploi et
leur transition vers la retraite c'est
ce que nous avons proposé et la
commission réhausse à 300 salariés le
seuil des entreprises concernées par la
publication du fameux index senior le
seuil de 50 salariés n'est pas adapté
monsieur le ministre vous en conviendrez
300 c'est le seuil des entreprises qui
doivent aborder le thème de l'emploi des
seniors lorsqu'elle négocie sur la
gestion des emplois et des parcours
professionnels si ce dispositif
limite constitutionnelle dans le PLFSS
donne quelques informations sur la
situation de l'emploi des seniors à
vouloir à vous enleux il est bien
insuffisant et aussi pour favoriser le
recrutement des seniors au chômage nous
proposons du concret un contrat de fin
de carrière ex onéré de cotisations
familiale réservée au plus de 60 ans qui
poursuivent leurs activités jusqu'à la
liquidation de l'orthroplan de leur taux
plein et éventuellement jusqu'à l'âge
d'annulation de la décote c'est un
contrat important entre le Seigneur le
Seigneur et son employé afin
afin d'inciter afin d'inciter les
employeurs à maintenir les seniors en
emploi il est judicieux de porter à 30%
le taux de la contribution assise sur
les indemnités à l'occasion d'une
rupture conventionnelle il est important
également de mutualiser entre les
entreprises le coût liées aux maladies
professionnelles à effet retardée
article 13 toujours dans l'optique de
favoriser l'emploi des seniors cet
article 13 ouvre fonctionnaires aux
assurés des régimes spéciaux aux
professionnels libéraux la possibilité
de partir en retraite progressive
possibilité dont bénéficie déjà les
salariés du privé tout en portant l'âge
d'éligibilité de ce dispositif de 60 à
62 ans ce que nous regrettons la
retraite progressive c'est aménager les
transitions entre l'emploi et la
retraite se tenir compte de la
pénibilité en allégeant la charge de
travail en fin de carrière et pour en
faire un instrument véritable incitatif
nous proposons de la mettre des 60 ans
et enfin le cumul emploi retraite sera
enfin créateur de Troie ce que nous
réclamons depuis un certain nombre
d'années pour conclure pour conclure
bien que tardive il y a un con complet
bien qu'un suffisant ce texte doit être
soutenu par notre assemblée il y va de
la sauvegarde de notre système de
répartition il en va de la garantie pour
les générations futures de bénéficier
d'une pension descente au terme d'une
vie de travail pour autant pour autant
nous réservons notre soutien à
l'adoption des amendements de justice
sociale que nous proposons nous vous
savons de bonne volonté monsieur le
ministre à vous de nous en donner
maintenant les preuves oui chers
collègues comme d'autres pays autour de
nous qui eux ont déjà pris leur
responsabilité la France vieillit les
naissances ne comblent plus notre
léogité croissante nous devons avoir le
courage de réagir non nous ne voulons
pas que nos enfants travaillent plus de
45 ans non nous ne voulons pas que nos
enfants travaillent après 65 ans à nous
de prendre nos responsabilités dans la
sérénité et le respect merci
merci Monsieur voilà il y a maintenant
un dernier orateur pour cette fois-ci la
commission des finances puis on passera
à l'examen de motion déposé par la
gauche et on verra que la tension
devrait monter d'un cran à nouveau à ce
moment-là mais place maintenant
[Applaudissements]
la présidente de la commission des
affaires
sociales madame monsieur lui rapporteur
chers collègues la commission des
finances a souhaité se saisir pour ravi
sur l'ensemble du plfssr au regard de
ces effets certains sur les finances
publiques notre système des retraites
repose sur le principe de répartition
selon lequel les cotisations des actifs
financent les pensions des retraités
soit
345,1 milliard en 2021 dans le scénario
retenu par le gouvernement et jugé
optimiste par la commission des finances
avec une croissance de 1% et un taux de
chômage à quatre et demi pour cent le
déficit du système atteindrait 13,5
milliards d'euros fin 2030 et 150
milliards en cumulent pour les 10 années
à venir
la stabilisation relative des dépenses
ne compensera pas la baisse des
ressources qui provient de la réduction
du nombre de cotisants de la diminution
de l'emploi public donc des cotisations
et de la réduction des transferts en
provenance des branches famille et
chômage en dépense le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites souligne que
les effets de la hausse du nombre de
pensionnés qui seront 23 millions en
2027 contre 19 aujourd'hui seront
partiellement atténués par la
stabilisation voir la baisse du niveau
des retraites rapportées au PIB
les dépenses progresseront néanmoins de
1,8% par an en volume sur le quinquennat
progression incompatible avec l'objectif
du gouvernement de réduction du déficit
public à l'horizon 2027 la réforme est
centrée sur une majoration de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits de 62 à 64 ans et
l'accélération de la durée de cotisation
portée à 43 annuités des 2027 le
gouvernement il carte l’hypothèse d'une
hausse de cotisation qui réduirait le
pouvoir d'achat de 442 euros annuels par
cotisant en 2030 ou la diminution des
pensions qui seraient de 719 euros
annuels par retraité en 2030 pour
compenser le déficit
la progression de l'emploi des seniors
constitue un enjeu majeur puisque bien
qu'en est hausse depuis 2003 celui-ci
reste inférieur à la moyenne européenne
de
59,6%. une attention sur mesure devra
être portée au 55 64 ans car la réforme
de 2010 avait induit une progression du
chômage pour ces classes d'âge le
montant des réserves placé par les
régimes de retraite atteignaient fin
180,4 milliards d'euros dont 86,5
milliards d'euros à l'agir Carco qui va
pouvoir réfléchir à l'utilisation de ces
excédents confortés par la réforme la
perspective de recettes supplémentaire
pour le système des retraites mais
également pour les autres branches de la
sécurité sociale et le budget de l'État
doit nous inciter à réviser le devenir
du Fonds de réserve des retraites
admirablement gérées depuis 2001
afin de nous prémunir d'autres aléas
démographiques n'est-il pas
indispensable de fléchir des recettes
supplémentaires liées à la réforme vers
ce fond qui sécuriserait notre système
par répartition le projet de loi
initiale propose plusieurs mesures
d'accompagnement estimer à 5,9 milliards
d'euros en 2030 année prévu pour
l'équilibre du système mais ce retour à
l'équilibre est fragilisé par les
amendements du Gouvernement déposés en
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
estimée à 800 millions à l'horizon 2030
vigilance sur ce point la réforme
prévoit également qu'à compter du 1er
septembre 2023 les régimes des retraites
des industries électriques et gazières
de la RATP de la Banque de France
d'éclairs et employés de notaire et des
élus du Conseil économique social et
environnemental n'aphilie plus de
nouveaux cotisants ces régimes sont
actuellement équilibrés soit au moyen
d'une taxe spéciale soit au moyen d'une
subvention d'équilibre versée par l'État
soit structurellement déficitaire le
montant des cotisations ne couvrant pas
celui des pensions
la fermeture de ces régimes entraînera
mécaniquement une attrition du nombre de
cotisants pour les caisses concernées je
m'étonne que les conséquences
financières ne soient pas d'ores et déjà
prévues notamment le reversement par la
CNAV et l'agirco des cotisants des
cotisations des nouveaux affiliés à
l'instar de ce qui fonctionne pour la
SNCF le relèvement de l'âge d'ouverture
des droits de 2 ans concernent également
tous les agents de la fonction publique
il ne devrait avoir que peu d'effets car
l'âge de départ est déjà de 63 ans et 8
mois pour laisser dentaires et 60 ans
pour les actifs le solde technique du
compte d'affectation spéciale pension
pourrait être de 0,7 milliards d'euros
en 2027 puis 1,1 milliard d'euros en
2030 de nouveau je préconise une
immobilisation de ces excédents au sein
du fond de réserve des retraites afin de
garantir l'avenir des retraites publics
au-delà de ces remarques la commission
des finances du Sénat estime que ce
projet de loi va dans le sens d'un
rééquilibrage du système des retraites
et que cet objectif doit être soutenu je
vous remercie merci Madame Laurent
voilà il est 15h41 sur l'antenne de
public c'est là nous sommes en direct
depuis 14h et nous suivons depuis 15h30
l'examen le début de l'examen de la
réforme des retraites au Sénat la
discussion générale a commencé à 14 ans
elle va être interrompue par l'examen de
deux motions de motions venues de la
gauche qui viennent comme ça dénoncer le
texte de la femme de retraite sur la
forme la première de ces motion vient
des communistes et c'est donc ayan
assassin leur chef de fil la présidente
du groupe communiste au Sénat qui va
prendre la parole pour et donc dénoncer
notamment l'utilisation du 47 ans de la
Constitution qui limite le temps de
parole autour de cette réforme 20 jours
à l'Assemblée 15 jours au Sénat en
écoutant
mes chers collègues
tout être humain qui en raison de son
âge son état physique ou mental de sa
situation économique se trouve dans
l'incapacité de travailler a le droit
d'obtenir de la collectivité des moyens
convenables d'existence la lecture de ce
11e alinéa du Préambule de la
Constitution de 46 sonne pour nous tous
à l'heure de légiférer sur une énième
réforme de réduction du droit à une
retraite digne comme un rappel aux
valeurs fondamentales de notre
République
issue de notre histoire le préambule de
1946 fait partie intégrante de notre
bloc de constitutionnalité avec la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789 ainsi que bien entendu
la Constitution de 1958 il reprend de
nombreux points du programme du Conseil
National de la Résistance
qui a permis la naissance de la sécurité
sociale et sous la direction du ministre
communiste Ambroise Croizat de la
création du régime de retraite par
répartition qui perdure aujourd'hui
encore
malgré les coups de boutoir des
partisans dogmatiques de la loi du
marché
cette réforme des retraites ou plutôt
cette destruction programmée de la
solidarité que porte la répartition
qu'Emmanuel Macron et son gouvernement
tentent d'imposer à notre peuple et
profondément injuste elle est injuste
moralement alors que sur fond d'une
inflation galopante nos concitoyens se
remettent à peine d'une crise sanitaire
violente alors que notre peuple plonge
progressivement dans une précarité dans
le travail mais aussi dans la vie
quotidienne du logement à l'accès aux
soins alors que les uns et les autres
sont frappés d'horreur par la guerre qui
tue à nos portes vous ne trouvez rien de
mieux monsieur le monsieur les ministres
mais aussi Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle et sénatorial que de
demander à nos concitoyens de travailler
plus longtemps
quelle violence
une planche faite à ses salariés souvent
usées pas seulement du fait de métier
jugé pénible qui devront travailler plus
y compris après des carrières bien
longues quel violence quelle violence
faite aux femmes qui du fait de leur
parcours professionnel heurté ou d'une
plus grande exposition au chômage
partiel devront travailler plus
longtemps
d'emblée je dénonce je dénonce les
propositions que je juge pour pas pour
ma part insultante pour toutes les
femmes de ce pays émanant du président
retaillod et du groupe les républicains
de vous préoccuper de la cause des
femmes vous les enfermez à quelques
jours du 8 mars dans un rôle de mère de
plus grandes familles possibles en
instaurant une prime à la maternité
qui fait vous plutôt
d'instaurer l'égalité salariale entre
les deux sexes cela assurera 6 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires de cotisations
sociales pour œuvrer contre tout nouveau
déficit à venir quelle violence quelle
violence pour les jeunes lycéens
étudiants et jeunes travailleurs qui
aujourd'hui se sentent à juste titre
condamnés à travailler jusqu'à un âge
avance les beaucoup estimant qu'ils
n'auront jamais de retraite il est de
bon ton de se moquer de ces jeunes qui
s'inquiètent de leur vieillesse mais
mesurez-vous l'angoisse de la précarité
de la guerre de notre planète qui
s'habille à un rythme fou votre projet
messieurs les ministres face à l'état de
notre société du monde relève de la
provocation il n'y a pas de
justification financière comme le corps
nous la démontré vous n'explorez aucun
financement alternatif ce qui n'est pas
étonnant car forcément c'est désagréable
pour le patronat et pour les plus riches
et ce n'est pas étonnant car vous êtes
dans votre monde dans votre bulle celle
des comptables de Bruxelles et de Bercy
aujourd'hui
l'inquiétude populaire se transforme en
colère des millions de citoyennes et
citoyens sont descendus dans les rues
des petites moyennes et grandes villes
l'unité syndicale vous a surpris mais
elle est solide elle tient et elle
construit méthodiquement la levée de
boucliers du 7 mars et des jours qui
suivront tous les actifs ou presque
retoque votre réforme une majorité des
électeurs LR est centrifient
l'entendre messieurs monsieur le
Président du Sénat et Monsieur retaillot
et Monsieur Marseille l'opinion publique
ne recule pas non elle exige le retrait
de ce projet mais plutôt que d'entendre
la raison comme l’on fait certains de
vos prédécesseurs
vous vous entêtez sans téter c'est
mettre en danger la cohésion sociale ces
fracturé c'est jeter le trouble les
seules responsables de la situation
actuelle du blocage annoncé c'est le
gouvernement c'est Monsieur Macron et
demain ce sera peut-être vous mesdames
et messieurs de la majorité sénatoriale
j'évoquais d'entrer le préambule de 46
toute cette première partie de mon
propos le confirme vous violez la
Constitution et vous faites planer une
menace contre le régime même de retraite
en prenant la capitalisation qui est
contraire à l'idée fondamentale selon
laquelle c'est la nation qui assure les
retraites et non pas les marchés
financiers
malgré tout cela
malgré tout cela si si monsieur le
ministre nous savons un peu nous savons
un peu malgré tout cela Emmanuel Macron
persiste et veut une adoption rapide de
ce projet portant réforme des retraites
il a inscrit cette dernière donc dans un
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale
réservée comme son nom l'indique à des
textes purement financiers l'avantage
donc c'est la limitation du temps de
débat 50 jours en tout 20 jours pour
l'assemblée qu'un jour pour le Sénat un
texte non voté par une assemblée et donc
transmis à l'autre assemblée et même en
cas de nombreux de la seconde une CMP
composée de 14 parlementaires et
convoqué et peut valider le texte
l'amender et le réécrire et en cas
d'échec de la CMP le gouvernement peut
légiférer par ordonnance ainsi un projet
d'une importance politique et sociale
considérable peut-être un jour promulgué
sans avoir été examiné jusqu'à son terme
par une des deux assemblées voir les
deux évidemment pour le gouvernement et
maintenant la majorité sénatoriale il
existe une solution
ne débattons pas ou à peine monsieur le
Président du Sénat mes chers collègues
comment avez-vous pu accepter de
délibérer d'un texte qui n'a pas été
soumis au vote de l'Assemblée nationale
je le rappelle les députés sont élus au
suffrage universel direct
l'accepter l'accepter
par l'accepter participe au coup de
force engagé par le président de la
République contre les institutions pour
imposer cette réforme massivement
rejetée tout n'est pas permis et cette
tentative de cases contre le Parlement
et peut-être le pari de trop engagé par
Monsieur Macron la seule affirmation
d'une légitimité liée à l'affirmation
durant le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle et bancale chacun sait
que le Président de la République
était
élu à Marine Le Pen et certainement pas
pour appliquer le recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite la méthode
profondément anti-démoc
utilisé par le gouvernement qui
contraint le débat parlementaire n'est
pas conforme à la Constitution Dominique
Rousseau professeur émérite de droit
constitutionnels le confirme je le cite
l'article 47 peut être utilisé pour une
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale les délais sont compressifs car
le budget bien évidemment doit être
adopté avant le 31 décembre or là il n'y
a aucune obligation que la réforme soit
votée en mars plutôt qu'en juin ou plus
tard fin de citation selon monsieur
Rousseau les sages pour essensurer pour
détournement de procédures et je le cite
à nouveau mon analyse c'est qu'il y a un
risque sérieux d'anticonstitutionnalité
car l'utilisation du 47 ans dans ce cas
porte atteinte à la sincérité des débats
finitation sincérité le mot et lâcher
quelle sincérité en effet
les deux chambres n'examine pas le texte
dans son ensemble Benjamin Morel pour sa
part rappelle que la décision du 3
juillet 86 a autorisé l'application du
47 ans à un plfs rectificatif mais à
condition de concerner des mesures je
cite d'ordre financier nécessaire pour
assurer la continuité de la vie normale
nationale votre texte menace-t-il la
continuité non ce n'est pas le cas
monsieur le Président nous sommes
aujourd'hui au Sénat et certaines choses
doivent être dites clairement avant
d'entamer l'examen du texte vu le cas
qui est imposé par le gouvernement par
le gouvernement que d'aucun estime
contraire à la Constitution je redis
avec la plus grande solennité que nous
ne comprendrons pas et que nous
n'accepterons pas que le Sénat avec sa
majorité
usent de procédure visant à accélérer le
débat à l'abroger à le tuer nous
n'accepterons pas que le droit
constitutionnel la liberté de parole
tout autant constitutionnelle doit être
mise en cause soit mise en cause
monsieur le Président allez-vous
aujourd'hui accompagner le gouvernement
et Monsieur Macron dans un coup de force
contre le Parlement qui si le texte
venait à être adopté par la seule CMP
voir pire par des ordonnances inusitées
sans habilitation ni ratification
relèverait d'un coup d'État feutré
contre les institutions de la République
ce texte donc et contraire à la
Constitution car il s'attaque à des
principes de solidarité au cœur de notre
République il est contraire à la
Constitution car il manipule la
Constitution pour contraindre le
Parlement le soumettre ne laissons pas
mes chers collègues au Conseil
constitutionnel le soin de censurer ce
projet de loi
clairement quelle que soit nos
engagements politiques que le Parlement
doit être respecté pour que la
démocratie le soit
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente la parole est
à madame la présidente Catherine de
roche cette boutique sur l'usage du 47,1
de la Constitution coûte forces contre
le Parlement méthode profondément
antidémocratique parole maintenant et
bien à la défense avec les LR contre la
motion du recevabilité et ensuite il y
aura la vie de la commission alors j'ai
bien entendu tout ce qu'a dit la
présidente assassine bon l'impact des
retraites sur le finance publique et
indéniable et puisque c'est même l'un
des premiers postes de nos dépenses
publiques et comme j'aurai l'occasion de
le rappeler en discussion générale c'est
très fort mais bien une réforme
budgétaire dans l'objectif est de
garantir la soutenabilité notre système
de retraite et assurer ainsi sa
pérennité elle a donc par conséquence
toute sa place en loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale j'entends aussi
l'argument selon lequel cette procédure
ne laisserait pas le temps nécessaire au
débat je voudrais s'il y aller et que
nous avons ouvert avec le président
Larcher plus de senteurs de débats alors
que nous passons en général 30 heures à
examiner le PLFSS qui concerne toutes
les branches l'ensemble des recettes et
des dépenses de la sécurité sociale
je rappelle que chaque année
depuis 2019 à l'initiative de rapporteur
de la commission des affaires sociales
pour l'assurance vieillesse le Sénat a
examiné cette réforme et a pu en
débattre alors le Conseil
constitutionnel sera certainement saisi
en effet il se sera conformément à sa
mission j'entends bien la présidente à
sa fille qui voudrait qu'on anticipe ce
que pourrait être une décision du
Conseil constitutionnel nous ne sommes
pas sur cette ligne et j'invite donc le
Sénat à se prononcer contre cette motion
merci merci madame la Présidente je vais
demander la vie de la commission madame
la rapporteur général merci monsieur le
Président chers collègues les auteurs de
cette motion conteste la
constitutionnalité de ce PLFR SS d'une
part sur le fond ce projet de loi
remettrait en cause le droit à la
retraite et d'autre part sur la forme à
tel texte ne pourrait pas être le
vecteur d'une réforme des retraites je
crois m'être expiré tout à l'heure à la
tribune sur le premier motif cette
réforme ne remet pas en cause le droit à
la retraite ni le fonctionnement de la
retraite par répartition au contraire le
redressement financier du système de
retraite a précisément pour objet d'en
assurer la pérennité pour les futurs
générations
et il en va de soi qu'au regard de
l'évolution de l'espérance de vie et je
pense qu'on aura tous les éléments au
cours de nos débats sur l'évolution de
l'espérance de vie il y a d'ailleurs eu
dernièrement des éléments qui ont été
portés à notre connaissance par
l'adresse qui indique que l'espérance de
vie sans incapacité à 65 ans et
supérieur à la moyenne européenne en
France en bonne santé sans incapacité
c'est ce que je dis sans incapacité
et donc le décalage progressif de l'âge
de départ ne prive pas nos concitoyens
du droit à bénéficier d'une retraite sur
le second motif la loi organique définit
les dispositions pouvant figurer dans un
plfsr RS et de nombreuses dispositions
de ce texte entre clairement dans ce
cadre
j'ajoute que même si les conséquences
financières de ce texte sur l'année 2023
sont modeste peu auront des faits en
fait je les dis tout à l'heure à terme
sur les finances sociales reconnaissons
que de nombreux projets de loi de
finance rectificative ont porté des
mesures beaucoup moins substantielles
pour les finances publiques sans jamais
avoir été censuré pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons même si le Conseil
constitutionnel aura et ça a été dit par
la présidente de la commission c'est
certain à se prononcer sur la place dans
ce texte de chacun de ces articles je
donne un avis défavorable à cette
exception d'irrecevabilité
merci je voudrais voir la vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci à Monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente vous avez évoqué trois sujets
plusieurs sujets pardon notamment des
sujets de fonds le débat sur les
articles et sur les amendements nous
permettra très certainement d'y revenir
si tenter que la motion n'était pas
adoptée donc nous aurons j'espère en
tout cas l'occasion de vous convaincre
que cette réforme est à la fois juste
qu'elle porte des progrès et qu'elle est
nécessaire je voudrais simplement
revenir sur trois points d'abord la
question de la recevabilité que vous
avez souligné mais madame le rapporteur
général de la commission des affaires
sociales comme madame la Présidente on
soulignait à quel point les dispositions
nous vous présentons ont un impact en
des conséquences sur les comptes sociaux
pour l'année 2023 ce qui justifie le
fait d'avoir recours un projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative pour l'année 2023 vous
avez ensuite madame la Présidente
considérait que la mise en oeuvre de
l'article 47-1 pouvait poser une
difficulté je voudrais rappeler deux
choses la première c'est que si nous
sommes dans le cas de l'article 47-1 ce
n'est pas une décision du gouvernement
l'article 47 terrain s'applique à
l'ensemble des lois de finances et la
récente loi organique que votre
assemblée a adopté comme l'Assemblée
nationale dit que lorsque les lois de
finances rectificatif pour la sécurité
sociale comme pour l'État relève de la
catégorie des lois de finances et donc
stombe sous le coup de l'article 47-1
cet article 47-1 fixe un certain nombre
délai il ne prévoit ni dérogation ni
possibilité d'aller au-delà et donc nous
l'appliquons de manière stricte mais
cela a été rappelé aussi cette
application de l'article 47 terrain le
respect de l'article 47-1 plus
exactement permet au Parlement d'avoir
un délai d'examen de cette réforme plus
long que le délai parlementaire consacré
aux réformes des retraites précédentes
et enfin Madame la Présidente vous avez
considéré qu'il n'était pas opportun
d'examiner un texte qui n'aurait pas été
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale les
différentes dispositions que j'ai
rappelé permettent cet examen et
organise un tel examen et je voudrais
simplement revenir d'un mot sur les
raisons qui ont amené à l'Assemblée
nationale à ne pas pouvoir examiner
totalement le texte à ne pas pouvoir
voter cette raison ne tient un seul mot
l'obstruction l'obstruction avec 20000
amendements qui ont été déposés et des
séries d'amendements identiques imaginez
madame la Présidente et je sais que ça
n'arrivera pas ici mais imaginez madame
la Présidente que
le dernier jour du débat le dernier jour
du débat il y avait 68 séries
d'amendements identiques déposés par le
groupe de la France insoumise avec mon
collègue Gabriel Attal nous avons mais
vous êtes leurs alliés mais avec mon
collègue Gabriel Attal nous avons écouté
patiemment 68 intervenants différents du
groupe de la France insoumise avant même
de pouvoir donner un avis et alors même
que l'amendement ne concernait pas le
fond du texte c'est la description de ce
que j'ai appelé l'obstruction ce qui
explique la situation que nous
connaissons pour toutes ces raisons bien
évidemment la vie est défavorable
merci
avant de consulter cela je vais demander
si à des explications de vote j'ai vu le
président canner
chez le Président Monsieur les ministres
vous avez choisi le détourner l'objectif
pire peut-être l'esprit du 47,1 de la
Constitution pour museler le Parlement
ce n'est même plus à ce niveau-là de
l'obstruction je qualifierais cela de
piraterie parlementaire pour ne pas dire
de déni démocratie le 12 mars à minuit
le couperet va tomber
pour la toute première fois depuis
l'introduction en 96 de ses lois de
financement au sein de notre
Constitution elles sont utilisées pour
mettre en place une réforme de grande
ampleur de notre système de retraite
c'est la première fois en procédant de
la sorte vous portez atteinte à la
crédibilité de notre Parlement à
l'équilibre de nos institutions et au
respect de la Constitution ces lois
financières on peut obliger le
déterminer les conditions générales de
l'équilibre financier de la sécurité
sociale selon les termes même de la
Constitution et vous n'ignorez pas que
la procédure tout à fait des rogatoire
prévu pour leur adoption poursuit un
seul et unique objectif garantir
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi de
financement pour l'année à venir avant
le premier jour de l'année civile
concernée
cette procédure n'a jamais eu ne devrait
jamais avoir provocation de permettre
d'introduire insidieusement au terme
d'un examen accéléré tronqué et
parfaitement inadapté aux enjeux de
véritables réformes sociales de fonds
relevant par principe du domaine de la
loi ordinaire par ailleurs en utilisant
cette procédure vous prenez le risque
que le Conseil constitutionnel censure
un minima cela a été dit par notre
collègue assassin les cavaliers sociaux
qu'elle contient car ils n'ont aucun
effet suffisamment direct sur les
recettes ou les dépenses de la sécurité
sociale exemple typique l'index senior
vous faites cela pour deux raisons
simples vous n'avez pas de majorité
maîtrisé au Parlement pour faire cette
réforme premièrement deuxièmement la
seule majorité que vous avez messieurs
les ministres elle est contre vous
contre cette réforme c'est celle des
Français
la constitutionnalité est donc manifeste
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
votera la motion présentée par Madame
Assesse
que le président compte
[Applaudissements]
oui merci merci monsieur le Président je
voulais d'abord rappeler à Messieurs les
messieurs les ministres ici on est au
Sénat et qu'on n'est pas là pour faire
le match retour ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale on est au Sénat on
va repartir sur des bases saines je
pense que il faut arrêter et si vous
souhaitez que le débat se passe bien je
pense qu'il faut arrêter avec ces
provocations voilà je pense que ça c'est
des choses qu'il fallait peut-être
peut-être appeler sur la proposition du
groupe CRCE je pense que le groupe a
tout à fait raison de dénoncer ce
corsetage et d'ailleurs je constate que
c'est quelque chose qui a été signalé
par un certain nombre d'élus de la
majorité
sénatorial qui dénonçait effectivement
ce corps se tâche ce choix du
gouvernement de limiter de limiter le
débat et je rappelle également
qu'Elisabeth borne nous avait promis un
temps un texte dédié elle nous avait dit
que on aurait un test dédié qui
évidemment
dépasserai pas par ce projet de loi de
finances de sécurité sociale
rectificatif bah on voit le on voit le
résultat mais alors pourquoi pourquoi
c'est urgence pourquoi ce passage en
force pourquoi ce festival des mensonges
pourquoi cette contrainte du débarque
parlementaire en fait tout simplement
pourquoi refuser le débat pourquoi parce
que vous ne voulez tout simplement pas
qu'on parle du fond vous ne voulez pas
parler de votre projet dans le fond les
raisons réelles de ce projet destruction
des services publics destruction de vos
de nos acquis sociaux toujours moins
pour nos communs toujours moins et
toujours plus plutôt pour le pour le
privé c'est ça votre projet c'est le
projet de la de la finance c'est les
projets d'une d'une retraite uniquement
gérée par le privé et puis pour les
autres pour le reste pour les petites
gens et bah il y aura les miettes voilà
votre votre projet mais évidemment vous
ne voulez pas qu'on en parle et bien on
aura et nous on souhaite avoir ce temps
du débat le temps qu'il faudra et il y a
une responsabilité ici qui sera la resp
onsabilité du gouvernement qui a décidé
de limiter ce débat
madame semi brûlant pour le groupe
communiste
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues oui
l'utilisation du 47-1 pour débattre de
ce projet de loi et contraire à la
Constitution et ceux qui semblent
vouloir le dénier font en quelque sorte
l'aveu qu'ils sont les côtes et les
coproducteurs de cette manipulation la
contrainte du temps d'examen des projets
de loi de finances et de financement de
la sécurité sociale ça a été rappelé ne
se justifie que par l'urgence de
respecter des délais et en particulier
celui du 31 décembre afin de ne pas
mettre notre pays en banque route ce que
chacun peut comprendre mais tout a
commencé par le rapport du corps montre
qu'il n'y a aucune urgence alleziférer
sur les retraites l'urgence c'est votre
obsession à empêcher que le débat et la
colère qui se développe dans notre pays
vous submerge vous êtes ainsi prêt à
accepter que ce projet de loi si
important pour l'ensemble
de notre peuple soit promulgué sans
avoir été soumis au vote de l'Assemblée
nationale et monsieur le ministre
vous avez de vous même tout fait pour
que l'Assemblée nationale ne puisse pas
aller au bout de l'examen du texte la
presse la presse durant ces 10 derniers
jours s'en est fait à de nombreuses
reprises les causes monsieur le ministre
êtes-vous prêt à soumettre à notre
assemblée séance tenante l'analyse du
Conseil d'État nous obligerait vous à
nous déplacer dans les prochaines heures
à votre ministère pour obtenir des
documents qui selon les échos mettent en
cause la constitutionnalité de votre
texte en matière de cavalier socio en
particulier cela a été rappelé par
Eliane assassy difficile en effet de
commencer nos travaux sans avoir
communication de ces documents monsieur
le ministre nous le redisons on ne joue
pas avec la démocratie on détourne pas
la procédure constitutionnelle on ne
s'appuie pas sur des contre-vérités
voire sur des mensonges comme vous
l'avez fait sur les 1200 euros en
déclarant dans un premier temps que tout
le monde tous les retraités seraient
concernés pour déclarer piteusement il y
a 48 heures que seuls 10 à 20 000
personnes le seraient finalement je
crois que le Sénat sonorerait d'adopter
notre émotion car il en va de la
démocratie je vous remercie
pas d'autres demandes
je vais maintenant consulter le Sénat
sur la motion pendant reposer
l'exception d'y recevabilité au cas où
cette motion serait adoptée il y aurait
rejet du texte en discussion en
application de l'article 59 le scrutin
public ordinaire et de droit il doit
être ouvert
il est ouvert
voilà c'est le tout premier scrutin
public de cet examen de la réforme des
retraites puisque la gauche a déposé des
motions de procédure notamment pour
contester l'usage de l'article 47 1 de
la Constitution qui contraint le temps
de débat à l'Assemblée nationale à 20
jours et à 15 jours au Sénat vous avez
entendu il y a une assassy chef de fil
des communistes parler de coup de force
contre le Parlement on a également
entendu le soutien des socialistes
Patrick Kanner parlait de piraterie
parlementaire ou encore et bien
Guillaume Gontard chez les écologistes
également soutenir cette motion qui
viserait donc à rejeter le texte avant
même le début de l'examen des articles
et des amendements on va voir avec ce
scrutin public qu'il va y avoir une
différence très nette entre la gauche
qui va soutenir ses motions et la droite
qui va la refuser il y aura d'ailleurs
une deuxième motion ensuite soutenue par
les écologistes mais donc ces notions
très peu de chances d'être adopté
puisque la gauche est tout simplement
minoritaire au Sénat et que la droite et
bien est favorable le texte même si elle
entend bien l'amant
nous allons passer à la motion pendant à
opposer la question préalable
madame ponce
monsieur Breuillet
les membres du groupe écologie et
solidarité et territoire ont déposé une
motion je donne la parole à notre
collègue Daniel broyer pour la motion
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs le rapporteur chers collègues
ils vont nous prendre deux nos deux plus
belles années de retraite me disaient
une ATSEM de la ville d'Arcueil la
semaine dernière
le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire demande par cette question
préalable de rejeter ce texte de loi et
de renvoyer le gouvernement à la
nécessité de reprendre le dialogue avec
les organisations syndicales ne vous en
déplaisent chers collègues ce serait un
message fort adressé à nos concitoyens
massivement opposés à cette réforme un
témoignage de notre écoute de leurs
aspirations et de leurs colères en
repoussant de deux ans l'âge d'ouverture
des droits à la retraite l'objet de ce
texte né en effet ni plus ni moins que
de faire peser l'équilibre du système de
retraite sur le dos des travailleurs
plutôt que sur le capital cette réforme
annonçait initialement comme une réforme
de justice mal mènera en fait nos
concitoyens et d'abord et principalement
les femmes
et bien sûr celles et ceux aussi qui
souffrent au travail celles et ceux dont
le corps et l'outil celles et ceux dont
les gestes répétitifs abîment les
épaules les dos mais aussi celles et
ceux qui vivent dans la tension
permanente du résultat sans plus
reconnaître toujours le sens de leur
travail les Françaises et les Français
nous parlent de leur vie et le
gouvernement répond
compatibilité comptabilité au fond cette
réforme comptable et financière était
déjà annoncé dans cette hémicycle par
Bruno Le Maire à l'occasion de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques non
pour équilibrer le régime des retraites
le système actuel n'est pas en danger
les dépenses ne dérapent pas et des
recettes sont possibles à condition de
l'examiner mais bien pour faire baisser
les dépenses publiques et respecter les
objectifs du pack de stabilité et de
croissance ce qui dérape c'est la dette
publique et elle dérape parce que vous
multipliez les baisses d'impôts
pour les entreprises du CAC 40 dont les
bénéfices battent pourtant tous les
records avec
59,8 milliards de dividendes versées la
France détient le record d'Europe la
seule suppression de la CVE représente
quasiment la totalité des économies
visées par cette réforme économique vous
faites vous payer cash par les salariés
en prenant deux ans de leur vie cette
vision comptable dans un petit texte
rectificatif fait l'impasse sur la
question essentielle celle du partage de
la richesse produite et de
l'accumulation de la richesse pour
quelques-uns
elle fait aussi l'impasse sur l'immense
apport non monétérisé des jeunes
retraités à la société dans les
associations la garde des petits-enfants
les conseils municipaux l'aide aux
parents en fin de vie et d'entendre
autre chose par cette question préalable
nous nous opposons un projet de loi qui
contrairement aux annonces de l'exécutif
ne permettra ni d'équilibrer
financièrement le système ni de garantir
une retraite minimum à 1200 euros
cela avait suscité de l'espoir 1200
euros pour tous on ne peut pas vivre
dignement avec moi voilà un débat pour
une République Solidaire nous ne
refusons pas le débat nous revendiquons
un débat parlementaire sur une réforme
du travail et des retraites ouvrons un
débat sur le travail sur les questions
de sens sur l'équilibre entre travail et
vie personnelle comme le font plusieurs
pays d'Europe en expérimentant à grande
échelle la semaine de quatre jours
ouvrons ce débat sur la possibilité pour
les salariés d'être associés au choix
stratégiques des entreprises sur la
façon de conserver l'expertise des
seniors dans l'entreprise plutôt que de
les mettre au chômage et ouvrons même le
débat sur cette volonté folle de vouloir
toujours produire plus et consommer plus
lorsque la planète nous dit que ce
productivisme nous conduit dans des
impasses dangereuses et lorsque le
dérèglement climatique bouleverse même
les conditions d'exercice du travail
ouvrons ces débats avec les partenaires
sociaux et même plus largement avec nos
concitoyens ils ont des idées et même
des propositions nous appelons ces
débats de nos vœux un simple texte
rectificatif du budget de la sécurité
sociale ne permet pas ces débats
monsieur les ministres votre réforme
malmène la démocratie d'abord la
démocratie sociale aucune réforme
monsieur le ministre aucune ne s'est
jamais faite contre l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales ce simple fait
disqualifie le texte la démocratie
contre l'immense majorité des Français
la démocratie contre les partenaires
sociaux ce n'est déjà plus la démocratie
et c'est un choix très dangereux lorsque
le rassemblement national est aux portes
du pouvoir
monsieur le ministre vous malmenez aussi
la démocratie parlementaire tout d'abord
par le choix d'un projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale un projet rectificatif est fait
pour rectifier qu'allez-vous rectifier
avec l'index senior d'un point de vue
financier rien qu'allez-vous rectifier
avec la suppression des régimes spéciaux
en 2023 rien non plus puisque la clause
du grand-père maintient heureusement les
régimes spéciaux salariés qui en
bénéficient déjà au-delà du fond de
cette réforme le véhicule législatif que
vous utilisez est problématique depuis
la création des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale c'est la première
fois qu'une telle loi sert de support
législatives pour une réforme des
retraites les lois de 2003 de 2010 et de
2014 était toutes des lois ordinaires et
non des lois rectificatives de
financement de la sécurité sociale rien
ne justifie ce module operandit et le
recours à ses contournements
parlementaires en venir les débats dans
des hémicycles il est urgent de sortir
de ce climat détestable qui affaiblit la
démocratie représentative l'usage de
l’artic 47.1 a grave cette situation
encore ce temps le temps des débats
depuis la constitution de ce
gouvernement aucune loi financière n'a
échappé à l'application du 49-3 le
Parlement est déjà affaibli dans son
pouvoir d'initiative et dans son pouvoir
d'amendement contraint par des
irrecevabilités financières et
matérielles je voudrais rappeler les
mots simples de l'article 24 de la
Constitution le Parlement vote la loi
nous appelons la présidence à conserver
sa vigilance dans la défense de la
plénitude et de la qualité du travail
parlementaire nous nous inquiétons
d'ailleurs aussi du danger de transférer
par ces procédures accélérées
l'arbitrage de nos débats parlementaires
au Conseil constitutionnel qui fait
aujourd'hui quasiment office de
troisième chambre bien sûr malgré ses
véhicules législatifs contestables vous
trouverez une majorité dans notre
nombreuses hautes l'appui de la droite
vous semble promis puisque vous faites
une réforme de droite c'est d'ailleurs
quasiment celle présentée ici même par
notre collègue Savary voilà trois mois
et les années précédentes et que vous
aviez alors qualifié de prématuré que la
majorité c'est notoriale depuis des
années utilise le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
pas un projet rectificatif d'ailleurs
comme vous le faites pour avancer ces
propositions d'allongement de la durée
du travail et compréhensible et même si
nous le combattons au fond ici les
débats sont feutrés mais les
propositions sont socialement très dures
mais que le gouvernement qui a la
maîtrise de l'ordre du jour du Parlement
refuse la présentation d'un texte de loi
ordinaire corps ce temps et limitant les
possibilités du débat n'est pas
acceptable pour quiconque défend un
véritable parlementarisme
le Conseil d'État et le président du
Conseil constitutionnel ont alerté le
gouvernement les articles non financiers
relatifs à l'index des seniors ou à la
modification des critères de pénibilité
devraient être supprimés pour raison
d'inconstitutionnalités vous n'avez
d'ailleurs vous avez d'ailleurs choisi
de ne pas rendre public cet avis du
Conseil d'État en aggravant les risques
d'inconstitutionnalité de plusieurs
articles ce texte se verrait amputé des
rares mesures d'atténuation de la
brutalité de la réforme renforçant
encore son déséquilibre en défaveur du
monde du travail et portant atteinte à
la sincérité des débats notre
interpellation s'adresse donc également
à la majorité sénatoriale pour rappeler
le nécessaire respect du pluralisme
garant de la qualité de nos travaux et
des débats de notre assemblée nous
devrions partager ici l'exigence d'un
véritable texte dédié aux évolutions du
travail et à la gestion des retraites et
non le passage en force par l'usage d'un
simple texte rect négatif messieurs les
ministres pour éviter le blocage du pays
il existe un moyen simple c'est de
bloquer cette réforme injuste
injustifiée et mal présenté chers
collègues en votant cette question
préalable nous redonnerons du temps au
débat avec les partenaires sociaux
l'histoire du travail toute l'histoire
du travail c'est une histoire de
conquête successives de gain de
productivité mais essentiellement au
service de l'amélioration des conditions
de vie et de la diminution du temps de
travail à la libération du temps pour
les humains cette loi fait l'inverse
entendons ce que disent des millions de
manifestants et l'immense majorité du
pays répondons à l'inquiétude des gens
qui refusent cette réforme et redoutent
cette idée de se faire voler oui chers
collègues les deux plus belles années de
leur vie à la retraite
mon pays c'est la vie combien de temps
encore à vivre des années des jours des
heures combien quand j'y pense mon cœur
bat si fort chanter Giani combien
sont-elles combien sont-ils aujourd'hui
à se poser avec votre réforme cette
question de combien de temps comme il le
dit dans cette chanson il le restera
pour rien pour courir pour pleurer
parler danser boire et voir et croire
merci
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner maintenant la parole
contre la motion à madame la présidente
Catherine de roche merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues l'objet d'une question
préalable est décidé qu'il n'y a pas
lieu de débattre c'est au contraire le
rôle du Parlement et des parlementaires
en particulier du Sénat des sénatrices
et des sénateurs que de débattre et se
prononcer pour un projet de réforme
important pour notre pays nos
concitoyens madame la Présidente assassy
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure le mode
élection des députés et l'importance en
effet qu'il débattent et qu'il se
prononce nous les sénateurs nous avons
la même valeur alors et c'est la force
du bicabéric
important dans les grandes démocraties
et nous envit beaucoup de citoyens même
s'ils n'ont pas le droit de le dire de
pays totalitaires au parti unique c'est
la mission la démocratie représentative
que d'assurer la pluralité des bas selon
des règles claires respectueuses du rôle
et des positions de chacun ce serait
nous dérober que de refuser d'assumer
cette mission
les auteurs de la motion considèrent je
le cite il paraît inutile de procéder à
tout délibération de fond je pense au
contraire que ces délibérations utiles
et qu'elle est nécessaire je note au
demeurant que plus de 4700 amendements
ont été déposés par les différents
groupes ce qui me paraît à tester d'une
préférence partagée pour la tenue d'une
délibération j'invite donc le Sénat
examiner ce texte en se prenant sans
contre la motion tendant à opposer la
question préalable
merci
quelle est la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
brolier vous m'avez interpellé
nous sommes confrontés nous aussi à
parler avec celles et ceux qui sont
concernés et dites-le à votre
aide-soignante si elle prend deux ans
supplémentaires ou votre ATSEM si elle
prend deux ans supplémentaires c'est
déjà par l'application de la réforme
Touraine qui a allongé la durée et fait
que elle sera contrainte de travailler
43 ans mais rassurer là qu'avec le
dégage de l'âge elle aura pas deux ans
de plus elle peut avoir quelques mois
mais ça lui garantira une meilleure
recette deuxièmement vous proposez de
taxer de façon supplémentaire vous savez
il faut être face à la réalité le
système par répartition c'est après le
principe de cotisation c'est pas un
principe de paiement par l'impôt c'est
la différence qui a entre le système
birmark
et le beveridjan et en conséquence quand
vous avez
une longévité qui accroît une natalité
qui baisse y arrive à un moment vous
pouvez taxer tout ce que vous voulez
c'est essayer de combler un puissant
faux c'est la raison pour laquelle il
faut prendre des mesures paramétriques
et troisièmement vous avez dit que le
débat était tronqué contre compte tenu
d'un nombre d'heures limitées plus de
centaines mes chers collègues trois fois
un PLFSS a été rappelé par Catherine
Desroches alors c'est pas assez pour
discuter de 4800 amendements et si vous
voulez qu'on discute effectivement
jusqu'au bout n'hésitez pas retirer ceux
qui sont redondants merci donc avis
défavorable de la commission
la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le Président la vie du
gouvernement est évidemment défavorable
nous considérons qu'il y a à la fois une
urgence nécessité et un besoin de
d'examiner cette réforme des retraites
et ainsi de garantir préserver nos
systèmes par répartition vous avez
évoqué monsieur sénateur l'accès à un
certain d'informations et mon devoir de
vous préciser que en matière de l'autre
financement de la sécurité sociale comme
de l'aide financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale il n'y a pas d'avis du
Conseil d'État il y a une note de
synthèse remis par celui-ci au
secrétariat général du gouvernement et
un certain nombre de parlementaires de
par les fonctions qu'ils occupent ont la
possibilité si le désir de solliciter la
consultation de ce document cela a été
fait à l'occasion du débat l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez évoqué un certain
nombre de sujets qui relève des
questions de revivabilité et les
éléments apportés par madame le
rapporteur général en réponse à la
présentation serait redondant si je l'ai
répété mais ce sont les mêmes pour
justifier d'un avis tout aussi
défavorable enfin je partage des
éléments exposés par madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales pour justifier dans la vie
défavorable à la motion rejet préalable
que vous évoquez vous avez conclu
monsieur le sénateur en citant Reggiani
il chantait aussi il suffirait de
presque rien effectivement il suffirait
de presque rien pour que nous puissions
rentrer dans le débat simplement le
rejet de la motion
merci explication de vote madame Lubin
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre c'est vrai
qu'habituellement au groupe socialiste
et apparenté nous aimons débattre ce que
nous allons faire d'ailleurs donc nous
appelons au débat mais il s'avère que
cette fois-ci le débat est tronqué le
débat est tronqué parce que nous allons
aborder une des périodes quand même les
plus importantes de la vie d'un salarié
celle à laquelle pendant laquelle il
aspire à se reposer un petit peu celle
de la retraite or là nous n'allons pas
parler retraites nous allons parler
chiffres d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre
du Travail vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous avez dit nous aurions dû
parler du travail de la vie mais nous
n'allons surtout pas en parler donc dans
ces conditions non nous n'avons pas
envie de parler retraite vous faites
porter les efforts uniquement sur les
salariés et vous ne remettez absolument
pas en cause votre politique fiscale
vous protéger toujours les mêmes et vous
soumettez toujours les mêmes vous
refusez d'examiner des solutions de
financement parce que mon cher collègue
René Paul Savary il faudra se poser la
question un jour on pourra pas toujours
faire travailler les gens plus longtemps
et moi je vous le demande et je vais
vous le demander souvent pendant ce
départ jusqu'à quand jusqu'à quel âge
pensez-vous notamment que les salariés
de première ligne pourront travailler
vous contraignez toujours ceux qui
travaillent depuis longtemps vous
exercez qui exercent les métiers les
plus difficiles et les moins bien
rémunérés en clair vous ne nous donnez
pas le choix parce que débattre c'est
choisir or là projet de loi de finance
de la sécurité sociale rectificatif
c'est rajouter des années au travail
c'est ne pas changer le mode de
financement étape est toujours sur les
mêmes et s'y faire travailler toujours
les mêmes nous n'avons pas de choix donc
effectivement nous ne pouvons pas
débattre correctement et nous voterons
cette question préalable
pour le groupe communiste
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues monsieur
les ministres nous sommes d'accord avec
vous nous aussi nous voulons un débat
mais pour faire un débat il faut être
deux nous avons donc des questions et
nous espérons obtenir quelques réponses
par exemple qui gagnera les 1200 euros
tout le monde comme vous l'avez fait
croire au début ou seulement 20 000
personnes comme la démontrer le député
Guedj à l'Assemblée nationale en quoi un
index pour l'emploi des seniors
sera-t-il plus utile quand on voit le
résultat aujourd'hui de l'index sur
l'égalité salariales femmes hommes
comment vous croire quand vous dites la
main sur le cœur vouloir défendre la
retraite par répartition alors que le
même casting ministériel nous disait en
2019 qu'il fallait absolument la
capitalisation et la retraite par point
qui croire encore
allons parler de justice sociale et que
vous vous apprêtez à voler les deux plus
belles années de vie aux travailleuses
et travailleurs utiles et essentiels
usé par une ville labeur et si nous
avons des questions monsieur les
ministres nous aurons aussi des
propositions vous cherchez des milliards
nous aurons des propositions la
véritable l'égalité salariale fameum
c'est de suite 6 milliards de
cotisations un million de travailleurs
et travailleuses supplémentaires en
emploi ces 10 milliards de cotisations
ou reprenons la main sur une seule
partie des 162 milliards d'aide direct
et indirects que vous donnez chaque
année au capital sans contrepartie
d'emploi de salaire ou de formation
alors messieurs les ministres vous
voulez un débat nous sommes prêts utiles
combatif et déterminés pour faire échec
à votre compte projet de réforme 64 ans
on est ni juste socialement ni efficace
financièrement et nous sommes prêts
déterminés bienvenue au Sénat et bon
débat
merci
donc pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote je n'en vois pas
je vais consulter le Sénat sur la
monsieur tendance à poser la question
préalable en application de l'artiste 59
du règlement le scripta public ordinaire
et de droit
le scrutin va être ouvert dans quelques
instants il est
le temps est ouvert voilà il est 16h29
sur l'antenne de publicelle nous sommes
en direct pour suivre ce deuxième
scrutin public sur une deuxième motion
venue de la gauche la gauche du Sénat
qui a donc déposé des motions de
procédure notamment pour dénoncer
l'usage de l'article 47 1 de la
Constitution qui contraint la durée des
débats au Parlement vous avez pu
entendre ainsi les écologistes qui ont
rejoint les communistes dans la critique
de la forme que prend l'examen de ce
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale la
droite a répondu qu'il y avait plus
d'une centaine d'heures ouvertes en 11
jours de débats c'est autant que l'ordre
l'examen du PLFSS le projet web
financement la sécurité sociale à
l'automne donc pour la droite il y a
suffisamment de temps pour examiner
cette réforme il devrait y avoir donc un
rejet cette deuxième motion on va aller
tout de suite rejoindre les musiques
pour écouter le résultat de ce scrutin
public
344 pour 93 contre 251 le Sénat n'a pas
adopté
j'informe le Sénat en application de
l'article 11 de la Constitution et de
l'article 67 de notre règlement j'ai
reçu de Monsieur Patrick Kader président
du groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains de Madame Éliane président
du groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste de monsieur Guillaume Gontard
président du groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire une motion qui
tend à proposer au président de la
République de soumettre au référendum le
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité le projet de
loi de financement rectif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 en application de
l'article 67 alinéa de notre règlement
cette notion doit être signée par au
moins 30 sénateurs dont la présence est
constatée par appel nominal il va donc
être procédé immédiatement à l'appel
nominal des signataires je demande aux
huissiers de procéder à l'appel nominal
Monsieur Patrick canaire
oui alors voilà il est 16h31 que se
passe-t-il en ce moment dans l'hémicycle
qui vient il y a trois groupes de gauche
les écologistes les socialistes et les
communistes qui ont déposé une motion
référendaire cette notion référendaire
est différente de celle que nous venons
d'examiner elle sera examinée d'ailleurs
demain matin elle sera constituée d'une
autre DG et pour examiner cette motion
référendaire il faut que l'on constate
qu'il y a bien 30 sénateurs présents en
séance afin qu'elle soit enregistrée par
la présidence de séance c'est donc en ce
moment ce qui est en train de se passer
il y a un huissier qui est en train
d'appeler les noms de tous les
signataires de ces de cette notion donc
dans les trois groupes de gauche afin de
vérifier et bien qu'elle est compatible
avec le règlement du Sénat ensuite j'ai
un lyncher devrait être annoncé qu'il y
aura donc un examen demain matin dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat de cette motion
référendaire une notion référendaire qui
vise donc à provoquer un référendum par
oui ou par non sur la question de la
réforme des retraites c'est donc une
demande des trois groupes de gauche qui
se sont alliés afin de déposer cet autre
motion après les deux émotions qu'on
vient déjà d'examiner mais celle-ci va
prendre plus de temps à examiner c'est
ce qu'on verra demain dans l'hémicycle
après cet appel on va reprendre la
discussion générale avec les prises de
parole de tous les groupes politiques du
Sénat ça va durer deux heures ça va
clôturer la journée d'aujourd'hui et
demain donc on reprendra avec cette
notion référendaire et l'après-midi à
partir de 17h le Sénat commencera
l'examen des articles des amendements à
proprement à proprement parler 20
articles dans ce projet de loi et 4700
amendements retour dans l'hémicycle
et donc donner monsieur Julien
voyez mon immense beauté ça durera pas
mais donc acte de lait du dépôt de cette
motion cette notion sera envoyée à la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la Présidente la discussion cette notion
aura lieu conformément à l'article 67 du
règlement dès la première séance
publique suivant sur des pauses et
l'article 67 alinéa 2
d'accord avec ta commission le
gouvernement nous fixons l'examen au
vendredi 3 mars à 9h30
pas d'observation il en est ainsi décidé
merci beaucoup
nous allons poursuivre notre discussion
générale et je vais donner la parole à
Madame
Raymond toncemonge pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire
[Applaudissements]
oh là madame pour ces Monges je voudrais
rappeler pour que chacun la discussion
générale est organisée je le rappelle
sur une heure
et les inscriptions de parole doivent
être faites avant 20h
ce jeudi 2 mars
vous avez bien noté discussion générale
sur une heure et inscriptions de parole
avant 20h ce jeudi de mars
maintenant nous entamons la discussion
générale Madame Raymonde c'est bon merci
monsieur
alors que le sens de l'histoire avait
conduit à la retraite à 60 ans les
contre-réformes se succèdent réforme
pesant essentiellement sur le monde du
travail parce que si la richesse
progresse sont partages inégal et la
super concentration des richesses aussi
pourtant rien dans la situation
financière du système de retraite ne
justifie cette réforme brutale car le
léger déficit prévisionnel opportunément
dramatisée provient d'une insuffisance
de recettes et non des dépenses dont la
trajectoire et maîtrisée selon le corps
des recettes qui proviennent de moins en
moins des employeurs le gouvernement
amplifiant la politique d'exonération
des cotisations sociales largement
contestées pour ses effets sur l'emploi
qui coûte au budget de l'État
l'équivalent de 7 fois le déficit du
système des retraites exonération de
moins en moins compensées par l'État
c'est ainsi plus de 2 milliards non
compensés en manquement des obligations
de la loi Veil et sans compter la non
compensation des exonérations des primes
pour le partage de la valeur alors que
notre amendement pour la rétablir avait
été adopté par notre chambre et retoquer
en CMP parallèlement le gouvernement
poursuit sa course folle au baisse
d'impôts qui alarme jusqu'au gouverneur
de la Banque de France les recettes
manquent parce que le gouvernement étant
les dispositifs d'exemption d'assiettes
de cotisations sociales et refuse
toujours d'aligner les prélèvements sur
les revenus financiers à hauteur des
revenus du travail quant à la
multiplication d'éléments de
rémunération des socialisée pour les
travailleurs leur a-t-on dit que cela se
paye par le recul de leurs droits et de
l'âge de la retraite pour les employeurs
par contre c'est tout bénéfice le
déficit se creuse aussi par la politique
d'austérité dans la fonction publique où
la baisse des effectifs le gel du point
d'indice passait et programmé signifie
une réforme des retraites à bas bruit
car si aucun votre recherche de la masse
salariale des fonctionnaires n'étaient
organisés le déficit serait diminué de 3
milliards à l'horizon 2030 non
nécessaire à la survie du système de
retraite ou d'autres solutions existent
cette réforme est indispensable par
contre au respect de la trajectoire des
dépenses publiques à 0,6 % en volume à
l'horizon 2027 que vous avez inscrite
dans le programme de stabilité envoyé à
Bruxelles alors que les retraites
progressent de
1,8%. car pour poursuivre la baisse des
impôts de production comme la
suppression de la CVAE qui prive les
comptes publics de l'équivalent du
déficit retraite les dépenses publiques
dont la retraite qui empêche un quart
joue ainsi les variables d'ajustement
voilà la vraie nécessité de votre
réforme une réforme qui ne demande
aucune contribution aux employeurs
pourtant premier responsable du faible
taux d'emploi des seniors mais sert la
poursuite des aides massives qui leur
sont versées et les baisses napouilles
de cotisations dont ils bénéficient
c'est pour poursuivre cette politique
quand même tant que le passage à 62 ans
en 2010 le fond de réserve des retraites
qui devait permettre de passer la bosse
démographique a été asséchée et détourné
injuste c'est très forme aura un coup
social inédit comme la réforme
précédente elle va allonger le sas de
précarité de pauvreté des femmes des
ouvriers et employés massivement et
employés massivement exclus de l'emploi
après 60 ans comme des 30% de français
les plus pauvres qui attendront deux ans
de plus le passage à la retraite qui est
pour eux marque une amélioration de leur
niveau de vie à 61 ans moins
d'enseignants sur deux est un emploi et
seulement 28% des ouvriers le chômage
s'est aggravé pour ces seniors suite à
la précédente réforme est près d'un
million ils sont depuis plus d'un an
avec très peu de chances d'en sortir
pour toutes ces personnes les catégories
populaire ni en emploi ni en retraite
comme pour plus du tiers des femmes la
réforme se traduira par une plus longue
période au minima sociaux en longue
maladie au chômage voire sans aucune
ressource alors que les femmes partaient
déjà 7 mois plus tard que les hommes en
courant derrière le taux plein le recul
de l'âge en substituant une partie de la
mobilisation des trimestres font en
trimestre travaillé allongera davantage
leur durée que les hommes après avoir
perdu un an et neuf mois avec la réforme
de 2010 les femmes de la génération 80
devront travailler huit mois de plus
pour tous ceux aux portes de la retraite
sur lesquels le gouvernement réalise les
économies à court terme nécessaire à son
objectif de respect du déficit à 3% en
2027 cette réforme n'est que brutalité
les travailleurs verront une nouvelle
diminution de leur durée de vie à la
retraite car l'espérance de vie n'est
plus tirée essentiellement que par la
baisse de la mortalité des plus de 70
ans de sorte que les réformes
successives dans celle de 2010 on
consommait plus que les gains
d'espérance de vie oui l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé augmente mais l'écart
d'espérance de vie en bonne santé entre
un ouvrier et un cadre reste lui de 10
ans avec votre effort le risque d'une
durée de retraite de moins de 10 ans
concernera plus de 40% des hommes les
plus modestes les rares mesures
d'atténuation de la brutalité de cette
réforme ni changeront rien tant pour
ceux coincés dans le sas de précarité
que pour ceux qui sont confrontés aux
inégalités de santé au travail et un
travail qui s'intensifie selon l'allera
d'Arès depuis 1984 tous les indicateurs
de pénibilité tous les indicateurs de
contraintes sur les rythmes de travail
ont été plusieurs fois multipliés la
question première centrale reste celle
du travail du travail concret de
l'urgence de changer le travail et de
l'urgence d'en réduire la durée face à
l'intensification du travail autre phase
du travailler plus d'ailleurs qui porte
le productivisme au cœur même du travail
votre réforme par la langue de la
finance quand il faudrait parler du
travail de ces conditions de son sens et
de la vie en travail à la place vous
multipliez des mensonges de la
revalorisation du micro dont une infime
minorité des nouveaux comme des anciens
retraités touchera les fameux 100 euros
pour faire oublier que ces contre deux
ans de travail en plus quand même et que
les femmes qui ne répondent pas aux
conditions et en seront donc exclues
sont sur représentés c'est pourquoi vous
créez les super carrières longues pour
mieux masquer le recul de deux ans de la
quasi majorité des départs anticipés
désormais donc à 22 ans alors que 60 ans
était la contrepartie de la réforme de
2010 quand tout le monde passait à 62 et
que dire de l'occultation des
externalités négatives alors que l'OFCE
dans un horizon de 10 ans
montre que ce report de l'âge provoquera
à chômage et baisse les salaires en
définitive cette réforme est une loi
contre le monde du travail c'est une loi
de classe qui touchera le pouvoir de
vivre des acquises mais surtout des
catégories populaires les Français l'ont
bien compris et c'est la raison pour
laquelle elle est si un peu plus l'air
et français ont bien compris que ce qui
se jouait était leur pouvoir sur leur
temps et comme disait André Gorce à
travers le pouvoir sur le temps c'est le
pouvoir tout court qui est en jeu le
temps que cette réforme leur veulent
c'est le temps libéré de la
subordination et de la nécessité un
temps sans incapacité que votre réforme
veut livrer une croissance
enfin qui ignorent les limites de la
planète le dérèglement climatique et
l'effondrement du vivant avec cette
réforme le gouvernement poursuit son
obsession du travail plus alors qu'il ne
faut pas tant augmenter le PIB que mieux
le partager et le subvertir par d'autres
indicateurs de prospérité comme
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé si
comme disait Ambroise Croizat la
retraite ne doit plus être l'antichambre
de la mort mais une nouvelle étape de la
vie elle doit être aussi une nouvelle
étape de notre rapport au monde dans un
siècle convoqué par la question
écologique cette loi du passé est une
loi d'une violence sociale inouïe qui
veulent les deux meilleures années de
retraite pour en faire les plus dures au
travail et c'est une loi qui barre la
bifurcation écologique une loi qui casse
le modèle social en prétendant
scéniquement le défendre pour toutes ces
raisons les écologistes s'opposent
radicalement à cette réforme et se
mobiliseront
jusqu'au retrait
la parole au président François Patriat
pour le rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la parole monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres
mesdames les rapporteurs monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues
à grande cause grande controverse
depuis des mois les retraites occupent
l'actualité sociale politique de notre
pays
le mot retraite est partout il vole de
tweet en tweet de manifestations en
émission de motion en émotion la
retraite est à la charnière de la vie
privée dont elle ouvre une partie du
projet personnel de chacun et de la vie
publique dont elle exprime le temps
solidaire la retraite mobilise la
question du vivre ensemble et de
l'acceptation des contraintes
collectives en même temps qu'elle
interroge sur le sens du travail si
toute l'ambition des acides du travail à
l'ouverture desquels monsieur le
ministre vous avez assisté sur deux
motivations essentielles et
complémentaires pour pouvoir mieux vivre
de son travail et pouvoir mieux vivre au
travail en somme redonner tout son sens
à la valeur travail car malheureusement
pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens la
conciliation entre le travail et
l'épanouissement personnel n'est pas
toujours au rendez-vous et nous le
savons la retraite est souvent vécue
comme une délivrance leur donnant enfin
un droit à la liberté
au bien-être et à la réalisation de soi
alors comment effectivement dire a-t-on
accepter de repousser ce privilège là
comment sortir de la dimension totemique
dans laquelle baigne désormais ce débat
une démocratie comme un autre est
capable d'en débattre sereinement même
d'un sujet si clivant et si passionnant
si fondamentalement français nous le
devons se débat aux Français car l'enjeu
est considérable sauvegarder notre
système de retraite pour dégénération
future et faire durer faire perdurer le
pacte de solidarité ou en sommes-nous
9 jours de débat l'Assemblée nationale
sont parvenir à l'article 3 des
stratégies d'obstruction et de blocage
20 000 amendements déposés désinfectifs
des violences verbales des menaces et
tout cela en fin de compte tout à
l'heure vous allez regretter que le
texte n'est pas été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale il n'a pas été voté parce que
les parlementaires n'ont pas voulu le
voter et Monsieur Mélenchon lui-même à
travers un tweet a bien demandé au Sénat
aux députés de ne pas voter ce texte
donc ils auraient pu le voter ils n'ont
pas le voulu le voter aujourd'hui ne
veulent pas vous dire qu'ils n'ont pas
vu le voter ici ici revenons au Sénat
revenons au Sénat les
426227 amendement déposé sont-ils les
premiers d'une obstruction au Sénat moi
je me le demande avec 69 avant de membre
mes chers collègues
identiques des trois groupes de la
gauche visant à supprimer l'article mais
il est liminaire je m'inquiète un peu le
comique de répétition est ses limites
rassurez-vous nous sommes rassurez-vous
69 similaires 69 amendement similaire le
psytacisme ça existe rassurez-moi
rassurez-vous nous sommes tous ici pour
débattre pour réaliser ce qui n'a pas
réussi l'assemblée et se prononcer sur
ce texte après le spectacle désolant du
dernière semaine il appartient au Sénat
d'ouvrir le débat et de le faire avec
exemplarité ce sera difficile parce que
c'est exigeant politiquement tranché
mais respectueux je sais les oppositions
résolues mais j'espère pouvoir compter
sur l'esprit de responsabilité chacun
pour débattre avec sérénité le Sénat
doit montrer que le Parlement est un
espace de dialogue débattre pour
éclairer une délibération et pour voter
notre conviction est que sans cette
réforme et sans consentir à de nouveaux
efforts il n'y aura pas d'avenir
pleinement assuré pour notre système de
retraite ceux qui préfère flatter
l'opinion en ayant la nécessité de ce
tréforme condamne notre système par
répartition quelles alternatives leurs
collègues une baisse des pensions
impensable une haute de cotisation
intenable notre choix nous l'avons fait
c'est la valeur travail le texte qui
nous est présenté aujourd'hui permet un
retour à l'équilibre en 2030 pour y
parvenir un effort de deux années
supplémentaires et demander aux Français
répartis de manière juste en tenant
compte de la situation de locaux citoyen
le plus vulnérable de se laisser qui ont
commencé plus tôt de la pénibilité des
Carnières hachées des pistes
d'amélioration sont encore possibles
notre groupe porte plusieurs noms au nom
de la justice sociale je pense au rachat
du trimestre pour les stages et les
études je pense aussi à leur
revalorisation des pensions de retraite
et de l'ASPA à Mayotte je tiens à saluer
ici le travail décisif de l'océateur
Maroilles notamment notre métallique
je crois profondément que ce texte peut
impulser nouvelle dynamique le point de
départ d'une réflexion plus large sur le
travail pour laquelle nous serons
pleinement investis mais aujourd'hui et
au sein d'un musc gue ici échangeons
bien sûr des bâtons mais surtout en fin
du compte votons je vous remercie merci
monsieur le Président donner la parole
de notre collègue Monique Lubin pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
République
tu as vu la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
Mesdames et Messieurs le rapporteur
chers collègues il est difficile
d'ouvrir ce débat sans évoquer en
préambule un élément structurant de la
réforme que vous défendez la méthode que
vous avez choisie pour la construire et
l'imposer elle trahit certainement vos
convictions profondes ainsi que vos
objectifs et priorités nous n'en avons
que trop conscience et c'est pour cela
qu'elle nous heurte si profondément
au-delà de la même de la manière dont
elle vous a conduit à construire votre
projet de réforme des retraites et à en
dénaturer l'objet
vous n'aurez eu que faire du dialogue
social conviant les syndicats à des
réunions mais ignorant les
revendications qu'ils portent au nom des
travailleurs vous aurez piétiné le
Parlement choisissant pour cette réforme
le véhicule du projet de loi de finance
de la sécurité sociale rectificative il
vous ouvre une porte de sortie bien peu
respectueuse du débat démocratique que
serait à énième 49-3 avec le choix
d'activer l'article et 47 1 de la
Constitution vous aurez achevé de faire
la démonstration au pays entier de votre
volonté de Nasser les parlementaires et
de les rendre inaudibles la très
mauvaise qualité de l'étude d'impact
accompagnant le présent de texte signalé
par le président du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques qui s'est reconnu
incapable avec les maigres éléments que
vous lui fournissez d'évaluer votre
réforme en témoignent également la faute
serait pour nous de vous laisser faire
par ailleurs vous portez atteinte à la
parole publique avec des chiffres faux
et des éléments de langage sophistiqués
destinées à perdre votre auditoire sa
témoigne d'un manque préoccupant de
sincérité vous avez illustré cette
insincérité avec le psychodrame des 1200
euros de pension minimale il a fallu
qu'un économiste et Michael Zemmour
perce le barrage de vos éléments de
langage pour dévoiler sur une radio
publique à une heure de grande écoute le
biais que vous utilisez pour affirmer
que votre réforme porterait la pension
minimale à 1200 euros même se
dévoilement tonitruant ne vous a pas
convaincu de cesser les infox il a fallu
qu'un député socialiste passe valoir ses
prérogatives de vice-président de la
mission d'évaluation et de contrôle de
la sécurité sociale à l'Assemblée au
siège de la sécurité sociale pour
obtenir les authentiques évaluations
chiffrées des effets de la réforme des
retraites
nous savons donc maintenant que ce ne
sont pas 40000 personnes chaque année
qui passeront le cap des 85% du SMIC et
que seul 20 000 retraités au mieux
franchiront le seuil des 1200 euros
pourtant annoncer
je me permets maintenant de vous
suggérer de prendre le temps d'un peu de
pédagogie auprès du président de la
République puisqu'il a très
explicitement démontré qu'il ne saisit
pas le fonctionnement du minimum
contributif si le président de la
République veut cette réforme des
retraites mais qu'il ne la comprend pas
il se trouve que nous avec les Français
nous la comprenons mais nous n'en
voulons pas en voici quelques raisons
l'exhaustivité est anticipe impossible
avant toute chose l'état des lieux de
notre système de retraite sur lequel il
a pu sa réforme n'est pas ce qu'en dit
le gouvernement le rapport du corps de
2022 déjà abondamment cité montre que
notre système des retraites est
stabilisé les résultats de ce rapport ne
valident pas le bien-fondé des discours
qui mettent en avant l'idée d'une
dynamique non contrôlée des dépenses de
retraite l'arrivée des babyboomers en
retraite est déjà pour l'essentiel
assorti amorti et si nous devons encore
tenir jusqu'en 2035 nous avons déjà fait
le plus dur notamment grâce aux gain de
productivité ce qui nous préoccupe avant
tout aujourd'hui c'est que les études
prévoient une baisse du niveau de vie
relative des retraités dans les
décennies à venir et si la trajectoire
des dépenses ne dérapmarque ne dérape
pas nous avons ici un problème de
recettes qui pourrait se traduire par un
déficit entre 10 et 13 milliards d'euros
d'ici à 2030 tout état de cause le
système des retraites versant plus de
300 milliards de pensions par an ce
déficit ne met pas en péril immédiat ce
pan de notre protection sociale il n'en
reste pas moins que nous devons
travailler à consolider le système de
retraite par répartition auxquelles nous
tenons absolument
le projet de loi repoussant l'âge de la
retraite de deux ans pour tout le monde
serait injuste pour de nombreuses
catégories de salariés cette mesure
pèserait moins sur la carrière des
cadres ils ont rarement commencé à
travailler avant 22 ans les 43 ans de
cotisation exigées à partir de la
génération 73 les amènent d'ores et déjà
à 65 ans quant à ceux qui auront
commencé à travailler entre 18 et 20 ans
l'âge où l'on peut bénéficier des
carrières longues étant également
repoussées de 60 à 62 ans ils ne
pourront valider leur retraite à 62 ans
qu'à condition d'afficher une carrière
complète or c'est dans ces catégories
que l'on trouve les employés les
ouvriers les aidants dont l'espérance de
vie et de 7 ans inférieur à celle des
cadres et c'est aussi dans cette
catégorie que se trouve ceux de la
première ligne à qui le gouvernement
prétendait offrir reconnaissance et
juste rétribution au pic de la crise
sanitaire
la justice est encore plus flagrante
sachant que les carrières longues
perdent une part importante de leur
surcote dans le passage d'un système à
l'autre les carrières courtes des CSP
plus qui sont souvent bien plus
rémunératrices et moins usante ne
connaissent que de faible décote pour un
départ à la retraite à 64 ans
pour les seniors qui ne sont ni en
emploi ni en retraite le recul de l'âge
de départ équivaudra par ailleurs au
rallongement de leur période de
précarité cela touche actuellement
environ un tiers des personnes
retraitées nées en 1950 37% des femmes
et 28% des hommes qui n'étaient plus un
emploi l'année précédant leur retraite
et ce n'est pas un index qui pourrait
changer cela en l'absence non démenti de
politique volontaristes en matière
d'emploi des seniors concernant les
femmes nous savons tous que cette
réforme fait perdre le bénéfice des
trimestres maternité pour la plupart des
mères en [__] le montant des pensions
accentue les décote et limite les
surcotes votre réforme affaiblit
considérablement un dispositif de
compensation des inégalités femmes
hommes s'agissant des femmes d'ailleurs
les dernières études démontrent que sur
les 18 milliards d'euros d'économies que
vous attendez de cette réforme 11
milliards seront payés par les femmes
si le report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite prévu par cette réforme est
inacceptable les mesures qu'il
accompagne sont plus ne sont pas non
plus satisfaisantes l'enjeu des régimes
spéciaux d'abord il n'y a ni besoin ni
urgence à les supprimer de la sorte nous
retrouvons ici les vieilles lunes de la
droite que vous reprenez à votre compte
monsieur Duce certains régimes auxquels
vous voulez mettre fin sont d'ailleurs
des régimes autonomes qui ne demandent
rien à l'état et la suppression du
régime spécial de la RATP c'est un
contrat que nous allons rompre mais nous
y reviendrons plus tard la suppression
de ces régimes est une pure diversion
politique
la question de la pénibilité et de
l'espérance de vie au travail n'est pas
moins traitée de manière problématique
ici en 2017 et par ordonnance l'exécutif
a supprimé le compte personnel de
pénibilité au profit du compte personnel
de prévention
à cette occasion il a supprimé la notion
de pénibilité au travail il n'est donc
plus question d'une gestion par
l'employeur de cette pénibilité elle
n'est pas réintroduite ici le fond
d'investissement proposé par le présent
de texte mentionne par ailleurs certains
des critères de pénibilité supprimés en
2017 mais pas tous et notamment pas les
agents chimiques dangereux concernant
les carrières longues ainsi que l'enjeu
de la pénibilité au travail ou la
question des inaptitudes au travail le
gouvernement prétendonner de nouvelles
tâches au médecin pour faire exister ces
dispositifs
nous nous interrogeons donc alors que la
France est en train de devenir un
gigantesque des airs médicales
l'exécutif aurait-il sous le coude des
praticiens mobilisables pour ces
nouvelles tâches
après avoir mené de nombreuses auditions
sur le présent de texte et entendu
toutes les parties prenantes il nous
paraît évident que cette réforme n'est
pas une réforme des retraites c'est bien
plutôt une réforme qui concerne les
finances de l'État puisqu'elles doit
faire baisser les déficits dans le cadre
d'une politique du gouvernement qui aura
eu pour constante de baisser les impôts
de production de favoriser les plus
riches et de dissosialiser les salaires
après le quoi qu'il en coûte payé par la
protection sociale nous voici face au
système des retraites sacrifiés sur
l'Hôtel du déficit de l'État
ce n'est pas un hasard si cette réforme
brutale fait peser les forces sur les
travailleurs et seulement sur eux c'est
aussi une réforme témoin qui doit servir
de gage à nos partenaires au sein de
l'Union européenne puisque le
gouvernement a jugé pertinent de
l'inclure dans son programme de
stabilité qu'il a transmis au Parlement
européen puis à la Commission
faute d'être capable de proposer un
véritable projet en matière du finance
publique dans un texte de projet de loi
d'orientation des finances 2023 2027
susceptible d'être amendée puis adopté
le gouvernement procède par coup de
force successifs il se ménage un chemin
budgétaire à coups de coupe dans notre
protection sociale
mais cette réforme est aussi une réforme
masquée du marché du travail nous y
reviendrons dans les débats
dans une récente des retraites la
question des recettes ne devrait pas
être un tabou des solutions financières
non douloureuses sont identifiables nous
signalons par exemple l'intérêt de
revenir sur les exonérations de
cotisations employeurs inutiles et
coûteuses auxquelles a procédé ce
gouvernement le total de ces
exonérations est en effet de 80
milliards d'euros par an une réforme des
retraites est par ailleurs inconcevable
si elle n'est pas précédée par exemple
d'une politique volontariste en faveur
de l'emploi des seniors de lutte contre
les inégalités de salaires femmes hommes
ou indépendamment d'une conversion
nationale sur les salaires que nous
d'une convention nationale sur les
salaires que nous appelons de nos vœux
le gouvernement devrait avoir le courage
de renoncer à son bricolage
contre-productif pour travailler en
profondeur avec les partenaires sociaux
et les parlementaires sur ce que nous
voulons comme modèle de société comme
partage des richesses comme modèle
social et comme progrès social
je vais donner merci cher collègue je
vais donner la parole à notre collègue
Cathy à Boursault Boli pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues ce projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificative pour 2023 est un
véhicule législatif inadapté à son objet
qui consiste à faire travailler deux
années supplémentaires l'ensemble des
Français le scénario de cette réforme
est celui d'un mauvais film il commence
mal et finira très mal pour le pays
quant aux acteurs que vous avez recrutés
il manque de crédibilité c'est votre cas
monsieur le Président Retailleau vous
qui déclariez le 23 juillet dernier que
les républicains auraient une attitude
sans complaisance avec le macronisme nid
dogmatisme c'est aussi votre cas chers
collègues de la majorité sénatoriale qui
travaillait main dans la main avec le
gouvernement pour faire adopter en
commission mixte paritaire un texte
qu'une majorité écrasante de nos
concitoyens refusent après avoir défendu
lors des élections présidentielles de
2017 et de 2022 l'allongement de l'âge
légal de en retraite à 65 ans pour
toutes et tous vous vous alignez
aujourd'hui sur le pouvoir en défendant
l'abaissement de l'âge légal de la
retraite à 64 ans et soi-disant mesure
pour les carrières longues monsieur le
ministre les vrais acteurs les bons
acteurs sont dans la rue à l'appel de
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
c'est avec eux qu'il faut réécrire le
scénario concernant le gouvernement les
cafouillages se sont multipliés ces
dernières semaines au point que même le
président de la République s'est pris
les pieds dans le tapis au salon de
l'agriculture sur la pension minimale à
1200 euros le 10 janvier dernier lors de
la présentation de la réforme des
retraites la première ministre avait
annoncé je la cite les petites retraites
auront droit à un relèvement de pension
à 1200 euros le gouvernement utilisé
répéter cet argument dans tous les
médias tentant ainsi de faire passer
pour un social ce projet qui est injuste
et inutile soyons clairs depuis le début
votre mauvais projet n'est fait que
d'approximation et de mensonges il ne
s'agit pas d'une revalorisation de 1200
euros mais de 1100 euros net toutes les
petites retraites ne seront pas
concernées puisque la revalorisation ne
concernera que les carrières complètes
en réalité même pour les carrières
complètes ce ne sera pas 1100 euros mais
une augmentation de 100 euros et encore
pas pour tout le monde enfin monsieur le
ministre du Travail vous avez été obligé
de reconnaître que cette revalorisation
ne concernerait qu'une dizaine de
milliers de personnes par an après avoir
fait croire qu'elle en concernerait des
centaines de milliers voire tous et
toutes au bout du compte il s'agit pour
vous de faire travailler les gens deux
ans de plus en étendant à tous la durée
de cotisations à 43 à nuités pour tous
en contrepartie vous n'avez rien d'autre
à nous proposer que 75 euros en plus par
mois pour 10000 personnes il faut que
vous retiriez ce projet
inutile
inefficace et d'une grande violence
sociale par contre il faut faire une
toute autre réforme des retraites c'est
ce que demande l'immense majorité des
Français selon les communistes Michael
Zemmour il suffirait d'augmenter de 28
euros la cotisation patronale pour que
les recettes de notre système de
retraite retrouve l'équilibre dans les
années à venir mais vous préférez taper
sur les travailleurs en les faisant
travailler davantage malgré la fatigue
et la pénibilité de leur métier pour
vous deux en supplémentaires ce n'est
rien mais une majorité de salariés n'est
plus en état de travailler à 60 ans
l'augmentation des cadences le mal-être
au travail l'épuisement physique avec
beaucoup de la question nécessite de
réduire l'âge de départ en retraite et
pas de l'augmenter votre réforme de fait
va priver les salariés de deux années de
vie en bonne santé en retraite à
profiter de leur petit enfant de leurs
amis d'un engagement dans le secteur
associatif culturel ou sportifs les
nantines sont pas les bénéficiaires des
régimes spéciaux que vous voulez
supprimer les régimes spéciaux des
électriciens et des gaziers de la RATP
sont le fruit de conquête sociale pour
mieux prendre en compte la pénibilité
des métiers pour nous ce sont des
régimes pionniers qu'il faudrait étendre
à chaque profession et convention
collective pour permettre à l'ensemble
des travailleurs une meilleure prise en
considération de la réalité de leurs
conditions au travail ceux qui vont
payer le plus cher ce sont les gens
modestes ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt ceux qui ont des
carrières hachées souvent des femmes et
des petits salaires votre projet très
fort mais bien un projet de classe
rétrograde c'est le copier-coller du
Medef bien silencieux dans cette affaire
c'est le copier de coller de la feuille
de route que vous propose chaque année
la bureaucratie européenne et c'est pour
ça que nous le combattons avec l'enfant
en l'ensemble des forces syndicales de
notre pays nous proposons un autre
projet de réforme des retraites où
l'humain prime sur la finance et les
intérêts des multinationales
contrairement à la majorité sénatoriale
et au gouvernement nous assumons de
demander aux entreprises de mettre la
main à la poche après avoir empoché
160 milliards d'êtres publiques sans
contrepartie et à dégager des bénéfices
records quand les travailleurs se
servent chaque jour la ceinture nous
présenterons nos amendements alternatifs
pour montrer que d'autres choix de
société sont possibles pour financer
notre système de retraite
l'auteur des enjeux du 21e siècle nous
proposons de mettre à contribution les
revenus financiers du capital les
milliards de dividendes d'augmenter la
CSG sur le capital nous proposons de
supprimer les dispositifs d'exonération
de cotisation sociale patronales qui en
plus le budget de la Sécurité sociale de
75 milliards d'euros sans effet sur
l'emploi et qui bénéficie surtout au
plus grandes entreprises nous proposons
conditionner les aides publiques à
l'absence de délocalisation des emplois
à l'augmentation des salaires et
garantir l'égalité salariale entre les
femmes et les hommes de l'argent il en
existe si on décide d'aller le chercher
et de s'en servir pour mener une réforme
des retraites de progrès juste en
rétablissant l'âge légal de départ en
retraite à 60 ans après 37 ans et demi
d'année de garantir une attention
minimale au niveau du SMIC pour une
carrière complète et à 85% du SMIC pour
une carrière incomplète de calculer les
pensions sur les 10 meilleurs années
nous proposons également d'augmenter les
salaires pour que les salariés puissent
faire face à l'inflation et aussi
accroître les ressources du système de
retraite nous proposons de mieux prendre
en compte la pénibilité en fixant des
listes de métiers et de postes ouvrant
droit au dispositif de votre départ
anticipé mais aussi en réformant
complètement le compte pénibilité
combien de salariés du bâtiment maniant
des charges travaillant marteau-piqueur
combien de travailleurs de
l'agroalimentaire travaillant de nuit
dans le froid d'ouvriers de fonderies
dans la chaleur et postée d'aide à
domicile et j'en passe se retrouve sans
aucun point après des années de travail
sur leur compte pénibilité nous
proposons de je vais prendre en compte
la situation des familles
monoparentales nous proposons de réviser
le tableau des maladies professionnelles
et de restaurer les CHSCT dans les
entreprises je m'arrête là mais la liste
des propositions n'est pas exhaustive
nous mènerons avec mon groupe une
bataille parlementaire contre votre
texte et défendront chacun
de nos amendements pour faire des
contre-propositions à vos mauvais coups
l'examen du texte au Sénat pour vous ne
sera pas un long fleuve tranquille vous
devrez compter sur nous pour vous
rappeler que comme
66% des Français et des millions de
manifestants le 7 mars nous sommes
opposés à votre réforme vous devrez
compter sur l'ensemble des sénatrices et
des sénateurs
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
et écologistes pour s'opposer avec force
et détermination à votre réforme
impopulaire refusé par 9 salariés sur 10
celle-ci est injuste et elle sera
inefficace en démocratie il faut écouter
la voix du peuple qui s'exprime avec
force je vous invite à écouter le peuple
qui sera dans la rue le 7 mars avec les
salariés le 8 mars avec les femmes et le
9 mars avec les jeunes
merci
je vais donner la parole
[Applaudissements]
au président
Hervé Marseille pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
la parole monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président messieurs les ministres
madame la Présidente de la Commission
mesdames et monsieur le rapporteur
en ouvrant l'examen de ce texte je
voulais vous dire d'abord qu'ici vous
n'avez rien à craindre monsieur le
ministre du socle et qu'ensuite nous
avons une seule intention c'est de
débattre et de faire aboutir nos débats
car le débat paradoxalement n'a pas
encore eu lieu voilà plus d'un mois
qu'on ne parle que de cette réforme de
retraite plus d'un mois qu'elle est
commentée à de nauséames sur les réseaux
sociaux plus d'un mois
qu'elle est contestée mais elle n'a pas
encore été vraiment débattue par ceux à
qui il incombe pourtant
constitutionnellement de le faire à
savoir les représentants de la nation
je ne vais pas revenir sur le spectacle
donné par l'Assemblée nationale mais ne
soyons pas étonnés à la suite de ces
palinodiques que le niveau d'abstention
augmente et que nous observions une
progression inexorable des extrêmes elle
est malheureusement prévisible le Sénat
a aujourd'hui l'opportunité de réhausser
l'image du parlementarisme compter sur
nous pour la saisir et s'il fallait
trouver des raisons de défendre le BIC
amérisme certains députés viennent de
nous l'offrir sur un plateau le refus
d'obstacle d'élus pourtant investi par
le suffrage universel et organisant
scientifiquement l'effacement de leur
propre assemblée démontrent par
l'absurbe la nécessité d'une deuxième
chambre apaisée
je me permettrai
de commencer par rappeler une évidence
les mécanismes que nous devons assumer
aujourd'hui relève d'un choix collectif
quasi unanime et presque enthousiaste
fait à la Libération en 1945 madame la
Présidente assassinat rappelé notamment
par Ambroise Croizat pour offrir une
digne fin de vie à nos vieux salariés de
l'époque nous avons opté pour un
dispositif consistant à ce que les
cotisations des actifs financent en
temps réel les pensions des retraités
cela avait l'avantage d'être
opérationnel immédiatement nous aurions
pu choisir une autre formule d'autres
formes de solidarité cela n'a pas été
fait la conséquence de ce choix que nous
sommes devenus dépendants des fondements
d'un système par répartition c'est à
dire dépendant de réalité démographique
en 1945 à cette égard c'était si vous me
le permettez un exercice qui n'était pas
trop compliqué avec une retraite à 65
ans et une espérance de vie de moins de
10 ans pour les retraités c'était un
rapport de quatre actifs pour retraités
autant dire que la solidarité
intergénérationnelle était plus facile à
assumer ce qui n'enlève rien l'avancée
sociale que cela fut à l'époque au fil
du temps le contexte démographique a
totalement changé la natalité s'est
dégradée l'espérance de vie a
considérablement augmenté de plus l'âge
de départ en retraite a été abaissé si
bien que le ratioactif retraité a changé
de nature il était de 4 pour 1 il est de
1,6 pour un aujourd'hui depuis 30 ans
les réformes se succèdent pour
accommoder cette évolution démographique
1995 2003
2010-2014 et heureusement que ces
réformes ont été effectuées sinon ou en
serions-nous aujourd'hui probablement
pour solde de tout compte puisque le
ratio est annoncé à un pour 4 pour 1 en
2050 dans ces conditions défendre la
pérennité du régime par répartition
c'est accepter d'en faire évoluer ces
paramètres nous ne souhaitons pas nous
considérons qu'il est inenvisageable de
baisser les pensions des retraités bien
sûr nous ne souhaitons pas augmenter le
coût du travail qui est le plus grand
ennemi d'un objectif de par conséquent
il ne reste que deux leviers
mobilisables soit la natalité soit la
durée de cotisation ce raisonnement par
élimination explique pourquoi nous
soutiendrons le report de deux anges de
deux ans de l'âge d'ouverture des droits
à la retraite et l'accélération de la
réforme tourate nous aussi nous avons
des propositions pour les recettes et
elles sont assez proches de celles que
j'ai entendues tout à l'heure nous ne
faisons pas oui oui
c'est Jean-Marie Wonder qui a déposé
l'amendement nous ne le faisons pas de
bonnes grâces mais c'est parce que c'est
la moins mauvaise des options raison
pour laquelle la majorité sénatoriale
l'adopte en PLFSS depuis des années nous
nous félicitons que le gouvernement s'en
soit inspiré il est dommage qu'on ait
attendu monsieur le ministre je vous
reconnais une forme de volontarisme en
nous présentant un texte de retour à
l'équilibre fondé sur des prévisions de
chômage assez optimistes nous nous
interrogerons d'ailleurs sur le réalisme
de cette trajectoire financière
alors que le taux de chômage à
4,5%, est encore loin d'être atteint
pour autant au titre de la solidarité
avec les générations montantes et pour
éviter de leur laisser une montagne de
dette nous assumons la dimension
financière de la réforme pour qu'elle
conserve un sens une pertinence elle
doit assurer un sol de durablement
équilibré nous ferons ainsi preuve de
vigilance dans les mesures que nous
examinerons nous soutiendrons évidemment
les mesures proposées par nos
rapporteurs dont je salue
l'investissement et le travail au-delà
notre groupe proposa d'autres
amendements sur le plan des recettes le
report de l'âge d'ouverture des droits
va induire un sur plus de recettes de
CSG nous portons l'idée comme la
rappeler Sylvie vermeiller tout à
l'heure de l'attribuer au fond de
réserve pour les retraites nous
souhaitons également favoriser l'emploi
des seniors en complément du dispositif
index senior et du CDI fin de carrière
proposée par la Commission nous
présentons une exonération de charges
sur les salaires de tous les travailler
de plus de 57 ans en miroir en cas de
licenciement l'employeur devra
naturellement payer l'équivalent des
charges exonérées par ailleurs dans
notre volonté de lutter contre les
violences intrafamiliales nous
proposerons que les parents condamnés
pour violence ou maltraitance de leurs
enfants soient privés des bonifications
qui leur sont liées de la même manière
lorsque le parent est condamné pour
abandon de famille ou non versement
d'une pension au profit d'un enfant
mineur la même sanction tombée dans un
autre registre au titre de la
préservation du pouvoir d'achat des
retraités nous proposerons d'indexer les
pensions sur l'inflation prévisionnelle
plutôt que sur l'inflation constater
l'année précédente dans un contexte de
forte inflation cette mesure évitera le
décrochage des pensions enfin nous
souhaitons améliorer les droits à la
retraite des élus des petites communes
souvent ils réduisent leur activité
personnelle pour exercer leur fonction
de ce fait beaucoup perdent des droits
et nous souhaitons leur permettre
d'arriver à à taux plein pour notre
groupe il semble indispensable de
rappeler que cette réforme n'est pas une
fin en soi la bouffée d'oxygène que nous
nous donnons jusqu'en 2030 doit nous
permettre d'ouvrir dans une certaine
sérénité un débat plus large sur
l'avenir du système de retraite la
réforme systémique d'inspiration
centriste par point doit être remis sur
le métier elle est en soi extrêmement
complexe dès lors qu'il faut assurer une
phase de transition si elle devait être
débattue à nouveau dans l'avenir elle ne
devrait surtout pas être associée à des
mesures paramétriques qui rendraient le
projet incompréhensible par ailleurs
envisager une part de retraite par
capitalisation pour le privé à l'image
de ce qui existe déjà dans la fonction
publique doit pouvoir être étudié sans
crispation de principe notre groupe est
prêt à participer à de tels travaux en y
associant l'ensemble des corps
intermédiaires et pour terminer j'aurai
un regret et une proposition un regret
c'est qu'on n'est pas ouvert le débat
sur la dépendance projet longtemps
annoncé toujours
qui me semble prolongée le débat sur les
retraites enfin et en me rapprochant de
ce que disait tout à l'heure notre
collègue broyé il paraît indispensable
d'ouvrir une conférence sociale pour
l'avenir pour évaluer les suites de la
société post covid en effet nous avons
examiné le commencement examiner les
retraites nous avons vu l'indemnisation
du chômage nous on nous annonce une loi
travail monsieur le ministre Attal vous
avez lancé
des expérimentations dans votre
ministère sur la journée de quatre jours
on parle du pouvoir d'achat je pense
qu'il serait opportun de travailler avec
les syndicats à une conférence sociale
pour réfléchir aujourd'hui autant de
travail à la société poscovide voilà ce
que nous souhaitons grouper espérons que
nos débats soient utiles
monsieur le président
venez la parole à notre collègue Esther
ben Bassa pour la Réunion administrative
des sénateurs
voilà il est 17h19 très précisément sur
l'antenne de public c'est là nous sommes
en direct depuis 14h30 pour suivre la
discussion générale autour de l'examen
de la réforme des retraites au Sénat
retour dans l'hémicycle
Premier ministre monsieur et mesdames
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues
cela a été déjà dit mais je le redis la
pédagogie c'est la répétition
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé est en
France de 64 ans pour les femmes et de
62 ans pour les hommes en repoussant
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à 64
ans est-ce donc ce message que vous
envoyez vous partirez quand vous ne
serez plus en assez bonne santé pour
travailler
avec cette réforme vous dessinez un
projet de société déshumanisant vous
rêvez d'une société qui travaille
toujours plus pour produire toujours
plus vous êtes dans la rentabilité la
compétitivité au lieu d'être dans la
solidarité la coopération et enfin la
vie simplement et loin de sauver la
retraite par répartition vous la
fragilisez et vous ouvrez la voix à la
retraite par capitalisation après tout
dites-vous que ce sont deux années dans
une vie
mais deux années c'est 730 jours de trop
pour un homme ou une femme ayant entendu
sa retraite comme une délivrance après
des décennies de dure labeur bien sûr
quand on travaille par passion et par
conviction sans s'épuiser à la tâche on
ne compte pas son temps voilà sans doute
pourquoi nous sommes si nombreux dans
cette émission avoir dépassé les 64 ans
n'est-ce pas
ne peut-on admettre que quand on
travaille par nécessité et dans l'effort
permanent on voit la retraite comme une
libération et le commencement d'une vie
nouvelle encore faut-il que cette
seconde vie on puisse l'amener dignement
le 10 janvier dernier madame la Première
ministre disait je cite une vie de
travail doit garantir une retraite digne
et ce gouvernement devant une réforme
revalorisant la pension des salariés au
SMIC jusqu'à 1200 euros brut s'ils ont
cotisé toute leur vie avez-vous
conscience qu'avec l'inflation actuelle
1200 euros ne permettront jamais à
quiconque de vivre mais au mieux de
survivre savez-vous seulement combien
pourront en bénéficier monsieur le
ministre du Travail donne chaque jour
des chiffres différents dès lors qu'il
faudra justifier d'une carrière complète
cotisée à temps plein au SMIC les femmes
comme toujours seront la première léser
elle représente 80% des salariés à temps
partiel et pour la plupart suspendent un
temps leur carrière en raison de leur
maternité leur salaire est en outre en
moyenne inférieure de 22 à 28% à celui
de l'homme elle ne cotise donc pas de la
même façon pour certains atteindre le
bon nombre d'annuités requis reviendrai
à partir à l'âge de 67 ans de quoi se
moque-t-on vous comptez sur la droite
sénatoriale pour vous accorder une
légitimité par le menteur je déplore
pour ma part qu'il n'y ait pas eu de
poursuit des débats ni de vote à
l'Assemblée nationale vous en êtes en
partie responsable en ayant tout recours
à l'article 47-1 de la Constitution
sachez en tout cas qu'une opposition de
gauche est bien présente dans nos rangs
au Sénat moins bruyante
présente oui et prête à débattre
jusqu'au bout les amendements de mes
collègues de droite pour corriger vos
textes notamment en proposant une
surcote de 5% pour les maires de famille
qui auraient une carrière complète ou la
création de CDI Seigneur visant avant à
favoriser leur emploi et à le valoriser
ne suffiront pas à rendre acceptable
cette réforme
une réforme que 69% des Français
rejettent sans appel selon un dernier
sondage il faut ces petits arrangements
à la marge ne démontrent qu'une chose
droite et macronie avance main dans la
main il est grand temps d'écouter la
colère sociale qui gronde nous avons été
des millions de citoyens et de
citoyennes dans toute la France a
manifesté contre ce texte le 19 et le 31
janvier le 7 le 11 et le 16 février le 7
mars il est elle diront de nouveau non
dans la rue à votre projet de société
nombre d'entre nous parlementaires nous
serons à leur côté dans la rue et aussi
au Sénat pour débattre des retraites
merci
la parole et maintenant notre collègue
Henri Cabanel pour le Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteur madame la Présidente de la
Commission
était-il urgent de faire cette réforme
des retraites
alors que la rue s'échauffe alors que
les sondages marquent l'opposition des
Français pour ce texte
alors que l'inflation la guerre à
l'Ukraine la crise de l'énergie la crise
économique crée un climat anxiogène
après une crise sanitaire mondiale
faut-il en rajouter si je suis le
premier à dire dans mes interventions
qu'il faut prévoir long terme et qu'en
France nous souffrons d'une absence de
culture d'anticipation et qui
raisonnable de faire de la faire passer
en force et c'est pas jouer avec le feu
je redoute ces conséquences politiques
car la colère entraîne souvent des votes
extrême si le risque que vous prenez
il y a encore une fois un problème de
méthode car chaque président de la
République Monsieur Sarkozy Monsieur
Hollande est désormais monsieur Macron
ont réformé notre système en peu de
temps
ne peut-il pas y avoir des prévisions à
long terme qui généreraient une réforme
à long terme également car les Français
ne comprennent plus
posons les enjeux
sécuriser le système de retraite
l'équilibre financier de notre système
de retraite et sur toute un enjeu pour
le régime de base de la sécurité sociale
depuis la loi organique du 14 mars 2022
relative aux lois de finances de la
sécurité sociale chaque PLFSS contient
un article liminaire sur l'état des
prévisions de dépenses de recettes et de
soldes des administrations de sécurité
sociale pour l'exercice en cours et pour
les années à venir
tout le monde s'accorde à reconnaître
qu'il n'est pas équilibré le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites chaque année
prévoit l'évolution du déficit entre 12
et 14% à l'horizon 2070 il faut donc
entrevoir des sources de financement
votre option est donc monter l'âge de
départ la France affichant un l'un des
âges les plus bas en Europe mais toutes
les solutions ont-elles été envisagées
étudier quelle évaluation
trouver le régime le plus efficient les
pensions sont financiers directement par
les cotisations des actifs c'est le
principe de notre système à répartition
cela nous impose d'anticiper mais là
encore avons-nous posé toutes les
possibilités qui pourraient solutionner
ces enjeux
le président Macron a imaginé lors du
quin qu'il a précédent une autre réforme
pour remplacer les 42 régimes de
retraite existants avec un système
unique à point cela soulevé à l'époque
une forte mobilisation sociale mais pas
plus que celle d'aujourd'hui la crise
sanitaire a effacé d'un revers de manche
cette option qui pourtant proposé le
même calcul pour tous même question
quelle évaluation quel bilan quel
scénario de solutions différentes c'est
pourquoi je salue l'introduction à
l'Assemblée nationale de l'article
premier bis qui demandera rapport sur la
possibilité les conditions et le
calendrier de mise en oeuvre d'un
système universel de retraite faisant
converger les différents régimes et
intégrant les paramètres de la réforme
prévue dans la présente loi
le groupe RDSE appelle depuis longtemps
de ses vœux une réforme systémique qui
pourrait aboutir à la mise en place d'un
tel système
rien ni les enjeux ni les solutions n'a
été véritablement expliqué aux Français
ce manque de sensibilisation laisse la
place à toutes les suppositions à tous
les fantasmes mais surtout à toutes les
oppositions
cela génère une fine un climat de
défiance nous sommes en plein dedans car
les Français se sont pris en pleine
figure une réforme qui leur paraît non
justifiée et surtout injuste car non
adapté aux carrières découpées des
femmes à celles des seniors aux métiers
pénibles et enfin aux carrières longues
pour générer l'adhésion vous le savez il
faut donner les clés de la compréhension
prenons les 43 ans de cotisations
peu de sang peu de Français savent que
cela déjà a été voté votez en 2014 sous
la présidence Monsieur François Hollande
cette loi est en train vigueur en 2020
la durée du cotisation pour obtenir une
retraite à taux plein devait augmenter
d'un trimestre tous les trois ans de
façon progressive en fonction des
générations
l'objectif étant d'atteindre 172
trimestres en 2035 soit 43 années de
cotisation pour les Français nés en 1973
votre gouvernement a donc prévu une
anticipation de la loi Touraine dès 2027
ce seul changement n'aurait pas dû
enflammer la sphère politique qui avait
raison et conscience a toujours pris ses
responsabilités
certaines parlementaires qui s'acharnent
d'une même voix à critiquer à invectiver
voire à vociférer en oublier de dire et
de redire que les 43 ans ont été votés
par la loi Touraine et de fait et de
fuite on a déjà reculé l'âge de départ
pour avoir un taux plein
il focalise la colère alors même que
cela a été acté il ne devrait pas y
avoir de débat à mon avis sur ce sujet
ils sont gravés dans le marbre de la loi
je pense que donc je pense donc vous
avez commis une erreur de communication
par ce texte car au-delà de l'erreur du
timing il en manque évidemment de
préparation de sensibilisation et
d'explication
une telle réforme sans l'accord d'aucun
candidat d'aucun syndicat pardon est
déjà un échec il rejette toute recule de
l'âge légal qui va pénaliser les plus
modestes un premier lieu les Français
ayant des carrières longues puisque
certains vont devoir travailler plus de
43 ans ce qui n'est pas équitable avec
un recul progressif de l'âge légal à 64
ans cette injustice concerne
potentiellement toutes les personnes qui
ont commencé à travailler avant 21 ans
sont donc des carrières longues qui
posent problème avec l'obligation de
Saint trimestre avec une organisation
par tranche d'âge avant 16 ans avant 18
ans avant 20 ans qu'il était cumuler
plus de 43 ans s'ils n'ont pas les 5
trimestres demandés
alors que très souvent ce sont celles
qui ont assumé les travaux les plus
pénibles même si nous ne sommes pas dupe
et qu'il s'agit avant tout d'un problème
financier et de solidarité du système je
salue par contre votre souhait d'entrée
une autre pour les moins de 21 ans
quant à la surcote de à 67 ans vous avez
dit que c'est pour soutenir les femmes
mais quelle évaluation de cette
proposition combien de femmes vont en
bénéficier heureusement votre
gouvernement vient d'annoncer une
nouvelle mesure destinée favoriser la
situation des femmes notamment via des
bonifications nous l'étudierons avec
grand intérêt
concernant la pénibilité le report de
l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans d'ici
2030 va automatiquement reculer l'âge de
départ possible en cas de pénibilité il
faut donc préciser les critères et
surtout favoriser des retraites
anticipées et nos débats vont nous
l'espérons faire avancer le texte car
l'article 9 n'a pas pu être examiné à
l'Assemblée nationale l'enjeu est
primordial
concernant les seniors l'article 2 a mis
en place un index et créer un objectif
d'amélioration de leur embauche et du
maintien de leur emploi
soutient l'idée d'un bonus valus qui
aurait de vrais effets de simulation de
l'emploi des seniors et poserait de
véritables objectifs car run index champ
pénalité ne servira à rien mais je
connais votre volonté de faire des
propositions concrètes à ce sujet
les critères de qualité de vie au
travail sont des indicateurs fiables par
exemple de taux d'arrêt de la maladie le
tourneur mais ils ne sont efficients que
s'ils sont accompagnés de contrôle et de
mesure coercitives
mon groupe le RDC est très attaché à la
valeur travail et le bien-être au
travail doit donc être au centre dans
nos débats car il n'y a pas de volonté
de s'arrêter tôt lorsque les paramètres
sont réunis pour une qualité de vie
professionnelle c'est pourquoi la visite
médicale le bilan du jour au travail est
primordial l'équilibre de notre système
passe par une solution de maintien dans
l'emploi des seniors il faut donc lutter
contre les abus de rupture
conventionnelle
de plus il faut absolument faire évoluer
les mesures de retraite progressive
pensez au bien-être du futur retraité
tout autant qu'à la nécessité de
transmission pour les nouveaux recrutés
je salue l'ouverture de ce système à la
fonction publique c'est pourquoi j'ai
déposé un amendement pour que des refus
des entreprises soient motivées il faut
les inciter accepter cette progressivité
dans l'arrêt à l'emploi
monsieur les ministres vous l'avez
compris pénibilité carrière longue
retraite des femmes et des seniors nous
semblent des sujets très importants et
les sénateurs de mon groupe vous
proposeront des amendements en ce sens
en fait je veux faire un aparté qui
n'engage strictement que moi
je suis choqué que nous amorçons ce
débat des retraites qui évoquent la
suppression de régime spéciaux sans
remettre en question notre propre
système celui des sénateurs
on me répond à juste titre que nous
avons un système autonome et que nous
finançons nous-mêmes notre régime certes
mais à partir de budget public et donc
de deniers publics puisqu'elle est
financée à la fois par notre cotisation
soit vas-y contraire notre indemnité et
bien financée par les deniers publics
par une cotisation employeur du Sénat et
par un prélèvement sur les actifs
financiers dont dispose le signe le
Sénat
l'Assemblée nationale aligné aligné son
régime à celui de la fonction publique
depuis 2008 pourquoi pas nous on me
répondra que les députés n'avaient pas
le même système c'est vrai mais quand on
veut on peut après 6 ans de mandat nous
bénéficions d'une pension qui n'a pas
été qui n'a pas
la très grande majorité que n'ont pas la
trigan de majorité des Français en une
carrière totale vous trouvez ça
peut-être normal moi je trouve ça
choquant je salue votre volonté monsieur
le Président ce matin encore sur une
chaîne publique d'avoir indiqué qu'il
faudrait réformer notre système
rapidement évidemment je suis pour une
réforme qui va s'appliquer rapidement
sinon de prévoir pour les autres c'est
toujours trop facile messieurs les
ministres beaucoup de points restent à
éclaircir
vous le savez l'ADN du groupe RDSE c'est
de débattre nous souhaitons donc aller
au bout de ce projet de loi dans un
climat apaisé mais je n'en doute point
pour construire un texte qui répondra
aux enjeux mais également aux
interrogations des Français tous les
regards sont portés vers le Sénat une
fois encore un dossera une mission de
sagesse et de raison pour faire évoluer
ce texte nous n'avons pas choisi cette
réforme notre responsabilité en tant que
par leur Inter et de débattre quel que
soit nos convictions au RDSE nous
assumerons son examen avait conscience
je vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame la présidente
Catherine de roche vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres
madame la rapporteur général monsieur le
rapporteur madame la rapporteur pour
avis mes chers collègues notre pays
évolue se transforme il vieillit nous
sommes loin d'en avoir tiré toutes les
conséquences sur un système social
construit pour répondre aux besoins
d'une société totalement différente mais
dans les représentations nous marquent
d'une empreinte durable si nous nous
référons au préambule la constitution du
24 octobre 1946
tout être humain qui en raison de son
âge de son état physique ou mental de la
situation économique se trouve dans
l'incapacité de travailler a le droit
d'obtenir de la collectivité des moyens
convenables d'existence la France alors
à 40 millions d'habitants les plus de 65
ans sont moins de 5 millions et
représentent 11% de la population
leur espérance de vie à cet âge est de
12 ans pour les hommes et de 16 ans pour
les femmes les retraités y sont pauvres
beaucoup plus pauvres que l'ensemble de
la population avec un taux de pauvreté
qui dépasse les 35% de ce point de vue
même si la pauvreté de certains
retraités en particulier aux âges élevés
restent une réalité le système de
retraite a permis de la réduire dans des
proportions considérables avec 8,6% le
taux pauvreté de plus de 65 ans et
inférieur au 14% de l'ensemble de la
population
la photographie d'aujourd'hui est donc
très différente en 2018 la France
comptait 65 millions d'habitants et plus
de 13 millions de personnes de plus de
65 ans soit 20% de la population
l'espérance de vie à cet âge a fortement
progressé elle est de 19 ans pour les
hommes et de 23 ans pour les femmes
depuis le milieu milieu du 20e siècle
l'espérance de vie a progressé de trois
mois par an en moyenne mieux encore
d'après des chiffres publiés récemment
l'espérance de vie sans incapacité à 65
ans à progressé de deux ans et 7 mois
depuis 2008 elle est de plus de 11 ans
pour les hommes et de plus de 12 ans
pour les femmes depuis sa création la
retraite a changé de nature et c'est
heureux une personne de 65 ans
aujourd'hui n'a que peu avoir avec ce
naïeul au même âge bien sûr la dynamique
de l'espérance de vie n'est plus aussi
soutenue que sous l'effet de la
Révolution cardiovasculaire c'est le
médecin qui parle qui a permis une
amélioration massive de l'état de santé
bien sûr nous constatons comment on fait
les pays nordiques avant nous les effets
du tabagisme sur l'espérance de vie des
femmes bien sûr les moyennes cachent
comme toujours de grandes disparités et
de Ford inégalités à cela aussi le
système de retraite a répondu se faisant
au fil des ans plus universel est plus
solidaires et corrigeant très fortement
les inégalités forgées au cours de la
vie active je prendrai pour seul exemple
la comptabilisation de 50 heures de 150
heures de travail au lieu de 200 pour
valider un trimestre certains nous
concitoyens vont ainsi le revenu
progressé en liquidant le retraite ces
évolutions
et démographiques ont conduit à faire
des retraites un des tout premier poste
de dépenses publiques au point de
s'interroger sur son avenir mais aussi
sur sa place dans les rangs de nos
priorités si les lois de programmation
des finances publiques n'étaient pas
devenue un exercice technocratique à
usage principalement externes elle
pourrait constituer le lien le lieu d'un
nécessaire débat sur nos priorités
d'actions publiques force est de
constater que la part des retraits dans
les dépenses publiques résultent plutôt
d'un choix implicite ni penser ni
articuler par rapport aux questions de
santé ou de vieillissement qui intéresse
pourtant au premier chef la même
population je ne parle même pas de la
justice de l'éducation de la défense
dont nous constatons chaque jour
l'ampleur des besoins alors oui les
légitimes d'interroger nos choix
collectifs en matière de retraite
lorsqu'elle est globalement prise plutôt
pour plus longtemps et dans des
conditions plus généreuses que dans
d'autres pays
oui il est légitime de s'interroger dans
le cadre d'un texte budgétaire car il
s'agit bien d'un enjeu de finances
publiques en jeu de finance publique qui
ne sont ni un tabou ni un gros mot aux
demeurant la réforme des retraites est
devenue un rendez-vous régulier notre
pays semble devoir faire avec ses
épisodes traumatiques au fil desquels
selon un rythme régulier il se livre à
cet exercice singulier le déroulé
souvent le même concertation opposition
manifestation puis adoption non sans
autant de recul qui sont l'annonce d'une
prochaine fois cela ne serait pas si
grave si à chaque fois l'exercice ne
contribuez pas à abîmer encore plus
notre tissu social il y a trois ans le
président de la République a tenté de
renouveler l'exercice avec une réforme
dite systémique table rase de tous les
régimes
hérités de l'histoire et place au jardin
la française du système universel une
belle construction intellectuelle
réalisée sans contrainte bud et donc
sans cristalliser les habituels
opposition d'abord intéressé par le bel
édifice nous avons ensuite été inquiets
au fil des discussions mais aussi de
deux colloques organisées au Sénat notre
inquiétude a grandi là je pivot est venu
perturber un régime universel qu'il
était de moins en moins qui s'annonçait
remarquablement coûteux et cheminée sans
pilote vers la catastrophe de la réforme
systémique nous étions passés au risque
systémique que cela crissée militaire a
pu nous épargner c'est donc un véritable
soulagement que nous avons noté le
renoncement à cette réforme toujours
présente sur le bureau du Sénat mais que
le gouvernement s'est bien gardé de
reprendre nous avions souligné que la
question du financement des retraites
demeurait pour des raisons qui sont
décidément têtus nous sommes attachés au
régime par répartition qui marque à la
fois la solidarité entre les générations
mais aussi une certaine garantie par
l'État de la pérennité du système pour
garantir sa pérennité son acceptation
par toutes les générations il faut
ressentir son équilibre de moyen terme
nous avons proposé des réponses qui
s'appuyaient sur un constat simple et un
choix clair nous ne trouvons pas
crédible levier de recettes
supplémentaire notre pays peine à
descendre sous un taux de prélèvement
obligatoire de près de 45 % nous
concitoyens comme la montre le épisode
de gilets jaunes sont peu enclin aller
voir augmenter nous ne souhaitons pas
affecter le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités en cette période d'inflation
et après plusieurs années de sous
revalorisation reste donc le levier du
partage d'une partie de la prolongation
de l'espérance de vie pour créer de la
richesse et consolider le système de
retraite idéalement nous devrions
pouvoir construire un consensus sur des
ajustements périodiques et la forme
qu'ils doivent prendre je regrette que
l'âge de la retraite soit devenu une
sorte de totem qui occulte tout besoin
nouveau de notre système social la
retraite n'est pas la seule question
sociale des personnes âgées j'ai
tendance à penser que leurs premier
sujet c'est la santé le sérieusement se
traduit par une épidémie de maladies
chroniques affectent la qualité de vie
et appelle un effort massif en
prévention mais aussi en prise en charge
le vieillissement c'est aussi la
préservation de l'autonomie dans toutes
ces dimensions la perte d'autonomie ne
concerne pas toute une classe d'âge mais
c'est un risque qui s'assure et si nous
devions augmenter le prélèvements
obligatoires je les affecterai plus
volontiers à une assurance de ce type
nous ne sommes pas prêts à faire face à
ce risque majeur pour notre société tant
par ces implications pour nos
concitoyens que par ses effets
budgétaires un pays qui vieillit aussi
un pays qui tend négligé sa jeunesse et
la préparation de son avenir la retraite
ne saurait être la seule perspective que
le nôtre à ceux qui ont leur vie à
construire nous devons au plus jeune une
éducation de qualité qui les prépare à
la fois leur vie de citoyens et d'actifs
dans cette économie mondialisée nous
devons famille des conditions favorables
à leur épanouissement nous devons à nos
concitoyens des services publics
efficaces et de qualité qui sont aussi
une des compétences une des composantes
de notre compétitivité faisons donc le
choix de l'équilibre de nos comptes
sociaux pour préserver non seulement les
retraites mais aussi notre capacité à
investir pour construire l'avenir on
nous reproche d'être la génération qui a
gâché la planète ne soyons pas celles
qui aura laissé dépérir faute de réforme
et de courage un système social qui fait
notre fierté collective et sans doute
une part de notre identité je vous
remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Emmanuel
Capu pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoire
merci
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
le rapporteur général Madame et Monsieur
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues
il y a toujours eu en France deux
grandes familles politiques
les cigales
et les fourmis
les cigales promettent aux Français des
droits sans savoir si la nation pourra
les financer
les fourmis ne promettent rien que la
nation ne pourra financer
j'ai pas encore dit qui était Cigale et
qui était formé
au début des années 80 la France des
cigales c'est offert accrédit la
retraite à 60 ans
cette décision était un contresens
historique majeur
à l'époque déjà tout prouve qu'il faudra
travailler plus pour équilibrer notre
système de retraite
le taux de natalité avait déjà commencé
à s'effondrer le taux de mortalité
diminuait lentement la population vivait
donc plus longtemps et se renouvelait
déjà moins vite
l'espérance de vie quand ils mettent
progressé depuis le début des années 80
le temps passé à la retraite n'a donc
jamais cessé d'augmenter
parallèlement les Français entraient de
plus en
plus de fait du travail c'est aussi l'un
des résultats de l'obsession du bac pour
tous et du grement consciencieux de
l'apprentissage
mécaniquement la proportion de retraité
par rapport aux actifs a donc augmenté
en 1960 on comptait quatre actifs sur un
retraité au début des années 80 on était
à moins de 3 pour 1 aujourd'hui serai au
est à 1,7 actif pour un retraité en 2050
ce sera un virgule deux actifs pour un
retraité
il n'y a pas de politique qui vaillent
en dehors des réalités disaient le
général de Gaulle
la politique du président Mitterrand fut
exactement l'inverse
ignorer la réalité par calcul électoral
depuis tous les gorées armements ont dû
rattraper le coup la droite la fait en
remontant l'âge légal de départ avec la
réforme werthe en 2010 la gauche l'a
fait en augmentant la durée de
cotisation avec la réforme Touraine en
on le voit le clivage politique entre
les cigales et les fourmis ne correspond
pas exactement au clivage gauche-droite
on trouve des fourmis à gauche
et on trouve des cigales à droite et à
l'extrême droite
elles sont même légion au rassemblement
national c'est un comble qui ne manque
pas de saveur les troubles de Madame Le
Pen militent aujourd'hui pour revenir à
l'air Mitterrand
les fourmis elles ont compris que
l'équilibre financier de notre système
de retraite par répartition est
gravement compromis et qu'il faut agir
pour le sauver
mais sur ce point là encore mes chers
collègues il existe deux types de
fourmis
il y a les fourmis que je qualifier
ais rouges
les fourmis rouges pensent qu'il faut
taxer davantage pour équilibrer le
système
elles oublient au passage
mes chers fourmis que nous sommes déjà
médaillés au championnat du monde des
prélèvements obligatoires
et puis il y a les autres fourmis
celles qui considèrent la solution passe
par une augmentation du temps de travail
il semble qu'on en trouve plus à
l'étranger qu'en France
les Pays-Bas l'Italie l'Allemagne ou
l'Espagne ont déjà décidé de repousser
l'âge légal de départ à 67 ans
confronté au même tendance sociétale que
nous ces pays se sont simplement rendus
à l'évidence il faut travailler plus
pour équilibrer les comptes le report de
l'âge légal à 64 ans est une mesure
raisonnable je dirais même une mesure de
bon sens
nous l'avons d'ailleurs déjà voté ici
plusieurs fois mes chers collègues
nous nourrirons pas le débat d'un report
au-delà 64 ans ce débat est pourtant
légitime nous devrions l'avoir j'ai bien
compris que le contexte politique et
social ne s'y prêtait guère
j'en profite d'ailleurs messieurs les
ministres pour saluer votre patience et
votre résistance vous avez survécu pas
ici à deux semaines de cacophonie de
vocifération à l'Assemblée nationale
bravo
certains jusqu'à maintenant s'interroger
sur l'utilité du Sénat
avec le cirque des insoumis et le
mutisme des le pénis beaucoup de
Français se demandent aujourd'hui à quoi
sert l'Assemblée nationale
j'espère donc et j'entends mes chers
collègues
que nous ne donnerons pas un tel
spectacle au Sénat du reste il n'est pas
possible de faire pire
notre groupe vous l'aurez compris mes
chers collègues soutiendra donc ce texte
sans ambiguïté
et nous serons forts de propositions
pour l'améliorer
merci mon chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue
s'il vous plaît
à notre collègue Martin lévrier pour le
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
et monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
pour une société juste et équilibrée la
solidarité est un bien précieux elle est
le ciment des liens sociaux participent
à la confiance entre les générations
elle est tout simplement le cœur de
notre cohésion sociale notre système de
retraite par répartition que bon nombre
de pays nous envie fonctionne sur la
solidarité intergénérationnelle
assurer son équilibre n'est pas un
objectif mais le moyen d'en assurer sa
pérennité fort et forme le système sera
déficitaire dès 2023 pour ne jamais
revenir à l'équilibre sans réforme le
déficit atteindra 12,4 milliards en 2027
13,5 milliards en 2030 et 21,2 milliards
en 2035 ainsi les déficits accumuler
d'ici 10 ans approcherait les 150
milliards d'euros à cela une raison
factuelle pour un pensionné on comptait
quatre cotisants en 1960 pour 2 pour 1
en 2000 aujourd'hui nous sommes à 1,7
pour 1 nous serons à 1,5 pour un en 2040
le constat est simple et sans équivoque
qui ici accepterait de baisser les
pensions qui ici aurait laissé aux
générations futures ce bijou qui est
notre système de solidarité
intergénérationnelle avec un déficit
colossal qui ici accepterait d'augmenter
les cotisations des actifs au détriment
du pouvoir d'achat ce texte permettant
de réaliser 18 milliards d'euros
d'économies à l'horizon 2030 donnera un
cadre clair et rassurant pour les
générations futures
ce plfrs aurait pu se limiter à une
recherche d'équilibre c'était le cas des
amendements déposés depuis quatre ans
par les républicains mais nous nous
devions de résorber ces inégalités
connues de longue date et restez
pendantes peiner pénalisant les plus
démunis
pour assurer l'équilibre notre système
le projet de loi allonge de 62 à 64 ans
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à
partir du 1er septembre 2023 cet âge
sera progressivement relevé à raison de
trois mois pour les générations nées
après le premier septembre 1961 l'âge
d'ouverture à la retraite sera portée à
63 ans et 3 mois en 2027 pour atteindre
64 ans en 2030 dans le même temps le
projet de loi propose l'accélération de
la réforme Touraine sans toucher à l'âge
de la décote qui dois-je le rappeler a
été initié sous présidence socialiste
ainsi une fois l'équilibre de systèmes
assurés cette réforme ambitionne de le
rendre plus juste
il importe donc au Sénat dont nous
connaissons tous l'esprit de
responsabilité au travers du PLF SS de
permettre entre autres une meilleure
prise en compte des carrières hachées
notamment pour les aidants une meilleure
prise en compte des carrières longues
avec une adaptation du dispositif pour
les actifs ayant commencé à travailler
tôt une meilleure prise en compte de la
pénibilité permise par la négociation
avec les syndicats initiés il y a trois
mois par le gouvernement
l'accès aux comptes professionnels de
prévention sera élargi et un fonds
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle sera créée et
dotée de 1 milliard sur le quinquennat
les soignants des établissements
médicaux sociaux de la fonction publique
hospitalière et de la fonction publique
territoriale seront ainsi mieux protégés
dans l'exercice de métier pénible
ce texte apporte par ailleurs des
mesures spécifiques au Seigneur à date
seul 23000 salariés utilisent le
dispositif de retraite progressive il
permet pourtant une véritable transition
entre vie active et retraite en
permettant à un salarié sur le point de
partir de réduire son temps de travail
tout en commençant à percevoir une
partie de sa pension de retraite la
réforme entend ce dispositif au libéraux
et aux agents publics par ailleurs le
cumul emploi retraite qui bénéficie
aujourd'hui à 500 000 retraités sera
grand du créateur de droits
supplémentaires à la retraite enfin ce
texte apportera une meilleure protection
du pouvoir d'achat
1,8 millions de retraités pourrait si le
texte était voté bénéficier d'une
revalorisation de leur pension de base
de 600 euros par an en moyenne un futur
retraité sur 4 pourrait voir sa pension
augmentée dans moyenne 400 euros par an
mais au-delà de ses moyennes cette
réforme vise particulièrement à revenir
sur nombre de situations inégales je
pense que particulièrement aux retraites
agricoles et aux cas très précis des
agriculteurs qui conserveront leur taux
plein même pour un départ pour
inaptitude ou invalidité c'est
revalorisations votées dans les textes
précédents ne ratez pas ouverte cela
sera chose faite mes chers collègues
vous le voyez c'est un texte déjà très
fourni qui nous est proposé
force de proposition lorsqu'il s'agit
d'améliorer le quotidien des Français
notre groupe déposera des amendements
parmi lesquels un amendement pour
permettre le rachat de ces trimestres de
stage à un tarif préférentiel jusqu'à un
âge défini par décret sans que celui-ci
ne puisse être inférieur à 25 ans un
amendement pour permettre le rachat de
cette trimestres d'études à tarif
préférentiel jusqu'à un âge défini par
décret sans que celui-ci ne puisse
inférieur à 30 ans un amendement
pourrait-on rendre la majoration de la
pension de 10% pour trois enfants aux
professions libérales au prochain
libéraux pardon mes chers collègues
notre démocratie parlementaire a été
profondément blessée par des débats
parasités et des comportements non
républicains voient révolutionnaires à
l'Assemblée nationale
les Français dans leur grande majorité
attendent de nous un tout autre
comportement un comportement responsable
de la part de ceux qui les représentent
au-delà de l'âge au Delage au-delà de
l'âge de départ à la retraite nous ne
pouvons faire l'impasse de tous les
autres sujets abordés dans ce texte
pénibilité précarité carrière arraché
égalité femme homme
l'examen au Sénat du PLFSS 2023 qui
comportait 112 articles a été battue
autour de 1142 amendements l'examen du
PLFR SS comporte plus de 2700
amendements pour 20 articles je ne veux
pas croire que cette comparaison donner
réponse
les Français attendent un débat de
controverse nous devons d'avoir le
courage d'étudier l'ensemble du PLFSS au
même titre que cette réforme est
courageuse dans un contexte difficile
pour tous faire fi du déficit à venir
c'est mettre à mal son existence et
l'idée même de ce qu'il représente notre
groupe sera attaché à examiner ce texte
dans son intégralité il y a le voter
pour l'avenir de notre système je vous
remercie merci
nous sommes toujours en direct ce public
snail il est 17h à 57 il reste encore 5
orateurs dans la discussion générale qui
sert d'introduction au débat sur la
réforme des retraites puis il y aura la
réponse des ministres principaux c'est
Bernard jaumier pour les socialistes
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame lapinente madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues la réalité de cette
réforme que vous nous soumettez c'est
que son inspiration purement financière
en porte de multiples conséquences
sociales que vous avez successivement
niéisé puis tenté de colmater jusqu'à un
texte qui est constellé de rustine je
voudrais que parler de la réalité des
fins de carrière que votre réforme au
fond détériore profondément cette
réalité ce sont des dispositifs de prise
en charge réduit de la pénibilité c'est
une adaptation insuffisante est souvent
inexistante d'ailleurs des postes de
travail ce sont des arrêts maladie à
répétition pour soutenir qu'un cas les
salariés à flot
comme l'avait justement révélé la
candidate des républicains à l'élection
présidentielle l'espérance de vie sans
incapacité en Suède et de près de 72 ans
l'âge de départ à la retraite oui et a
été repoussé à 65 ans et donc vous vous
voulez repousser l'âge légal à 64 ans en
France alors que l'espérance de vie
moyenne sans incapacité atteint
difficilement justement cet âge le
granion social de cette espérance de vie
sont cinq capacités signe à lui seul
l'injustice de votre choix car c'est un
choix de rééquilibrer le régime des
retraites sans faire appel au plus
favoriser la réalité c'est que repousser
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
revient à fabriquer de la maladie à
dégrader les fins de carrière
il est intéressant de regarder les
conséquences de la réforme de 2010 qui a
repoussé l'âge légal de départ de deux
ans à 62 ans elles sont parlante en 2019
la Cour des comptes a relevé une hausse
de 800 millions d'euros du coût annuel
des arrêts maladie 6 ans après le report
de l'âge légal de départ à 62 ans elle
en a attribué une large part à ce report
le mois dernier l'étude du CNAM a
confirmé ce phénomène le report à 62 ans
a provoqué une augmentation
significative de la fréquence des arrêts
maladie
il faut donc prendre en charge la
pénibilité et adapter les postes or à la
matière presque tout reste à faire vous
qui avez supprimé la prise en charge de
4 facteurs de pénibilité vous ne
réalisez les rétablissez même pas tous
par exemple au lieu de balayer la
question des agents chimiques dangereux
complexes il faudrait au contraire mener
un vrai travail sur les activités
responsables des missions d'aérosols
dangereux sur le fondement des
nombreuses bases de données qui existent
et il faut aller plus loin réserver les
postes les moins pénibles aux plus âgés
favoriser le recours effectif au C2P qui
n'est mobilisé que par 6 personnes et
l’égypes sur 1000 et prévenir les
risques bref mener une politique de
prévention c'est un effort qui s'est
révélé payant dans les pays qui en est
ont déployé les moyens mais le virage de
la prévention de novembre dernier à
percuté le mur de Bercy et ce texte
n'est pas une loi de finance sociale
c'est une loi de Bercy les français eux
ils ont tout compris cette réforme
financière vous voulez l'imposer à leurs
dépens dans les petites villes sur tout
le territoire ce sont des visages qui
travaillent monsieur le ministre et
souvent pour peu de revenus qui se
révoltent ce ne sont pas des inactifs
non plus
ces personnes ces Français il est temps
de les écouter avant que le sourd
sentiment qui traverse le pays ne porte
d'autres conséquences nous avons élu un
chef de l'État pour qu'il fasse barrage
à l'extrême droite nous ne l'avons pas
élu pour qu'ils défendent un projet qui
ajoute du carburant à son moteur je vous
remercie
merci
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Jean-Marie van lerenberg pour
le groupe de l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur les ministres madame la
Présidente de la Commission mesdames
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues veut-on d'un doux mensonge ou
d'une amère vérité
celle-ci malheureusement est claire le
système des retraites par répartition
est menacé
faut-il donc le réformer la réponse de
notre groupe c'est le cas rappelé le
président Marseille tout à l'heure
éclaire et sans ambiguïté c'est oui d'un
système conçu
à l'origine avec quatre cotisants pour
un retraité ce ratio tombent aujourd'hui
à 1,7 cotisants pour un retraité c'est
un déséquilibre évident incontestable et
qui s'accroît avec l'espérance de vie
d'aucun pensent que les hommes mentent
les chiffres un peu moins le corps
conseille d'orientation des retraites
c'est soudainement retrouvé sous les
feux de la rampe des rapports en général
indigestes sont devenus malgré eux
livrent d'éveil pour pas dire de chevet
pour certains irresponsables politiques
car il s'agit bien d'irresponsabilités à
ne retenir du corps que le seul fait que
des dépenses soient sous contrôle
c'est négliger le sujet de la dette la
dette retraite et déjà très élevée 43
milliards portés par la Cadès c'est
négliger aussi que les déficits cumulés
selon le corps d'ailleurs
représenteront 150 milliards de dettes
nouvelles en 2030 alors fallait-il
réformer dès maintenant
nous répondons encore 800 hésiter en
matière climatique on parle volontiers
d'urgence de ce que nous laisserons à
nos enfants et petits-enfants il en est
de même pour les retraites et notamment
pour les jeunes qui croient de moins en
moins qu'ils en auront une
le Sénat dans sa sagesse d'ailleurs n'a
pas attendu l'agenda gouvernementale
pour réformer il adopte depuis plusieurs
années le recul progressif de l'âge de
départ à 64 ans avec l'accélération de
la loi Touraine bien plus juste car
recul brutal à 65 ans
la réforme proposée est-elle adaptée
notre réponse c'est encore affirmatif
sinon on accepte comme postulat de ne
pas augmenter les cotisations retraite
afin de ne pas
affaiblir pardon le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés pour lequel évidemment nous
sommes d'accord
mais en ce qui concerne la création
d'emplois j'en doute en effet admis
point de plus de cotisations employeur
représente 4 milliards et demi de
recettes en moyenne 225 euros par
salarié par an
c'est pour une entreprise de 100
salariés un peu moins qu'un poste de
travail
donc cette réforme est-elle
satisfaisante d'un point de vue
comptable oui d'un point de vue social
et politique on peut en débattre et
c'est bien cela d'ailleurs auquel nous
sommes conviés d'un point de vue social
les 17 milliards sept dégagés en 2030
permettront de financer 6 milliards de
mesure de solidarité et d'un point de
vue politique l'évidence c'est que les
Français n'admettent pas le recul de
l'âge à 64 ans considérant à juste titre
que seuls les salariés sont mis à
contribution une autre solution serait
évidemment d'augmenter la taxation du
capital est-ce que c'est envisageable et
bien c'est une question que je pose au
gouvernement et à ceux qui seraient
tentés de prendre tout le plat dans leur
assiette pour citer la des pierres
au nom de la solidarité nationale il ne
me paraît ni outrageant ni indécent que
les bénéficiaires d'un CAC 40 au plus
haut actuellement accepte une
augmentation de la CSG sur le capital
un point supplémentaire rapporterait un
milliard 5 alors abordons maintenant
quelques articles rapidement
saluons tout d'abord les propositions du
gouvernement pour tenter d'améliorer la
justice et l'équité du système
nous avons quelques questions parce que
certaines mesures pour certaines mesures
le diable on le sait se cache dans les
détails pour les petites retraites tout
le monde a retenu qu'il n'y aurait pas
de retraite à moins de 1200 euros mais
peu on comprit que cela concernait que
les carrières complètes alors il
suggestion celle de Lucas qui me paraît
intelligente et intelligible pourquoi ne
pas mettre un plancher à 75% du SMIC
soit 1000 euros pour les carrières
incomplètes
pour les carrières longues
le dispositif paraît serpenté de façon
erratique entre 43 et 44 ans de durée de
cotisation en fonction de l'entrée dans
la vie active il nous apparaît
nécessaire de lisser l'ensemble avec
donc des départs de 57 à 62 ans de quoi
ouvrir une fenêtre d'ailleurs de départ
de 57 à 64 ans chers aux économistes
Blanchard et Tyrol et beaucoup plus
jeune que juste qu'une borne unique de
départ à 64 ans
pour les seniors le gouvernement a
décidé de s'intéresser aux fins de
carrière mais je crains que l'index
Seigneur proposait une Swagger suffisant
pour répondre à l'intention qu'il
manifeste il nous semble que c'est index
doit être accompagné d'une prime à
l'embauche sorte de un seigneur une
solution et que pourquoi pas d'ailleurs
un CDI senior et nous devrions pas faire
l'économie d'un bonus malus sur la base
de cette index pour favoriser le
maintien des seniors dans l'emploi
pour les droits familiaux
nous proposions donc avant la hache de
l'article 40 un départ anticipé à 62 ans
pour trois enfants et 63 ans pour deux
mais nous constatons aussi de fortes
disparité dans les droits familiaux la
réversion particulière ou 13 régimes
subsistent et qu'il sera nécessaire de
revoir dans la prochaine loi enfin
la pénibilité la Pénélope du travail que
l'on s'y arrête un petit peu plus nous y
sommes attentifs bien entendu nous
sommes attentifs à la réflexion aussi
sur le travail la nécessité de lui
donner plus de sens nous sommes aussi
tous aussi vigilants face à ceux qui
contesteraient la valeur du travail il
n'appartient pourtant pas à cette loi de
financement évidemment de la sécurité
sociale de traiter de ce sujet beaucoup
trop complexe où tous les points de vue
divers se vend suivant évidemment le
point dont de duquel on se on se place
du point de vue de quel on se place
alors faisons venons-en à ce qui nous
préoccupe vraiment c'est à dire réparer
l'usure professionnelle la loi dans ce
domaine est généreuse elle prend en
compte les trois autres critères
d'ergonomiques qui donneront lieu à un
suivi médical c'est bien mais il nous
paraît nécessaire de compléter ce bilan
avec un bilan de compétences pour
envisager l'avenir sérieusement enfin un
mot pour conclure sur ce qui nous tient
à cœur à nous Centris le dialogue social
nous regrettons qu'il est tourné court
que certains partenaires sociaux et
responsables politiques et refusé
d'emblée le diagnostic du corps du corps
avant d'y consenti que d'autres est crus
que la désinformation est listerie
pouvait remplacer le débat aussi ce vrai
débat que chacun mérite et qui pourra je
l'espère se nouer ici au Sénat aucune
réponse n'est faite pour l'éternité
plusieurs dates Allonnes de décennies de
réforme des retraites si ajoutera sans
aucun doute 2023 et peut-être aussi 2027
avec la réforme présidentielle pour cela
nous pensons qu'il est bon qui est une
clause de revoyure ou plutôt un bilan
d'étape produit par la Cour des comptes
afin d'assurer peut-être la série dineté
du débat qui suivra comme celui qui je
l'espère pourra se dérouler ici demain
dans cette assemblée merci beaucoup
merci
voilà prochaine orateur Bruno Retailleau
le chef de fil des sénateurs LR ici à la
Chambre haute il va pouvoir défendre
notamment ses amendements voulu par la
majorité de la droite et du centre le
CDI pour les seniors ou encore la
surcotte pour les mers ou encore le
retour de l'index pour les seniors le
chef de file d'air qui dispose de 12
minutes à la tribune c'est parti
président de la commission madame
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
pour lever tout suspense je voudrais
dire que bien sûr nous allons voter un
texte qui sera notre texte
c'est à dire que nous voterons la
réforme une réforme modifiée une réforme
que nous allons amender selon les
prescriptions
qu'il a fait avec pédagogie qui avec
humour du docteur sur le rapporteur René
Paul Savary
de quoi aurions-nous l'air mes chers
collègues si nous refusions de voter une
réforme que nous votons ici chaque année
depuis plusieurs années nous ne sommes
pas des girouettes notre boussole ce
n'est pas email Macron ça n'est pas le
gouvernement c'est l'intérêt national
c'est le seul international et je crois
que
[Applaudissements]
ce sont les têtes à queue et je pense
que le Sénat Sonora de travailler avec
constance bien sûr et cohérence nous en
avons monsieur le ministre Gabriel Attal
et je pense que la politique pour ce qui
me concerne et j'en suis même intimement
convaincu ce qu'il l'honore c'est de
pouvoir tenir un discours de vérité la
vérité mes chers collègues aujourd'hui
c'est de dire par exemple quand 2030
quand la réforme va s'appliquer nous
aurons en France le régime le plus
avantageux en matière d'âge de départ à
la retraite en Europe nous aurons aussi
le régime le plus avantageux d'Europe
notamment pour ce qui concerne les
carrières longues c'est une vérité c'est
un fait incontestable la vérité est de
reconnaître que oui la réforme est une
réforme budgétaire
elle est évidemment budgétaire
perdez-moi de vous dire qu'elle est
accessoirement budgétaire oui et les
budgétaire parce que elle doit faire
face aux chiffres qui viennent encore
une fois d'être énoncé ici 150 milliards
de déficits cumulés sur 10 ans et encore
avec des hypothèses macroéconomiques
extrêmement favorables un taux de
chômage à 4,5 % avec
toujours plus de pensionnés de retraités
toujours moins de cotisons comment il
fait-on face et il s'agit bien sûr de
sauver un régime auquel on tient tous
par-delà de nos divergence de nos
différences partisanes mais
voulons-nous demain garantir le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités
voulons-nous demain que nos jeunes on
leur impose de payer deux retraites la
note et puis la leur non il faut
réformer bien sûr et quand j'entends
dire que il faut pas regarder les
chiffres que sais-tu fétichisme
comptable mais derrière les chiffres
derrière les chiffres il y a l'argent
des Français derrière l'argent les
Français il y a la peine des Français
est-ce que ça ne vaut pas le coup qu'on
en prenne un peu soin mes chers
collègues alors si Monsieur les
ministres je l'ai souvent dit je l'ai
même répété parfois si le point de
départ de cette réforme ce sont des
déficits le point d'arrivée de la
réforme ça ne peut pas être non plus des
déficits il y a pire il y a bien pire
que de demander aux Français des efforts
c'est demander des efforts aux Français
pour rien
le cas si en 2030 la réforme ne serait
pas équilibrée et nous allons proposer
un certain nombre de pistes notamment
d'économies sur la fraude certains en
ont cités ici bien sûr bien entendu sur
la biométrie vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur ministre mais aussi sur
l'alignement notamment pour le mineur
social des conditions de résidence
pourquoi est-ce que il y a pas les mêmes
conditions de résidence quand on verse
le RSA ou quand on verse pas évidemment
et
nous amendements vont enrichir
raisonnablement avec un coû raisonnable
bien loin monsieur le ministre des 6
millions d'euros de mesure
d'accompagnement sans doute parfois
légitime ces milliards pardon bien sûr 6
milliards sur les 17,7 milliards que
prévoit comme marge financière la
réforme et ça pour nous c'est un point
quand je disais que c'était une réforme
budgétaire bien sûr mais qu'elle n'était
budgétaire qu'accessoirement c'est parce
que fondamentalement peut-être qu'on
sera d'accord non pas sur le sens mais
au moins sur ce que je vais dire c'est
que cette réforme porte en elle une
vision de la société un projet de
société
et que c'est une réforme globale
certains même avaient indiqué c'était la
merde de toutes les réformes c'est une
réforme globale parce que elle
récapitule de nombreuses enjeux au moins
3 pour moi et à mes yeux sont les trois
enjeux les plus importants premier enjeu
le modèle social avec un régime de
retraite par répartition
qui permet justement de donner du sens
au lien entre les générations qui permet
de donner du sens à ce que nous sommes
au fait que nous ne sommes pas
simplement un agrégat de communauté ou
d'individus mais que nous sommes une
nation un peuple dépendant les uns des
autres c'est ça la signification du
régime par répartition que nous voulons
sauver un régime
qu'on peut toujours tenter d'améliorer
mais qui est généreux cela a été dit
mais la proportion n'a pas été cité ici
je voudrais la cité
peut le site en général pourquoi en
France parmi les grands pays de la
France et le pays où la proportion de
pauvres âgées de plus de 65 ans et le
plus faible
2,5 x - par rapport à la moyenne des
pays européens c'est cela qu'on tente
aussi
de changer mais aussi de conserver de
préserver c'est ce qui est absolument
fondamental mais évidemment la
générosité va avec l'exigence exigence
de lutte contre les fautes exigences de
justice de justice vis-à-vis aussi des
régimes sociaux pourquoi est-ce que on
attend 43 ans pour les faire converger
est-ce que le sort d'une infirmière
est-ce que le sort d'une infirmière ne
mérite pas moins
que celui d'un conducteur de la retapé
ou de la SNCF nous déposerons bien sûr
un amendement c'est une question de
justice et croyez-moi ces populaires et
croyez-moi ces populaires
croyez-moi ces populaires deuxième enjeu
la démographie parce que un système
intergénérationnel c'est un système
démographique Auguste Comte un jour
avait dit très justement la démographie
c'est le destin oui c'est le destin d'un
régime par répartition son
renouvellement générationnel peut pas y
avoir de solidarité c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ne voulons pas que cette
réforme se fasse sur le dos des femmes
des maires de famille qui ont eu des
enfants et qui travailler et qui ont eu
des carrières complètes qui n'ont pas
souvent eu d'ailleurs le loisir de
s'arrêter longtemps qui ont dû bosser
parfois parce qu'elles élevaient seuls
des enfants parfois parce que leur mari
avait de petits salaires et qu'il
fallait aussi payer les tracts de la
famille et bien oui et bien oui nous
proposerons avec courage et avec fierté
pour ces maires de famille une surcote
on leur doit bien mes chers amis on leur
doit bien
troisième enjeu troisième enjeu pour
parler d'un enjeu de société important
quelle société voulons nous
est-ce que c'est la société
du droit à la paresse ou est-ce que
c'est la société du travail est-ce que
c'est la société de la décroissance du
déclassement collectif
ou la société de la pauvrissement
individuel la société de cette
appauvrissement ou cette société que
nous appelons nos vœux de la prospérité
pour tous pour chacun mais aussi de la
croissance c'est ce que nous voulons et
pourquoi donc le rapport des Français au
travail s'étend dégradé sans doute il y
a eu l'épidémie sans doute il y a eu la
covid mais je pense que la raison
fondamentale de la dégradation du
rapport des Français au travail c'est
qu'il y a trop de Français aujourd'hui
qui ne parviennent pas à vivre du fruit
de leur travail et ça c'est le produit
[Applaudissements]
écoutez moi vous n'aurez pas à faire un
ingrat et ça c'est le produit d'un
mensonge vieux de 40 ans
Dieu de 40 ans le boniment de sel et de
ceux qui nous ont vendus la retraite à
60 ans les semaines au 35 heures celles
et ceux qui ont dit aux Français qu'il
vivrait toujours mieux en travaillant
[Applaudissements]
par
le résultat nous le voyons la richesse
par habitant c'est-à-dire le niveau de
vie des Français à dégringolé au 26e
rang il est là le résultat et il est
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues tant de
sortir de ce mensonge de tenir un
discours de vérité aux Français ce qui
peut permettre demain d'améliorer le
pouvoir d'achat le niveau de vie c'est
la prospérité pour tous c'est le salaire
bien sûr mais c'est aussi la création de
richesse grâce au travail
d'où le recul des deux années pour l'âge
de départ à la retraite c'est
fondamental je sais que ce recul il est
exigeant je sais qu'il est un populaire
ce que je veux dire aussi c'est que bien
sûr que c'est un levier budgétaire mais
que c'est surtout un filet de sécurité
le ministre je l'entendais tout à
l'heure parler de machines à la décote
bien sûr c'est un filet de sécurité là
de départ contre ces décotes massives
qui créeraient sinon des travailleurs
pauvres relaient l'excellente simulation
de la CNAV qui a simulé ce que fait une
réforme avec un allongement de la Dar de
la durée de cotisation et une autre
hypothèse avec le recul de la borne
d'âge mais surtout et j'en viens la
prospérité croyez-vous que la France
puisse s'en tirer en travaillant
toujours moins et bien le recul de l'âge
procure un autre avantage c'est que nous
allons automatiquement mécaniquement
augmenter le taux d'emploi des seniors
et donc mettre plus de travail dans la
machine
[Applaudissements]
voilà et ça c'est fondamental
aujourd'hui la croissance de demain elle
est opérée elle est obérée par une
productivité qui est tombée elle est
obérée par une durée du travail qui est
en berne elle est obérée par un taux
d'emploi qui est l'un des plus faibles
de tous les pays européens voilà et bien
entendu nous voulons améliorer les
conditions d'emploi des seniors et
Monsieur le Ministre la proposition que
a fait notre commission est une
proposition qui n'est pas un caprice
vraiment je vous demande d'y prendre
garde ça fait partie des points qui pour
nous sont essentiels l'index est une
statistique un contrat de fin de
carrière c'est bien autre chose c'est un
outil beaucoup plus opérant et pour
terminer
mes chers collègues nous aurons ici
chacun peut le dire avec ces mots mais
je pense qu'on peut se rejoindre quel
que soit nos appartenances partisanes
nos divergences politiques nous avons
ici un rôle important à jouer nous
sommes le Sénat nous sommes la Haute
Assemblée nous avons chacun d'entre nous
une responsabilité et je sais que et je
le sais par avance que le débat il sera
passionné mais il sera raisonné que le
débat il sera parfois rugueux évidemment
nous n'avons pas les mêmes convictions
d'ailleurs je suis assez heureux de voir
que ce débat ressuscite un peu le vieux
clivage droite-gauche ça n'est pas moi
qui ça n'est pas moi qui vais le
regretter vous le savez bien vous me
connaissez
mais ce que je veux dire ce que je veux
vous dire c'est que le Parlement c'est
la représentation la représentation des
Français c'est pas la guignolisation et
que la politique c'est pas la guerre
c'est pas l'institutionnalisation de la
violence dans un hémicycle la politique
c'est la démocratie la démocratie Ie
c'est le moyen c'est cette invention la
belle invention qu'on trouvait le plus
anciens pour canaliser la violence
justement dans le débat et notamment
dans l'espace public voilà c'est nous
qui avons cette tâche mes chers
collègues sénateurs ici au Sénat de
relever le défi d'un débat respectueux
mais d'un débat qui a jusqu'au vote
parce que ne me dites pas que un bon
débat ce serait simplement un débat
calme et respectueux non
le Parlement les parlementaires c'est
fait pour voter après un débat mais
c'est fait pour voter j'entends que vous
voulez voter l'article 7 ça signifie
monsieur le Président ça signifie donc
que le 8 le 9 le 10 les petites
retraites la validité la question
notamment des travailleurs handicapés
toutes ces questions là ne mériteraient
pas un débat ne mériterait pas un vote
et bien si nous voulons aller au bout du
texte nous le devons pour les Français
et pour nous c'est un devoir
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Daniel
Chassain pour de gros plus indépendants
République et territoire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président
Monsieur les ministres madame la
Présidente de la Commission mesdames
Messieurs le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
carrière longue emploi des seniors
retraite des femmes retraite progressive
avant d'en arriver à un projet de loi eu
lieu était heureux de commencer par une
loi travail qui aurait permis de traiter
ces différents sujets avec les
partenaires sociaux pour autant ce
projet de loi là il nous doit en
débattre de façon sérieuse avec toute la
responsabilité qui nous incombe je
voudrais tout d'abord féliciter et
remercier Elisabeth Doisneau et René
Paul Savary pour leurs exposer
complémentaires et très complet ils ont
présenté les enjeux de la pérennisation
de notre système de santé mais aussi des
propositions claires et précises qui
permettent d'améliorer ce texte
le fait hélas ça a été dit par mon
collègue Emmanuel le nombre d'actifs
pour un retraité ne cesse de diminuer de
4 en 1970 il est passé à 1 à 2 en 2000
1,7 en 2020
17 millions de retraités en 2020 25 en
2050 le corps annonce un déficit de 14
milliards d'ici 2030 26 en 2040 par an
avec un chômage à 5% et optimiste
indiquant aussi une détérioration bien
sûr de notre système de retraite et donc
celle de la sécurité sociale
cela malgré les lois de 2004 2010 et
2014 sous la présidence de François
Hollande qui est allongé la durée de
cotisation à 43 ennuités votez selon la
loi Touraine je rappelle que ce projet
de loi accélère effectivement le
calendrier de cette mesure mais n'en
remet pas en cause l'objectif si vous
êtes né en 71 travailler à partir de à
21 ans et bien vous aurez votre retraite
en 2035 pleine à 64 ans nous devons
permettre de sauver notre système de
retraite par répartition
issue du CNR en 1945 sans laisser une
désastreuse à nos enfants tout en
conservant le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités nous ont amélioré ce projet
valoriser davantage de la maternité des
femmes à ce titre j'ai proposé un
amendement nous avons le taux de seniors
au travail le plus bas d'Europe 36%
entre
et 64 ans se pencher de loi ne doit pas
les précariser il doit au contraire
retrouver un emploi une place peut-être
dans le tutorat la formation la retraite
progressive avec l'article 2 nous devons
faire de l'emploi des seniors une
priorité en améliore en sensiblement
l'index dans les entreprises avec une
politique volontariste en faveur de
recrutement et du maintien dans l'emploi
la proposition du rapporteur René Paul
Savary nous paraît avec une avec un
seigneur une solution nous paraît tout à
fait être en cohérence pour améliorer
sensiblement l'emploi des seniors sur
l'article 8 notamment les carrières
longues il est essentiel que les
personnes ayant commencé à travailler
avant 16-18 ou 20 ans puisse partir
après 43 ans l'article 9 peut également
être amélioré afin de mieux prendre en
compte et valider valoriser l'usure
professionnelle avec un suivi médical
plus régulier et le rétablissement de
certains critères de pénibilité dans le
compte de prévention en associant les
partenaires sociaux
sur l'article 10 les aidants devraient
être aussi mieux pris en compte
revalorisation de certaines pensions les
plus faibles à 85% du SMIC constituent
constituerait un progrès toutefois
monsieur le ministre il faudra que nous
apportiez plus de précision est-ce que
les agriculteurs retraités les artisans
carrière complète auront bien 1200 euros
et ainsi que les autres retraités après
l'article 13 ce projet améliore
sensiblement le dispositif emploi
retraite votée en 2014 et permettra
désormais aux retraités qui reprennent
une nouvelle activité de nouveaux droits
c'était une carence qui a notamment
démotivée d'ailleurs beaucoup de
médecins retraités à effectuer des
remplacements il est toutefois
nécessaire d'ouvrir plus largement la
retraite progressive et assurer
pleinement les conditions de départ
anticiper des personnes handicapées en
conclusion
il est regrettable que le gouvernement
n'est pas mobilisé en amont les
partenaires sociaux pour mettre en place
une loi travail cela à mon avis aurait
été nécessaire bien sûr le travail des
rapporteurs et leur connaissance du
dossier ont permis d'amander ce projet
et d'apporter une autre dimension à ce
texte notamment sur l'emploi des seniors
la prévention de l'usure les carrières
des femmes nous espérons que notre
travail ici au Sénat contribuera
l'amération de ce texte et apportera
pour nos enfants pour les futurs
retraités un équilibre pérenne du budget
de retraite avec un pouvoir d'achat
conservé et par la même un équilibre de
la sécurité sociale colonne vertébrale
de notre démocratie je vous remercie
merci mon chers collègues la parole est
à notre collègue victoire
jasminant sa chemine tout doucement vers
la fin de cette discussion générale il
reste une oratrice la sénatrice de
Guadeloupe victoire jasmin ensuite les
ministres vont pouvoir répondre
retour à l'hémicycle
et bien les données que je vais être
transmettre ici c'est un compte
également de la j'espère que pour les
territoire d'outre-mer vous avez vu
évidemment de quoi je parle cette
réforme est juste injustifiée aura des
effets néfastuensemble des populations
des territoires d'outre-mer comment
expliquer qu'aucune est une préalable
n'a été menée pour prendre en compte la
réalité de ces territoires dans ce
projet de loi les conséquences de vos
choix seront irréversibles dans un
contexte de chômage des jeunes déflation
de vie chers et de démographie
déséquilibré par idéologie et en
s'appuyant lorsque les éléments d'un
langage effondré le gouvernement a
décidé d'imposer son projet
machiavélique en limitant à 10 jours le
débat parlementaire au Sénat c'est tout
à fait regrettable
une application différentielle de la
réforme et pourtant un impératif
indispensable quand on connaît la
précarité les conditions de vie les
retraités ultramarins et
particulièrement des femmes je l'ai
évoqué d'ailleurs il y a quelques jours
lors des questions au gouvernement ce
sera une véritable catastrophe humaine
sociale économique et systémique avec
des conséquences graves pour les futurs
retraités bien sûr mais aussi pour les
collectivités locales en Guadeloupe les
acteurs de terrain tels que les CCAS il
est à 15 général de sécurité sociale
servent aujourd'hui le rempart face aux
inégalités qui existent déjà et qui
caractérisent le travail le marché du
travail et donc la retraite face aux
conséquences de la pénibilité et
particulièrement les conséquences du
chlore des cône sur notre territoire ou
encore de la vie chère les disparités en
notre mère et en hexagone sont pourtant
connus les défauts de déclaration et la
maltraitance institutionnelle contribue
énormément au nombre de courroies dans
ce territoire en raison de l'étroitesse
du marché de travail les salariés des
autres mères ont trois fois plus de
beaucoup de carrière que la moyenne
nationale ils ont des carrières
particulièrement hachées et on constate
qu'ils sont déjà contraints à partir
plus tardivement à la retraite 65 ans en
moyenne en Guadeloupe contre 60 degrés 7
au niveau national en moyenne rallonger
de 2 ans la durée de cotisation c'est
condamné mécaniquement les salariés des
Outre-mer à partir encore plus
tardivement à la retraite avec des
problèmes de santé et vous le savez pour
les cancers des prostate notamment et
pour les femmes des cancers du sein et
des situations de grande pauvreté en
plus en effet les niveaux de pension
sont inférieurs de 10 à 17 % par rapport
à ceux de l'Hexagone dans un contexte
d'inflation permanente 9 à 15% des
retraités des outre-merce non considérés
comme étant en grande pauvreté contre 1%
en moyenne au niveau national en
Martinique 24% des pensionnés sont
bénéficiaires du minimum contributif
dans 18% du micro majoré les
travailleurs indépendants les
agriculteurs et surtout les femmes sont
de plus en plus nombreuses
solliciter la SPA l'ancien minier mon
vieillesse le nombre d'allocations a
augmenté entre 2017 de 2017 à 2022
depuis le 40% d'ailleurs en Guadeloupe
mais des questions restent en suspens
concernant la décongivialisation de la
prestation et concernant le montant du
seuil de recouvrement sur l'actif
successoral en fait une concertation
avec les syndicats et les employeurs
publics est nécessaire pour une
véritable prise en compte des
différentes primes dans ce dans celui
des fonctionnaires monsieur le ministre
monsieur les ministres mes chers
collègues vous constatez donc que les
sujets des réformes de retraite en
outre-mer sont très nombreux et très
spécifiques pour mériter plus de
concertation de différenciation la
chambre des territoires le Sénat doit
écouter et entendre les Français je vous
remercie merci monsieur
voilà c'est la fin de la discussion
générale que vous avez pu écouter depuis
14h30 sur l'antenne de Public Sénat tous
les groupes politiques ont pu s'exprimer
maintenant la réponse des ministres avec
Olivier du stock ministre du Travail
en écho différentes interventions
d'abord pour vous remercier de ces
interventions et de ce débats qui
s'ouvrent aujourd'hui puisque dans
chacune des interventions à la tribune
sont exprimés à la fois des oppositions
des soutiens des nuances et je pense que
cela augure de débat qui nous
permettront d'avancer sur un certain
nombre de points la première remarque
que je voulais faire concerne l'objectif
de la réforme que nous menons je l'ai
dit mais je le répète café écola aussi
de nombreuses interventions nous voulons
faire cette réforme pour ramener le
système à l'équilibre tout en améliorant
si nous nous contentions de l'améliorer
ça ne serait pas très responsable ce
serait plus facile mais ça ne serait pas
très responsable si nous nous
contentions de le ramener à l'équilibre
par des mesures purement budgétaires
sans mettre à profit cette occasion de
débat pour corriger des inégalités pour
présenter un certain nombre de nouveaux
droits mieux prendre en compte la
pénibilité ou encore relever les petites
pensions j'y reviendrai
nous devons malgré tout et faire cela en
gardant le cap de l'équilibre la réforme
telle que nous vous la proposons va
générer environ 18 milliards d'euros
17,7 milliards d'euros selon les
prévisions qui ont été partagées par les
seules mesures d'âge nous avons prévu
d'augmenter légèrement le taux de
cotisation la CNRS et je sais
l'attachement de votre assemblée à ce
que la loi telle que nous l'examinons
garantissent la bonne compensation pour
les employeurs concernés hospitaliers et
territoriaux nous pourrons avancer sur
ce sujet là nous avons aussi proposé
pour rester dans les bornes du système
de retraite que le taux de cotisation
ATMP des employeurs puissent être
légèrement réduit la branche à TMP étant
excédentaire à hauteur d'environ 20% de
ses recettes globales pour à contrario
augmenter légèrement le taux de
cotisation des employeurs et la CNAV et
ainsi générer un milliard d'euros
supplémentaires dans le cadre du système
de retraite c'est ainsi que nous
arrivons autour de 19, milliards d'euros
de retraite en 2030 et c'est 19,5
milliards d'euros nous permettent à la
fois de financer les mesures nouvelles
les mesures d'accompagnement mais aussi
de résorber le déséquilibre le
déséquilibre prévu pour 2030
c'est-à-dire 13 milliards 5 pour être
tout à fait complet il y a un certain
nombre de mesures qui sont annoncées ou
qui sont envisagés je pense pour les
mesures envisagées un amendement qui
tient beaucoup pour beaucoup de cœur à
monsieur le rapporteur sur la retraite
anticipée pour les salariés en
incapacité permanente qui peut faire un
débat budgétaire Gabriel l'a rappelé je
pense à des mesures annoncées par le
gouvernement comme le financement du
Fonds de prévention l'usure
professionnelle dont les dépenses ne
relèvent pas du système de retraite mais
plutôt de la branche ATMP mais nous
savons la capacité de celle-ci à faire
face-temps à la modulation des taux
casser les pensent supplémentaires que
nous proposons de lui faire prendre en
charge et l'ensemble de ces dispositions
nous permettent donc d'avoir un système
de retraite qui revient à l'équilibre
mais nous devons être particulièrement
vigilants pour que les différentes
mesures notre est adopté ne viennent pas
contrarié cet objectif il serait
extrêmement dommageable de mener une
réforme et finalement de ne pas avoir le
bénéfice d'un retour à l'équilibre et
donc d'une pérennisation du système la
deuxième chose que je souhaitais
souligner deuxième remarque fait tiens
compte plutôt ou on fait le lien avec un
certain nombre de propositions
d'amendements et évidemment il y a des
amendements et c'est normal dans un
débat parlementaire qui n'auront comme
seul objectif que de remettre en cause
l'essence même de la réforme que le
gouvernement ne pourra évidemment pas
soutenir évidemment qui vont permettre
d'avancer qui vont permettre de préciser
qui vont permettre de créer des droits
déposés par la quasi-totalité des
groupes et donc le gouvernement avec ce
cette prudence financière que j'ai
évoquée il y a un instant sera ouvert à
l'ensemble de ses propositions et je
tiens à la fois à le dire et à le
souligner parce que ce texte tel qu'il
sortira du Sénat tel qu'il sera voté je
l'espère par le Sénat devra ensuite
faire l'objet d'une discussion en
commission mixte paritaire et chaque
fois que nous pouvons l'améliorer pour
faciliter les consensus des convergences
et peut-être Gomm est parti des
différences ou des oppositions qui sont
exprimées je pense que nous aurons tout
à y gagner il y a une troisième remarque
enfin que je voulais faire avant de
terminer cette troisième remarque
concerne la complexité du sujet je crois
que chacune des interventions là aussi
sous Ling nous avons un système de
retraite qui est extrêmement complexe
complexe parce que morcelé avec 40 de
régime complexe parce que traversé par
des inégalités ou des injustices parfois
en tout cas des différences sur les
règles qui s'appliquent lorsque j'ai
évoqué dans mon propos liminaire la
question du chantier des droits
familiaux j'ai renvoyé aussi à la
question des pensions de réversion
imaginez que nous avons dans notre
système de retraite aujourd'hui 13
règles en matière de définition des
pensions de reversion imaginez que un
individu avec exactement la même
situation les mêmes revenus la même
situation familiale était lisible à une
pension de réversion dans un système et
pas dans l'autre parce que les
conditions de revenus ce sont pas les
mêmes d'un système de réversion à
l'autre cela relève des injustices et
des inégalités que sur lesquels nous
devrons travailler des styles le PLFSS
2024 et cette complexité ce matérialise
et je crois qu'il faut l'accepter sur
tous les points à l'instant madame la
sénatrice jasmin vous avez évoqué la
question des outre-mer et en réalité
dans votre propos on retrouve aussi
cette complexité là vous l'avez dit
vous-même à la tribune aujourd'hui les
assurés en outre-mer dans les
territoires d'outre-mer partent déjà à
la retraite avec un âge effectif qui est
supérieur au Nouvel Âge d'ouverture des
droits que nous souhaitons fixer à 64
ans vous l'avez rappelé pour la
Guadeloupe vous l'avez rappelé pour la
Martinique à chaque fois c'est super à
64 ans et cela ne relèvera la solution à
apporter à cela ne relèvera pas du texte
mais bien des chantiers que vous avez
évoqué en particulier la question de la
déclaration la question de la fiabilité
des systèmes d'information et la
capacité à garantir des carrières moins
âgées par contre je ne partage pas un
point de votre propos vous avez dit
obligé à travailler deux ans de plus va
les mettre en difficulté en non le
relèvement de l'âge pour les raisons que
vous avez évoqué qui sont de mauvaises
raisons en réalité parce que la
situation telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui s'explique par de mauvaises
raisons en tout cas que nous devons
combattre collectivement mais le
relèvement de l'âge légal ne sera pas
mordant pour reprendre cette expression
qu'on utilise souvent pour les assurants
outre-mer dans la mesure où là
effectivement 64 ans par contre ce qui
est mort dans et ce qui est générateur
de petites pensions d'outre-mer c'est le
relèvement de la durée de cotisation tel
qu'il avait été voté en 2013 et que nos
accélérons avec cette réforme mais il y
a de nombreux chantiers derrière ce que
vous avez évoqué qu'il nous faut ouvrir
je pense par exemple un chantier qui
dépasse très largement le cadre de spel
FSS puisqu'il dépend des seuls
partenaires sociaux mais en Guadeloupe
et à la Réunion les salariés du secteur
agricole et je dis bien les salariés pas
les indépendants pas les exploitants ne
sont pas couverts par la Bretagne
complémentaire agirco alors que partout
ailleurs sur le territoire national la
retraite la complémentaire agir Carco
concerne aussi les salariés du secteur
agricole c'est une décision qui relève
des partenaires sociaux et c'est
l'examen de cette réforme qui est à
titre personnel m'a permis de de la même
manière que nous pourrons avancer sur
les questions relatives à la retraite à
Mayotte ou la situation appelle des
réponses différentes dans la mesure où
le système de retraite n'est obligatoire
que depuis 1987 et que les 2500 ou 2600
assuré pensionnés aujourd'hui à Mayotte
ont une retraite moyenne de 287 euros
mais cette retraite moyenne très basse
s'explique aussi par le fait que leur
cotisations telles que déclarés tels que
transmises mais s’élève qu'à 9 années 9
années de cotisations ce qui explique
cette difficulté à avoir des retraites
plus importantes deuxième sujet
d'illustration de la complexité la
question de la revalorisation des
pensions minimales et je saisis cette
première intervention avant l'examen des
articles la pension minimale ça vient
l'article 10 je ne doute pas que nous y
serons rapidement et que nous pourrons
apporter toutes toutes les réponses mais
ça dépend ce qu'on appellera rapidement
madame Lubin ça peut être quelques jours
ou quelques heures
mais pour le pour revenir à ce sujet qui
est sérieux quel est l'engagement qui a
pris le président de la République
pendant la campagne c'est de garantir un
salarié qui a une carrière complète
rémunérée au niveau du SMIC le fait
d'atteindre 85% du SMIC net au moment de
son départ à la retraite
la difficulté première qu'il faut
souligner nous sommes sur un modèle
cible d'un salarié qui toute sa carrière
aurait cotisé en étant rémunéré au SMIC
évidemment que dans la vraie vie si je
puis dire certains gagnent un peu plus
un moment d'autres peuvent
malheureusement gagner un peu moins mais
nous avons cet objectif cible mais
surtout comment est-ce que ça va se
traduire ça va se traduire par ça a été
dit par Monsieur le Sénateur à lévrier
ça va se traduire par le fait que parmi
les 17 millions de retraités actuels un
million 8 je le répète un million 8 dès
le mois de septembre vers l'environ leur
pension revalorisées avec une
revalorisation en fonction du nombre de
trimestres cotisés il s'agit du myco
majoré que nous augmentons pour les
retraités actuels avec une
revalorisation qui va varier d'une
vingtaine pour les plus bases jusqu'à
100 euros et avec 50% d'entre eux 900
000 courront une revalorisation comprise
entre 70 et 100 euros nous parlons de
retraités qui ont des petites retraites
de 800 de 900 de 1000 euros et pour
lesquels une revalorisation de 70 à 100
euros est loin d'être négligeable ça ne
les rendra pas riches personne ne le dit
l'inverse
c'est loin d'être négligeable et cette
revalorisation va concerner à la fois
ceux qui ont une carrière complète à
temps plein mais aussi ceux qu'on a une
carrière complète à temps partiel mais
avec un principe de progratisation qui
s'applique c'est le nombre de trimestres
cotisés qui va un site permettre d'y
arriver et donc c'est une première
valorisation et pour les retraités
nouveaux je l'ai dit tout à l'heure nous
en avons 800000 par an à peu près 200
000 auront une pension revalorisée entre
25 et 100 euros nous procédons un peu
différemment puisqu'il s'agit du
relèvement du minimum contributif de
base de 25 euros et du minimum
contributif majoré de 75 euros ce qui
explique que les répartitions sont un
peu différentes et là où la complexité
vient trouver un relief particulier
c'est que nous avons à peu près 40 000
de ces 200 000 retraités qui vont passer
le cap des 1200 euros
nous en avons 40 000 qui vont bénéficier
de leur valorisation maximum c'est à
dire 100 euros mais ce ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes ce ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes parce que tout le
monde ne parle pas du même niveau de
retraite et nous savons c'est l'exercice
de transparence auquel nous sommes
livrés que pour la première génération
celle de 1962
le passage du cap de 1200 euros sera à
la fois justifié par la revalorisation
mais aussi par les phénomènes
d'indexation par contre ce que nous
savons aussi c'est qu'entre la
génération 62 et la génération 1972 qui
partira à la retraite 10 ans plus tard
le nombre de ceux qui passeront le cap
des 85% du SMIC du simple fait de la
réforme va être multiplié par 4 et
globalement ce que je répète ce sont 200
000 retraités avec des petites pensions
qui auront grâce à cette pension
minimale une retraite meilleure que sont
la mise en oeuvre de la réforme enfin je
termine par un dernier point
pour simplement dire en écho aux
interventions sur la question des
seigneurs sur la question de la qualité
de vie au travail des conditions de
travail la question du dialogue social
pour dire que cette réforme des
retraites telles que nous nous la
présentons mais évidemment pas un
aboutissement c'est un jalon c'est un
jalon qui est la seule échelle à
l'échelle de ce seul quinquennat il y a
un prêt des dispositions sur la
participation intéressement dans le
cadre de la loi pouvoir d'achat de
juillet dernier via après la réforme du
marché du travail et de l'assurance
chômage et vient avant un texte dont la
première ministre a annoncé qu'il sera
présenté au Parlement avant l'été en
particulier ici au Sénat puisque je
crois qu'au mois de septembre vous ferai
occupé à d'autres activités pour une
partie d'entre vous en tout cas et ce
texte autour de l'emploi du travail et
de l'insertion va permettre d'aborder
des sujets extrêmement de donner suite à
l'accor national interprofessionnel
entre les partenaires sociaux sur le
partage de la valeur de conforter ce que
nous avons fait en matière
d'apprentissage de formation continue de
formation professionnelle de donner
suite du travail qui ont été évoqués la
tribune autour des questions de qualité
de vie de conditions de travail et je
fais un chantier pardonnez-moi pour
certains stand narcissique très
personnel de la lutte contre les
accidents gravent et mortels au travail
nous avons 650 personnes chaque année
qui me retravaillent nous en avons 9600
qui connaissent un accident du travail
leur laissant une forme d'incapacité
permanente au moins supérieur à 10% et
donc ce sont des des chantiers que nous
devons conforter et des priorités que
nous devons nous donner et puis nous
aurons aussi des choses sur la
démocratie dans l'entreprise parce que à
l'heure où les collectifs de travail
sont physiquement éparpillés par le
télétravail par le travail entière lieu
par le travail à distance faire en sorte
que la démocratie puisse s'exprimer
différemment et que l'accès à
l'information soit aussi améliorée dans
ce cadre nouveau ça fait partie de ces
priorités et je ne doute pas aussi qu'un
certain nombre de sujets que nous aurons
à évoquer dans le cadre de nos débats et
qui peut-être n'auront qu'un lien ténu
avec la forme qui a cette réforme c'est
à dire un bel effet SS pourront le cas
échéant trouver la place dans ce projet
de loi pour l'emploi
un travail d'insertion c'est vrai autour
du travail des seniors et puis c'est
vrai pour d'autres sujets qui eux
devront certainement trouver un débouché
ailleurs j'en termine par là
véritablement le président Marseille a
évoqué tout à l'heure la volonté de
sénateurs et de sénatrice de son groupe
de priver les parents qui se voient
retirer définitivement l'autorité
parentale de la majoration de 10% c'est
un objectif auquel je souscris mais nous
savons aussi que d'une part pour une
part c'est déjà prévu et que d'autre
part ça s'apparente plutôt en termes de
projection à une peine complémentaire
que les juges pourraient prononcer à
l'occasion de la condamnation de
violence sur les enfants et dès lors que
nous sommes dans le schéma d'une peine
complémentaire et qui s'ajouterait
j'imagine je ne suis pas juriste code
pénal ça ne relève pas véritablement
d'un pays FSS mais plutôt de texte sur
la justice et sur la capacité Corré la
justice à sanctionner par ses peines
complémentaires des parents qui dès lors
qu'ils sont coupables de violence sur
les enfants peuvent être qualifiés de
parents indiens et donc nous allons
affronter ces débats je crois en ayant
en tête cette complexité en ayant en
tête la difficulté qu'il y a parfois a
bien articuler les mesures entre les
différents textes et les différentes
priorités mais je ne doute pas que dans
quelques jours pour ne pas aller trop
vite et ne pas faire preuve d'impatience
nous puissions à l'issue de ces débats
non seulement avoir examiné en tout cas
c'est le souhait du gouvernement
l'ensemble des dispositions et faire en
sorte que le texte soumis ensuite à la
commission mixte paritaire soit un texte
amélioré en tout cas merci à toutes et à
tous pour vos interventions
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
mes chers
je rappelle que notre prochaine séance
sera demain matin à 9h30 pour la
discussion de la motion référendaire la
séance est donc levée
voilà un retour en salle des conférences
sur le plateau de Public Sénat installé
de façon extraordinaire au milieu de
cette salle qui juste l'hémicycle vous
avez pu suivre sur notre antenne en
direct et en intégralité la toute
première journée de l'examen de la
réforme des retraites en séance au Sénat
sur un total qui va s'étaler jusqu'au 12
mars de 11 jours au total d'examen vous
allez tout pouvoir suivre sur notre
antenne pour en parler on va retrouver
notre journaliste Audrey vettaz bonjour
Audrey vous êtes en tribune de presse du
Sénat on peut le dire le ton cette
première journée au Sénat il est bien
différent de celui de l'Assemblée
nationale oui Quentin plusieurs heures
viennent de s'écouler plusieurs heures
de discussion et je vous le confirme les
échanges ont été beaucoup plus courtois
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale pas de
débordement car les sénateurs tout
étiquettes politiques confondues veulent
débattre sur le fond on a quand même
senti cet après-midi de la tension ici
au Sénat et je peux vous dire que c'est
peu courant pour un texte budgétaire
comme celui-ci d'habitude on a conserver
d'abord une sorte de pas de deux entre
la majorité sénatoriale de droite et le
gouvernement qui a besoin de faire voter
sa réforme la majorité sénatoriale qui
est en faveur de l'allongement de l'âge
de départ en retraite pour équilibrer le
système le Sénat et donc en position de
force alors le gouvernement a multiplié
les mains tendues toute l'après-midi
avec un objectif faire voter la réforme
dans 11 jours écouter
j'adresse un appel engageons-nous dans
ce débat sans faux-semblant et sans
posture politique un appel au compromis
entre la majorité sénatorial qui incarne
la volonté d'une réforme et la majorité
présidentielle qui porte la
responsabilité de la réforme un appel à
la cohérence la majorité sénatoriale a
tant voulu cette réforme et la voté de
nombreuses fois un appel à la
responsabilité augmenter les impôts pour
financer les retraites ce n'est pas la
bonne solution car à la fin il y en a
toujours un qui paye et celui-ci
s'appelle le contribuable j'adresse donc
cet appel au Sénat discutons amendons
des bâtons mais à la fin votons ce texte
votons-le car garantir aux Français que
leur retraite seront payées n'est ni de
droite ni du centre ni de gauche c'est
tout simplement
œuvré pour l'intérêt général
les sénateurs de la droite et du centre
en nous aussi profité pour rappeler que
cela fait plusieurs années qu'il vote un
amendement dans le budget de la Sécurité
sociale amendement pour allonger l'âge
de départ en retraite à 64 ans et que
chaque année il est retoqué par le
gouvernement écouter René Paul Savary
sénateur LR il est en charge de la
branche vieillesse et spécialiste de ce
dossier
alors pourquoi pourquoi le gouvernement
n'a-t-il donc pas jugé bon de se rallier
dès 2018 au recommandations du Sénat la
pente serait moins raide le déficit
moins abyssal
que perdu que de temps perdu néanmoins
néanmoins l'effet sont là
messieurs les ministres il n'est jamais
trop tard pour bien faire
alors je voulais dire alors je vous l'ai
dit les échanges ont été plus courtois
ici déjà parce que c'est l'habitude de
la chambre haute les ébats ils sont en
général plus feutrés mais aussi parce
que les sénateurs ont en mémoire le
fiasco on peut le dire des débats à
l'Assemblée nationale et le fait que les
Français et les syndicalistes ont été
très déçus d'être privés de débat sur le
fond ça n'a pas empêché les moments
d'intensité écoutez l'intervention de
Bruno Retailleau le chef de fil a des
républicains au Sénat
j'entends que vous voulez voter
l'article 7 ça signifie monsieur le
Président ça signifie donc que le 8 le 9
le 10 les petites retraites la validité
la question notamment des travailleurs
handicapés toutes ces questions-là ne
mériteraient pas un débat ne mériterait
pas un vote et bien si nous voulons
aller au bout du texte nous le devons
pour les Français et pour nous c'est un
devoir
merci
une intervention ponctuée de bravo Bruno
quand il est retourné s'asseoir dans son
camp la droite qui veut donc aller
jusqu'au bout du texte jusqu'à l'article
20 et voter ce texte la gauche elle
voudrait voter l'article 7 celui sur
l'allongement de l'âge de départ en
retraite elle veut qu'il y a un vote car
elle veut que les sénateurs disent qui
est pour et qui est contre ce point il
va falloir aller vite car il y a plus de
1400 amendements déposés rien que sur
l'article 7 mais les sénateurs de gauche
refusent qu'on les accuse de faire de
l'obstruction parlementaire comme a pu
le faire le groupe la France insoumise à
l'Assemblée écouter
qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée nationale
s'est passé à l'Assemblée nationale on
est au Sénat on va repartir sur des
bases saines je pense que il faut
arrêter et si vous souhaitez que le
débat se passe bien je pense qu'il faut
arrêter avec ces provocations voilà je
pense que ça c'est des choses qu'il
fallait peut-être peut-être appeler
je rappelle qu'il n'y a pas de groupe
LFI au Sénat les groupes de gauche se
sont les communistes les socialistes et
les écologistes voilà Quentin pour
l'essentiel de ces échanges le mot
d'ordre c'est donc feutré mais intense
merci merci Audrey Taz pour se récap
très complète cette première journée
d'examen ici au sein de la réforme des
retraites pour en parler j'ai accueilli
ici ils avaient Doisneau bonjour vous
êtes la rapporteur général du budget de
la Sécurité sociale au Sénat alors un
mot sur l'ambiance on était attentif à
savoir comment est-ce que ça l'espace et
le ton des débats qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez il est à la hauteur des exigences
des Français en matière
en l'occurrence il est à la hauteur de
ce qu'on attendait du Sénat c'est à dire
un débat serein passionné bien sûr
passionnant je l'espère et en tout cas
quelque chose qui va apporter des
réponses à l'ensemble des Françaises et
des Français et je pense pouvoir dire
que chez les opposants comme chez les
partisans du texte et bien on a pu
sentir l'envie de débattre et d'aller à
ses lois dans le texte et voir de le
voter il y a quand même eu deux motions
qui ont été examinées elles ont été
déposées par la gauche de l'hémicycle
ici au Sénat elle dénonce l'usage du
47,1 cet article de la Constitution qui
vient contraindre la durée des débats
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ces
sénateurs de gauche qui ont la sensation
que l'on les empêche d'aller au bout de
tout ce qu'il faudrait avoir comme jour
d'examen autour de ce texte mais étant
surpris en fait de ces émotions non bien
sûr comme celle de the matin qui sera
discuté la motion référendaire c'est
c'est tout à fait normal et très
franchement nous étendu on sait aussi en
réalité donc qu'est-ce que je en fait il
faut évidemment plein de bonnes raisons
pour poser ses motions et le 47 1 est
une des raisons est-ce que pour autant
il va raccourcir le débat alors qu'on a
plus de 100 heures de comment de
proposer ici au Sénat et que les
week-ends
[Musique]
mais donc dans un cadre budgétaire
contraint il ira vers vous il vous il
prendra cette main tendue qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé de ces notamment à la
fin de la discussion générale et bien
écoutez on a travaillé toute la semaine
dernière avec le rapporteur de branches
avec la présidente de la commission et
avec le cabinet du ministre on a mis
avec l'exécutif de la semaine dernière
sur la mesure mais oui tout à fait parce
que nous n'allions pas improviser en
fait et en commission des affaires
sociales et dans l'hémicycle l'ensemble
des mesures que sur lesquelles nous
étions attachés donc nous avons pu y
travailler nous n'avons pas été d'accord
voilà le premier jour mais nous avons
travaillé et les uns et les autres à
trouver le compromis comme l'a dit
d'ailleurs le ministre Gabriel Attal on
préfère le compromis plutôt que voilà
d'être
mis devant le fait accompli je crois me
rappeler de ses propos et je suis assez
dans l'idée que justement tout se
prépare pour justement parce que
l'improvisation elle est elle est pas
bonne en général on va aller sur le fond
des mesures dans un instant mais d'abord
un dernier mot sur la forme et sur ce
chiffre qui est un peu le chiffre du
jour on peut le dire c'est 4700
amendements qui ont été déposés sur le
total alors on verra combien sont
recevables il y aura peut-être ensuite
certains moments qui vont tomber car ils
sont jugés ils recevables ils créeront
de la dépense et ils ne pourront pas
être examinés dans l'hémicycle mais
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce chiffre
11 jours d'examens enfin il y en aura
moins sur les articles et les
amendements et 4700 ça va être possible
d'aller au bout du texte écoutez on
s'imaginait avoir beaucoup d'amendements
on se disait 4000 5000 finalement notre
pronostic est atteint en quelque sorte
maintenant il y a beaucoup de
d'amendements qui se ressemblent donc
qui seront traités ensemble qui pourrait
tomber tous ensemble alors allons-y
allons sur notamment ce que la droite et
le centre a décidé de porter comme
amendement en commission ce sont des
mesures en faveur on peut le dire de
l'emploi des seniors ou encore des
femmes qui ont au moins un enfant on
pense par exemple à ce CDI senior pour
les personnes de plus de 60 ans qui
n'auront pas de cotisation famille à
payer ou encore cette surcote pour les
mères sur les trimestres cotisés après
63 ans qu'est-ce que vous dites avec ces
deux la première mesure que je viens
d'évoquer elles ont beaucoup de chance
de passer avec l'accord de du
gouvernement c'est justement parmi ces
mesures que vous aviez un petit peu
topées en avance avec l'exécutif oui
mais pas que pas que on avait une liste
de courses si je puis dire et c'était
normal qu'on ait des exigences alors que
le texte arrivait même avec un déficit
en quelque sorte mais un défi qui était
créé par quelques promesses qui ont été
donnés par la première ministre à
l'Assemblée nationale alors que
l'Assemblée nationale n'a même pas
débattu donc ces premières mesures alors
sur les seniors nous étions attachés à
l'Union centriste à l'index des seniors
mais pour les entreprises
le gouvernement par ailleurs nous avons
dit mais nous nous voulons aussi un CDI
de fin de carrière qui permettent de
maintenir le Seigneur dans l'entreprise
ou en tout cas d'embaucher des seigneurs
dans l'entreprise et ça ça nous semble
tout à fait favorable
qui est pas bon en ce moment des
seigneurs il est pas bon et c'est
amélioré mais on sait aussi qu'une
réforme qui repousse l'âge de départ à
la retraite augmente le nombre le
Seigneur dans les entreprises assez vu
aux dernières réformes sur les retraites
donc je veux dire que c'était une boîte
à outils que l'on met en place l'index
il est important aussi parce que
certains nous disent oui mais ça va
donner quoi finalement sans bonus malus
le bonus malus on en reparlera quand on
aura une loi de travail mais qu'est-ce
que ça va donner de plus et bien en tout
cas de la transparence que fait
l'entreprise est-elle vertueuse
vis-à-vis des seigneurs de son
entreprise est-ce qu'elle peut dire
qu'elle s'améliore d'année en année
c'est important un mot également sur
cette surcote on explique le mécanisme
si la personne qui a eu un enfant ou
plusieurs continue de travailler après
63 ans elle pourra comme cela avoir des
bonifs un bonus sur sur sa pension c'est
ça qui va se jouer avec cette surcote
écoutez le Sénat essayait de négocier
quelque chose pour prendre en compte
c'est majoration de durée d'assurance
les MDA c'est-à-dire cette trimestre que
sur tous les femmes acquères parce
qu'elles sont elles ont elles ont une
maternité parce que elles ont adopté ou
parce que elles ont éduqué leurs enfants
quelquefois elles peuvent partager
d'ailleurs ces quatre trimestres dans le
privé avec leur conjoint et puis c'est
aussi d'autres MDA qui sont acquises
pour élever un enfant handicapé par
exemple bon je peux pas tout nommer ce
soir
on fera le débat mais dès lors que vous
repoussez l'âge de départ la retraite
les femmes se trouvaient pénalisées et
donc nous avons voulu trouver une
solution il était difficile d'avoir un
amendement qui soit accepté que sur les
femmes parce que la Cour européenne nous
aurait finalement retoqué
cette volonté cette ambition d'aider les
femmes et donc nous avons essayé de
trouver un autre chemin et la surcote et
finalement le résultat de de cette
négociation avec le gouvernement et bien
merci merci pour toutes ces explications
au micro de Public Sénat et vous
reviendrez et je l'imagine j'espère nous
expliquer encore d'autres détails dans
cet examen qui va se poursuivre jusqu'au
12 mars on va parler d'un des autres
moments forts de cette séance avec ce
moment où la gauche a tenté de la
nouveauté des motions afin et bien de
rejeter ce texte avant même à la fin de
la discussion générale on va retrouver
Audrey vettaz en tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle Audrey on peut le dire c'est
un des moments où il y a eu le plus de
tension oui la discussion générale a été
entrecoupée par le dépôt de motion de la
part de la gauche vous l'avez dit la
première de la part du groupe communiste
la seconde de la part du groupe
socialiste émotion ce sont des outils
dans les parlementaires disposent pour
s'opposer d'emblée au texte avant même
le début de l'examen des articles et de
leurs amendements en fait les groupes de
gauche estiment que la forme choisie par
le gouvernement budgétaire avec un
calendrier restreint n'est pas la bonne
pour un texte qui concerne autant les
Français et leur avenir je précise tout
de même que le gouvernement peut le
faire la Constitution lui autorise mais
pour la gauche c'est un coup de force
démocratique les mots sont forts
allez-vous aujourd'hui accompagner le
gouvernement et Monsieur Macron dans un
coup de force contre le Parlement qui si
le texte venait à être adopté par la
seule CMP voir pire par des ordonnances
inusitées sans habilitation ni
ratification relèverait d'un coup d'État
feutré contre les institutions de la
République ce texte donc est contraire à
la Constitution car il s'attaque à des
principes de solidarité au cœur de notre
République il est contraire à la
Constitution car il manipule la
Constitution pour contraindre le
Parlement le soumettre ne laissons pas
mes chers collègues au Conseil
constitutionnel le soin de censurer ce
projet de loi
clairement toi nous engagements
politiques que le Parlement doit être
respecté pour que la démocratie le soit
ces deux motions ont été rejetées par le
Sénat à majorité de droite mais ce n'est
pas fini car une motion référendaire
cette fois-ci porter par les groupes de
gauche a été enregistré tout à l'heure
elle doit être débattue demain matin en
séance à partir de 9h30 avec cette
motion les groupes de gauche demandent
au président de la République de
convoquer un référendum pour demander
leur avis aux français puisque ce texte
les concerne rendez-vous donc demain
Quentin sur notre antenne évidemment
pour savoir si cette motion référendaire
a été acceptée ou non par le Sénat
rendez-vous est pris merci Audrey pour
toutes ces explications et bien sûr vous
suivrez sur notre antenne comme vous
l'avez fait en intégralité depuis 14h30
ces débats demain autour de la motion
référendaire alors pour en parler j'ai
accueille ici et il y a un assessi
bonsoir à vous bonsoir vous êtes la
présidente du groupe communiste ici à la
Chambre haute un mot déjà sur le rejet
de ces deux motions que vous aviez
déposées alors avec vos collègues
écologistes mais que vous souteniez on a
entendu des prises de parole de votre
groupe et c'était quoi l'idée c'était de
dire que notamment l'article 47 ans qui
est utilisé pour la procédure et qui
contraint le temps de débat c'est
quelque chose qui est anti-démocratique
c'est cela
en fait avec ces notions nous avons
voulu mettre en évidence un certain
nombre d'éléments qui nous font penser
que le véhicule qui a été choisi le 47
ans n'est pas n'est pas le bon
contraindre le temps du débat sur un
texte aussi important nous semble quand
même assez
anti-démocratique je le dis nous ne
sommes pas les seuls à le dire puisque
plusieurs constitutionnalistes aussi et
nous microso Benjamin Morel etc même
pierre
rozanvallonciers là on est sur une
société on est sur une réforme sociétale
vous savez au tout début de l'annonce de
cette réforme il y a eu trois options
qui ont été mises sur la table il y
avait celle d'un amendement dans le
cadre du projet loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale donc tous les auteurs
il y avait l'idée d'un projet de loi
dédié et au dernier moment est arrivé
donc dernière option d'un projet de loi
de financement mais c'est ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas le cadre ce n'est pas le
cas pour examiner d'une loi sur les
retraites et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous essayons et nous
essaierons encore dans le débat qui va
qui va continuer dès demain à démontrer
à la fois sur le fond et sur la forme en
quoi cette réforme est mauvaise et en
quoi ce véhicule n'est pas adapté à tel
texte c'est votre deuxième idée demain
avec cette motion référendaire c'est de
provoquer un réforme un référendum et
que les Français puissent se prononcer
par oui ou par non sur une sur une sur
une informe de retraite c'est ça
je vais vous dire quelque chose en fait
demain 9h30 mais le président de la
République alors qu'il était aussi
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
pendant la campagne a dit lui-même
qu'il ouvrait la possibilité à
l'organisation d'un référendum sur sur
les retraites donc moi je ne fais que
dire chiche visiblement 90% des actifs
qui sont contre cette réforme plus de
60% des Français qui le sont il serait
peut-être intéressant que les Français
puissent directement dire
au gouvernement oui ou non je pense que
il y a une certaine fébrilité qui
parcourt les rendus du gouvernement
comme d'ailleurs de la de la droite dans
sa diversité pourquoi parce que je pense
que pour eux ils décident que c'est trop
tard pour organiser un référendum parce
que selon eux ce serait la légitimité du
président de la République qui se
retrouverait au centre des débats
pendant la campagne et du référendum de
l'éventualité je dis bien de
l'éventualité d'un référendum et je
pense que il n'a comme ils vivent dans
une bulle c'est qu'ils n'ont pas écouté
ce qui montait dans le pays sur cette
réforme et bien évidemment
peut concevoir qu'il décide aujourd'hui
que c'est trop tard voilà mais il aurait
fallu un référendum et donc nous
insistons quand même avec cette motion
référendum pour qu'il y a un référendum
et je dois vous dire que les choses ne
sont pas terminées parce qu'on pourrait
imaginer aussi même après l'adoption
scandaleuse de ce texte par 14
parlementaires en CMP on pourrait
imaginer l'organisation d'un référendum
initiative partagée pourquoi pas un mot
sur ce chiffre c'est un peu le chiffre
du jour qu'on a découvert ce matin plus
de 4700 amendements je crois qu'il y en
a plus de 3300 qui viennent de la gauche
vous dites quoi c'est une forme
d'obstruction pour aussi se garder la
possibilité de ne jamais aller au bout
de l'examen du texte c'est ça la
stratégie de la gauche
la stratégie de la gauche c'est le débat
vous voulez examiner l'article 7 sur par
exemple bien évidemment l'article 7
c'est le coeur du réacteur mais on veut
aussi débattre de l'article linéaire du
premier enfin tous les articles
pratiquement tous les articles de ce
texte sont importants d'où effectivement
notre refus qu'il a été qu'il ait été
inscrit dans dans le véhicule du 47 ans
on a le temps de débattre nous nous
avons deux objectifs et c'est ce sur
quoi nous nous sommes mis d'accord avec
les autres présidents des groupes de
gauche et nos sénatrices et nos
sénateurs c'est un débattre de tous les
articles de l'article 7 avoir un débat
de fond donc il faut déposer des
amendements
que cet article 7 soit soumis au vote du
Sénat parce que nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyens ont droit de savoir qui est
pour l'allongement de la durée de de
l'allongement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite donc ils sont ils ont Julien
ils sont c'est tout à fait normal qu'ils
le sachent et de continuer ensuite le
débat parce qu'il y a des il y a des
articles intéressants
notre stratégie
notre stratégie c'est de débattre sur le
fond et puis si on n'a pas terminé
dimanche soir à minuit on n'a pas
terminé dimanche soir à minuit voilà un
mot sur les amendements voulus par la
droite et le centre ils vise et bien
améliorer le texte en faveur de l'emploi
des seniors ou encore pour les femmes
qui ont eu des enfants on pense à ce CDI
pour les seniors à cette surcote pour
les mères avec des trimestres cotisés
après 63 ans qu'est-ce que vous dites à
la droite et le centre toutes ces
mesures vous les voter NON d'abord il
faudrait que je vois ces abandons mais
j'ai entendu monsieur Savary qui est un
des rapporteurs sur ce texte et en fait
il dit il dit précisément que avec ses
amendes la droite veut adoucir le texte
ce qui veut bien dire quand même au
départ ce texte est d'une dureté sans
nom
avec aussi des gens qui sont contre la
réforme oui sans doute mais voilà le
point de départ c'est quoi c'est cette
réforme ne va pas et ils essayent de
trouver des petites solutions qui ne
sont pas sincèrement je n'ai pas vu les
amendements donc je n'en parle pas mais
c'est des petits arrangements entre amis
c'est des petits arrangements en famille
à l'évidence
ça ne fait pas l'unanimité ou ça des
groupes LR et centrices donc on verra là
aussi le débat va éclairer me
semble-t-il les sénatrices les sénateurs
mais aussi les gens arrivent à la fin de
cette interview j'ai une dernière
question il y a cette journée de
mobilisation qui se profile le 7 mars
c'est mardi qu'est-ce que vous prévoyez
il y aura-t-il quelque chose de
particulier de la part des des
communistes en séance pour se faire les
courses de cette mobilisation dans la
rue de l'intersyndicale je ne vais pas
vous dévoiler voilà l'essentiel
l'essentiel pour nous c'est de d'être
utile au mouvement social c'est ça c'est
être utile s'il y a 3 millions de
personnes dans les rues je peux vous
dire que ça va changer la donne du débat
après que nous ayons des initiatives
spécifiques ici ou pas je crois que
c'est pas ça qui intéresse
fondamentalement les gens ce que veulent
les gens c'est le retrait de ce texte
donc on participera à notre façon
et c'est pour ça que je dis est utile à
notre façon à cette exigence populaire
comment communique la mobilisation
sociale la mobilisation par l'Inter
syndical et la mobilisation au Parlement
est-ce que ça communique les
dans la société française
je ne parlerai pas pour les autres sont
des militantes et des militants depuis
plus de d'un mois nous sommes toutes et
tous en meeting à travers la France donc
le pouls le pouls du peuple de France on
le connaît
voilà on le connaît on fait tous des
meetings et donc on connaît bien le la
l'exigence donc qui est portée par les
gens de retirer ce texte et bien merci
merci
pour cette réaction à notre micro
présidente du groupe communiste au Sénat
en suivra bien sûr la discussion autour
de la motion référendaire demain matin à
9h30 sur l'antenne de Public Sénat
Public Sénat qui se mobilise notamment
avec ce studio installé au coeur de la
salle des conférences du Sénat pour vous
faire vivre au plus près les débats
autour de la réforme des retraites
jusqu'au 12 mars min